have to have special Astronaut training
you don't have to have been preparing
for this all your life though wallyfunk
seems to be in great shape and she
certainly has great energy there are
some height requirements there are some
weight requirements they need to get up
those seven flights of stairs to the
crew capsule in a matter of 90 seconds
they need to be able to zip up into a
flight suit but that's basically it
they've gone through two days of
training 14 hours all together some
demos some simulation some emergency
simulations but the idea is that just
anyone ultimately will be able to take
this ride and some Keen I make that one
two three four crew members in that camp
show now Jeff Bezos the first to walk in
you can just about see wallyfunk through
that window I understand it these
windows are the largest windows that
have been into oh yes because let's be
clear about this for any tourists going
into space going past the common line
you want two things you want that
experience of zero gravity and you want
to be able to experience that full View
right curvature of the earth and that's
what that design is for I had the
immense privilege John of talking to the
late Michael Collins about the windows
uh in orbit and what you could see and
the improvements were made by astronauts
screaming from the six inch porthole
that Alan Shepard had in 1961 and they
were so angry Gus Grissom had a window
carved into his Liberty capsule as well
uh Tim stanovic with us as well with
Bloomberg kick quick take Tim what do
you see
hey good morning from West Texas well
the sun is just Rising here in Van Horn
it's about 69 70 degrees winds about
seven miles an hour it's a cool morning
here and what I see are a lot of people
who are excited about what's going on
today look locals this they're telling
me that this is the biggest thing that's
happened in their Decades of living here
they're certainly excited about it the
town has only 2 000 people but also
tourists who are totally unaffiliated
with blue origin people who are just
interested to see what's happening as
I've been sitting here getting set up
for the last hour guys several people
have stopped just to ask me Hey where's
the best place to watch this someone
came over to my car and said he flew in
all the way from New York City just to
watch this so this is the second new
origin launch he has seen so it's
certainly doing that job that Jeff Bezos
is hoping it's doing of inspiring people
Tim you're a student of this what is the
significance in we've seen the fumes off
the rocket of liquid oxygen and liquid
hydrogen as well I mean it's very
traditional rocketry isn't it
yeah what's interesting about this is
that technology actually hasn't changed
in terms of propulsion significantly in
many many years there are a lot of
similarities between this and earlier
types of engines that have been
developed at the same time though what
we are seeing is a lot of uh progress in
terms of reusability that is the key
Innovation here this particular stack
the capsule in the booster has already
been flown twice and tested twice this
is the specific one that is used for
space is this one that is used for for
Taurus I should say in addition to that
guys what we're also seeing right now
are the final checks that they are going
through as they do get prepared for
flight fully autonomous capsule here any
evaluations that take place on board
whatsoever Tim
I think we've lost the sound over there
to Tim Tom just moments away in the next
couple of minutes on my screen T-minus
25 in the next couple of minutes T minus
24 I think we expect that hatch to close
so South China's attention of what
happens with rocketry and this is uh
other astronauts have said uh it's a
stick of dynamite putting a capsule up
62 miles the capsule can unhinge from
the rocket at any time uh John this is a
decision made on the ground not by Mr
Bezos and the other three Travelers but
from a safety standpoint you can bring
the capsule apart Emily Chang describe
the festivities last night I saw a video
of Miss Chang diving for the food as Mr
Bezos prepared it
yes Tom we got a surprise visitor
yesterday afternoon Jeff Bezos and his
brother showed up bearing the gift of
food which nobody here in the middle of
the desert will turn down uh he was
carrying his mother's favorite recipe
chicken thighs Black Eyed Peas mac and
cheese I have to say it was pretty good
he even gave us the recipe how generous
of him didn't take too many questions
but said he was excited still excited
that is the sentiment he has echoed all
along we haven't caught a bit or even a
sense of nerves uh uh you know who knows
if that's changed now that he is
officially on board John that dinner's
house friendly I just hope they have
Tang on board I just you just want to
know if you can get served alcohol on
this trip Tom no that's what you're
trying no that always that awaits other
flights as well but I I do hope like the
Gemini missions that there's Tang on
board that would be important Emily as
we await this catch this hatch to be
closed I just wonder from your
perspective if you know the evaluations
that need to take place by the crew
members do they literally just sit there
and do nothing we've been told all it's
fully autonomous what do they have to do
from here
they got to strap themselves in John and
when they're told to unstrap they
unbuckle and they get a 30 second
warning from Mission Control when
they're supposed to buckle back up and
come back down as I said it's it's
pretty minimal obstruction minimal
training uh the the the pressure though
as we understand it as they accelerate
up into the air and get up to Mach three
or three times the speed of sound
they'll feel three times the force of
gravity so basically imagine your body
weight times three pressing down on you
you'll be pushed down uh back into the
seat but as they continue upward into
the air that weight will lighten until
they get to zero G's that three to four
minutes of weightlessness that Jeff
Bezos that Wally Funk
have been waiting for all their lives
and it'll be a quick trip it'll be
buckle up just a couple of minutes later
and then they're on their way back down
it'll all depend on those parachutes
that'll carry the crew capsule back down
to earth slow it down down and then as
soon as they get to about 60 miles above
ground the Retro thrust systems as it
calls will kick in it's basically a
cushion of air that will cushion the
crew capsule as it lands hopefully
safely in a cloud of desert dust just a
final check of the harnesses here now
Tom that hatch is about to be closed and
then it's T-minus 22.
it is T-minus 22 and John you know again
I'm going to go back to all that we have
experienced some Mercury through Gemini
Apollo and all this huge space shuttle
tragedy that was just so difficult I'm
going to just state that within the
happy talk and you know pork and beans
and all that is a lot of risk there's
always risk to space flight and we'll
have to watch the launch as it goes
through those first steps there's a key
point six or seven minutes into excuse
me three minutes into it where they
reach the physics of the greatest
tension Tom just checking in the
astronauts let's take a listen and see
if we can hear what's going on
clear thanks for everything Sarah we
appreciate it
it's my honor and my pleasure
all right astronauts we are at T minus
21 minutes and Counting as we proceed
I'll keep you updated for now just sit
back and relax
Tom just ahead of take off the hatch
about to be closed the harnesses have
been checked the communication between
the astronauts is almost complete Tom it
is T-minus 21. uh it's and again they've
got to reuse capsule reuse this and and
that Tim stenovic I believe is still
where this Tim talked to us about the 14
previous flights of blue origin
yeah this is uh something that they've
been testing for years the new Shepherd
um part of the testing guys included
what happens during a disaster so they
had three separate tests uh specifically
just to show what happens during a
disaster and they were able to
successfully deploy and separate the
capsule from the booster three different
times at all three portions of flight so
they were able to do it once during
launch they were able to do it once
prior to Lodge and they were able to do
it once from space and they were also
able at one point guys to do it as the
rocket was going up and what that did
was it demonstrated that the crew can
safely Escape but from at any point
during the flight and I should note I
did lose you guys and lose your audio so
I'll have to check back in with you in a
few minutes okay well we'll wait for you
to check in some technical problems on
our end no technical problems on their
end hopefully Tom the hatch is being
closed it's T-minus 20 until launch time
well T minus 20 with the hatch closed
and John uh you you expect what's going
to be after this let's assume a very
successful flight and then on we go to
further testing before the Glenn Mission
maybe a year and a half two years out
which is a two-stage rocket into orbit
so it's very much of the pattern we saw
from Mercury to Gemini and somebody is
the what next of this that gets your
attention isn't it what's next yes and I
reflected on this moment around about an
hour ago on Bloomberg TV and radio and
I'll do it again I think many people are
very very quick to throw mud at
Innovation like this throw mud at an
effort like this and I think of Jeff
Bezos as Amazon in the late 90s Tom and
many people questioning what it could
become why did it have the valuation it
had when it was just an online
Bookseller the abrasive snark was almost
the media and I just wondered Tom
whether we have to be really humble
about this moment when we look back in
10 years 20 years time and what this
could develop into what this could
become well I think everybody's you know
live this their lives I mean I have the
clearest memory John of being in a NASA
family and literally neighbors down the
street and next door Dead Set against
the NASA program in the early morning of
West Texas we await a launch right now
we are thrilled to bring you without
question this nation's expert on Amazon
bradstone is written on Jeff Bezos
bradstone knows a story better than
anyone I know Brad your thoughts on Mr
Bezos into space frame his path in his
life to this moment
yeah hey Tom you know this is a story
that started probably 40 years ago when
he spent his Summers with his
grandparents at their Ranch in South
Texas and his grandfather had worked on
the Space Program Bezos got the spacebug
watching the Apollo moon landings he
gave his his uh Speech uh at his at his
high school he was a valedictorian about
space travel and really he's he's been
consistent with the vision that speech
was all about opening up the space
Frontier having humans living and
working in space and today is the first
step on that Journey it's been a long
path he founded blue origin in 2000 the
company hasn't had a lot of success to
show for it but as you mentioned they're
working on orbital rockets and moon
Landers often in competition with SpaceX
but today even though it's a more modest
sub-orbital flight it's an important
step for Bezos and for blue origin Brad
have tried to be transparent and
balanced about the moment we're in right
now because myself Tom others get a lot
of criticism for covering an event like
this this is an event that is very very
divisive if basos has taken a lot of
criticism about it how has he confronted
that issue as he makes these kind of
steps forward
he's ignored it I mean he's you know
he's someone who probably has pretty
thick skin over the years being
criticized for so many things at Amazon
some quite justifiably but as Emily
mentioned earlier there's kind of a
palpable excitement here in in West
Texas right now the criticism seems kind
of distant I'm sure we'll return to it
in the press conference later today but
Bezos is just consistent he's got this
long-term Vision he kind of knows that
not everyone's going to buy into it but
you know he's been right about these
things before particularly with Amazon
not saying he's right here it seems kind
of wacky this idea of millions of humans
working and living in space one day
Generations from now but you know he
that's he he believes in it it's his
money he's got 200 billion dollars and
this is what he wants to spend his money
in his time doing now Brad blue origin
actually has two astronauts on staff and
the understanding among employees was
that those astronauts would be the first
to fly on the new Shepherd instead Jeff
Bezos seemed to surprise many people
saying it would be him in all your years
reporting on Amazon and all your years
reporting on Bezos did you ever think
he'd be the first person to ride on his
own rocket yeah definitely not I don't
think a lot of blue engineers and
Executives thought that he would be
going first as you say to NASA ex-nasa
astronauts are on staff the idea was
that they would go first and kind of
test the the customer experience but in
some ways it's consistent I mean Bezos
is all about bold moves he uses the word
Adventure swashbuckling adventure and
right this is the greatest Adventure
that there is and he's sending a signal
here to his company into the world that
he believes in the spacecraft he
believes in the mission and he's willing
to put himself at some small amount of
risk to go see it to fruition now
basically is doing this just a couple of
weeks after stepping down as CEO of
Amazon he has said he could have done
this as CEO of Amazon but but do you
believe that do you buy that or do you
think this was part of some sort of
coordinated timeline he wanted to do
this but not while he was CEO I mean it
does appear orchestrated right that he
would have announced his resignation as
CEO back in what was in late January and
then stepping aside in early July and
now a few weeks later going to space I
mean I think if blue origin had readied
new Shepherd two years ago when it was
supposed to launch the 50th anniversary
of the Apollo 11 moon landing he
probably would have gone as CEO but like
it's just neater now it's cleaner you're
not you don't have Amazon investors
maybe worrying as much so no I don't
think it's an accident we are 15 minutes
away from the first human flight for
blue origins new Shepherd you can hear a
round of applause from the headquarters
of blue origin you can see Jeff Bezos
just inside the cap show the final
check's taking place Tom they're secured
in their harnesses we've had the final
Communications the hatch is closed it's
T-minus 15. yeah again T minus 15 and
you wonder about the sequencing the
sequencing here as well what's
interesting with the modern technology
of liquid oxygen and liquid hydrogen
John it is a shockingly simple system it
is radically simpler cleaner and better
than what we were used two years ago
remember the Saturns they'd start
flaming up ages before they take off
this is a piece of cake with a much much
less heavy payload as well right now as
we prepare for this launch we want to
bring in Chad Anderson with space
capital A managing partner but far more
than that a student of the space
industry and we're thrilled that Mr
Anderson could join us this morning
thank you for being so patient as we
show the moment as well frame this when
we look back five years from now this is
incredibly exciting to watch I mean
space used to be a domain that was
reserved for just a few of us and it's
opening up like never before and you can
see that in the diversity of This Crew I
mean the richest person in the world and
his brother sure but you've also got the
oldest and the youngest person ever to
go to space no medical checks
um a completely autonomous vehicle clean
burning fuel that that the emissions are
water vapor
um multiple aborts throughout incredibly
safe much safer than any vehicle right
that we've flown before what's the path
here to orbital flight can can people
say that tourism is going to be you're
going to go up like Glen and go three
times around the Earth
so that's the plan and Bezos says that
actually it's like Landing a rocket is
like um balancing a broomstick and so
actually a larger broomstick is easier
to balance and so his argument is that
this new Shepherd is actually much
harder to land and so by doing this then
he's you know taken the greatest step
steps forward towards his new Glenn
rocket Tom just an update here the
countdown has been paused at T minus 15
that's taking place just in the last 60
seconds or so
well that can happen it is not weather
is Tim stenovic said it it's uh really
quite uh quite good weather out there so
we'll have to see what that announcement
is again safety is the major precaution
uh as we wait for that hold to come off
with us now Jennifer Vandy Sierra space
Executive Vice President and she is a
former NASA astronaut as well will these
be astronauts astronaut kavandi
well technically speaking once you pass
that 62 mile Mark you will be in space
and therefore have traveled in space
which is the definition of an astronaut
not necessarily a career astronaut but
an astronaut of us what is so
interesting here is the Simplicity of
the systems identify this experience
versus our stereotype of Ron Howard's
you know the right stuff and the rest of
it Apollo 13 all the back and forth of
hundreds and hundreds of people how do
you experience this Simplicity Mr Bezos
has invented
I think it's very elegant you know the
more we learn the more we learn what we
need than what we don't need um he has
gone a very simplistic route uh I think
it's a wonderful achievement for someone
who's essentially done this on his own
because of his own desire to go on Space
his own desire to see the Earth from
that Viewpoint and I think he will
continue to do great things bigger and
better things just like NASA did through
the generation and the evolution of the
rockets that were that came before this
one Johnny I understand we will have the
oldest and the youngest both the oldest
and the youngest ever into space can you
walk me through the degree of training
that these particular astronauts to be
have experienced versus what would have
been experienced 10 20 years ago for a
similar mission
probably not all that different I mean
you have your space suits that you have
to learn how to operate if there are any
emergencies you have those kinds of
equipment that you have to learn to do
an egress from when you go up to the
space you have to unbuckle and then
float around without kicking each other
in the head then you have to get back in
your seat which is probably one of the
more trying things to do and since
you'll only be there for a few minutes
and then get yourself in a safe position
so that you can come back down on land
without hurting anyone so and then
probably an emergency egress out of the
capsule on Landing once they have landed
so those kinds of things are what you
practice just in case something you know
somewhere we're not there or something
were to go wrong you can you can help
yourself get out of the vehicle Janet
just experiencing a brief hold here at T
minus 15. how typical are things like
this to have a brief hold 15 minutes out
oh very very typical I don't think there
was ever a space flight that I was on
that didn't have a hold at some point
during the countdown uh sometimes
they're built in and sometimes they're
unexpected
um it does kind of you know raise the
tension inside the cockpit because
you're excited and and you want to go
and and there may be a delay and uh but
it is um it doesn't matter and the end
whenever you fly it's all worth it after
the commandity I've got to get in a geek
question here because it's something we
have not talked about as we've prepared
for this launch today your PhD at
Washington is an analytical chemistry
and in Material Science how original are
the materials of this blue origin rocket
in capsule versus our stereotypes
sitting in the Smithsonian Air and Space
Museum
I mean I think they're all relatively
similar every evolution like I mentioned
earlier you try to learn something new
use a better material a better fuel less
toxic fuels less toxic materials uh as
as you well know Jeff is all about the
environment and keeping the planet
healthy and making it a safer place in a
in in
and longevity of the earth is really
Paramount in his mind so he wants to
protect her so I'm sure he's gone to
every extent to try to use the least
toxic materials possible for our
audience worldwide on Bloomberg TV and
radio and for our audience joining us
over on Bloomberg quick take we've been
on hold now for a little more than six
minutes Tom a T-minus 15 just a brief
hold that's lasted about six minutes as
we are white blue origin's first human
flight six minutes we've been on hold at
T minus 15 so
it we'll see we'll have to see where
this goes as the astronaut tells us this
is not unusual confounding I I've got to
talk about the fresh air of your
Missouri coming out of Carthage there in
the University of uh Missouri and Wally
Funk to the south in Oklahoma what is it
about the Midwest Aviation Heritage that
puts people like you into space
you know I thought about that a lot
there are a lot of midwesterners that
love to go to space I don't know I think
in part for me at least it was seeing
the night sky from the Midwest it's very
beautiful you can see all the stars you
can see the Milky Way and it's just so
Majestic when you look at space from
that vantage point and I know from a
very young age I would tell my dad that
I wanted to go up there and see what
would be like to be in space and look
back at the Earth so maybe it's that and
maybe it's just that you know there's
not the other distractions that you have
in a a more urban life
um you know you have time to dream you
have time to look out there you have
time to think about exploring so maybe a
combination of all those things is what
inspires us what midwesterners Dr
cavendi thank you so much greatly
appreciate it with Sierra spacer
Executive Vice President of course uh
NASA astronaut and former director of
NASA's Glenn Research Center John tell
them I'm sure I'll upset some people by
cutting in and doing this but nothing
can peel me away from the bond market
for too long we will have full coverage
on the markets at about 34 minutes time
your bond market Tom is Bid yields are
lower by four safest points a 114 handle
and speaking of 14 T minus 14 right now
Tom security very good I just saved
myself from all the criticism did an itk
there we go with T minus 14. yeah we'll
have a treasury bill with one minute to
go we'll go to the treasury building
houses as well John Emily Chang's still
with us at the blue origin launch Center
Emily a slight delay here T-minus 14
what's behind the hold up
slight delay look delays in space
launches are uh
happen a lot and so we've been told
there is a few hour window that this can
take off this morning if it gets Beyond
a few hours it's too long for the
astronauts to sit in there it's too long
for everyone to sit in mission control
and it'll likely be moved to tomorrow at
this point I spoke to the head of design
for the new Shepard who's been working
at Blue origin for 17 years at this
point it's the unknown unknowns that
could cause the issue I mean as far as
all of the known quantities they have
checked everything off their checklist
and at this point it's the unknown
things that could possibly come up one
of which is weather I mean we were
driving through thunderstorms last night
we were sitting here with rain and
lightning I'm told that's typical in the
west Texas desert in the afternoon in
the mornings it is clearer and that's
why they have scheduled a morning launch
they've been testing out the weather for
the last 48 hours with weather balloons
that's very typical for a space launch
and up to this point up to this brief
hold it was all systems go so no clear
reason for for the delay I will say it
is not unusual it should not cause alarm
and we'll just have to wait it out and
see the countdown clock has resumed a
T-minus 13 now we continue to count down
almost to T minus 12. Emily you
mentioned to our colleague Brad Stone a
little bit earlier on about maybe and
I'm going to say it this way you didn't
just maybe a little bit of division over
at Blue origin about who went up first
the first human flight for blue origin
and Jeff Bezos takes Center Stage can
you just walk me through that dynamic
you know I wouldn't necessarily call it
division blue origin has two astronauts
on staff and the understanding was that
those two astronauts would be the first
to fly the first crude Mission and it
surprised people even here I believe in
a good way that Jeff Bezos was going to
be the first person on that flight it is
a huge vote of confidence for what
they've been working on here for 21
years it is an expression of his faith
in the company the faith of his rocket
ship and ultimately he sort of said look
how can I expect anyone else to go up if
I can't go up myself and so yes this has
been his lifelong dream but he is also
the founder of this company and it's a
huge validation and a huge statement
that he is putting himself out there as
the guinea pig now it is a completely
autonomous system if if he was a trained
astronaut he wouldn't necessarily be
able to do much more than a regular
person and that's the whole idea of this
flight that you can get on it with
little training go up and down and have
that experience that's so far been
limited to most mostly government craft
and professional astronauts Tim
sternovic your thoughts please a
distance from the launch pad
yeah I'm about 35 miles from the launch
pad and I will say the wind has
significantly picked up where I am we're
still seeing a lot of excitement on the
ground several people just in the last
few minutes have stopped by asking us
where the best place to actually see
this is I was talking to some folks from
Blue origin yesterday and they did say
that when we're here even though we are
miles away from The Landing site in the
town of Van Horn in West Texas we will
still hear Sonic booms the Sonic booms
will not necessarily be able to be heard
from the booster because that is so loud
but we will be able to hear them as the
capsule re-enters also what you hear
behind me is a freight train happens uh
very very frequently here in Van Horn
and happening as it's going right behind
me so this is where you throw back and
really quickly Yeah
Tim thank you Tom Keane it's T minus 10.
10 minutes and 40 seconds away now 10
minutes and 40 seconds away from a
launch and again John I I really want to
emphasize I love this scale of this
project again 60 feet it's all Chad
Anderson with us as well as we consider
this flight and Chad to me what has been
so important is it's a suborbital launch
this is a little rocket it's almost a
Charming rocket it is yeah and I mean
it's a more traditional route than the
space plane that we saw fly nine days
ago you know what's so interesting for
us as investors in this category is that
in the same way that it's opening up for
passengers and for for travelers it's
opening up for businesses as well
um what would be a business application
here so SpaceX has lowered the barriers
to entry in a way that we have have not
seen before so tourism is one category
of many that we're watching in the space
economy we're going to grow tomatoes up
there I mean give me an applied
application here for Mr Bezos or Mr musk
or anyone that would follow
so tourism is one one piece of this the
data is really what we're after as
investors the data from satellites in
space are what enable us to understand
and address the greatest Global
challenges it's what allows us to see
Over the Horizon and do business with
the people over there it's the invisible
backbone that powers our global economy
so get me for jumping in Chad we keep
talking about the degree of criticism
this kind of flight has also taken can
you walk us through the Innovation that
is on this particular flight that is
helping us Advance happy just make the
steps forward that you'd like to see
well so first of all it's
um it's a new rocket designed for
commercial passengers so everything from
the cabin I've been inside this cabin
and it's extremely large it's spacious
when they unclip they can float around
there's plenty of space for them to do
that
I would say I don't know for sure but
inside I mean it's 12 feet
12 feet ceiling it's um it's big enough
for me to stand on my head probably big
enough to do somersaults Tom that's what
you need to be able to do yeah you see
me doing a summer I can't see you doing
a summer so Tom I bet you that our 82
year old Aviation icon is doing some
assaults up there but I imagine
without a doubt fitter than you yes some
for that matter please make a banner of
that Chad let's talk about investable
opportunities away from just tourism
what are they
so there has been since SpaceX removed
the barriers to entry 10 years ago
um things have opened up in a
considerable way so before there was
really you know a handful of Defense
contractors on one on one side and the
government on the other it was a very
limited market with the barriers entry
removed you can now start a business you
know how much it costs to get to orbit
you can go out and raise Capital venture
capital for these businesses you can be
a founder of a company you can work for
a company you can now go to space so
there are a number of ways in which
we're seeing increased participation in
the space race and we're seeing that
today 20 years of work and effort that's
gone into building these vehicles and
they're coming together within nine days
of each other that's no coincidence
right competition is driving the
Innovation and the progress here and at
the same time you've got SpaceX is has
done a static fire of their super heavy
booster yesterday that's going to
connect with their starship and take us
into orbit in the moon and into deep
space
so on that end there's some very
interesting opportunities we're really
interested in in the data in Earth
observation the satellites that are
being launched by these rockets that are
gathering unprecedented amount of new
data about our planet
um big Tech is getting into the game
Microsoft and Amazon are very
um interested in getting this data onto
their Cloud for the storage and compute
and for the value-added services that
come on top of that and the applications
that are being built on top of this data
are in trillion dollar Industries like
agriculture Insurance Maritime Logistics
you name it so this is opening up in a
way that GPS did for us and GPS is a is
the most successful space technology in
existence has generated trillions of
dollars in economic value in some of the
largest Venture outcomes we've ever seen
the same thing is happening in Earth
observation and geospatial intelligence
and in Satellite Communications with
starlink and Amazon's project Kuiper and
oneweb connecting the planet in a way
that it hasn't ever been connected
before and all the applications that are
come on the back of that we are now T
minus six Tom then it's over to the
command center to start the engines
liftoff should be several seconds after
that T minus six Tom I want to describe
you again the traditional rocketry John
and the idea that this is liquid oxygen
and liquid hydrogen and we all learned
John at one point in high school physics
that means cold these are these are
processes that are ice ice ice cold way
below anything we know in Fahrenheit
Celsius down near the Kelvin level 100
200 degrees plus colder and that's a key
thing at launch T minus five let's head
back over to Bloomberg's quick takes Tim
stenovic Tim blue origin new Shepherd
let's speak to the shepherd piece of
that name Alan Shepard's 1961 Mission
how different this is compared to that
yeah look there are a lot of
similarities at the core they're both
sending people into space Shepard went
significantly higher 116.5 miles above
the Earth's surface he also ended up
much further from the launch area uh his
flight was just a few minutes longer
though uh also very different objectives
here uh the autonomy too versus the fact
that Shepard had to Pilot elements of it
himself
um finally guys it has a lot to do with
vacation right this is a this is an
experience this is supposed to provide a
vacation this is supposed to be
something that tourists experience think
about the message that the United States
was sending the world in 1961 when it
did put Alan Shepard up there one other
thing that I will note about this is
Shepherd's rocket wasn't even as
powerful as blue Origins rocket the new
Shepherd that is sending these four
astronauts into space in just a few
minutes and once again uh part of the
part of the uh of challenges being in
the field I have lost my audio so I'm
going to send it back to you guys in New
York that keeps happening Tim we've
appreciate it though we appreciate your
time we're inside the final five T minus
four let's head back over to Emily Chang
Emily walk us through what we're about
to see in about four or five minutes
time and then from there the next 25
minutes or so
all right John four or five minutes time
and when the countdown clock gets to
zero you still got seven more seconds
before actual liftoff but that is when
the engines will light uh the rocket
will shoot up vertically in the air
about two and a half minutes in there
will be Separation The Crew capsule will
separate from the booster they will both
continue on past the Carmen line the
crew capsule will go uh higher than the
booster itself that is when they will
experience that weightlessness for three
to four minutes they'll be told to
buckle back up with a 30 second warning
and they will make their way back down
they will be descending via parachute so
we are looking for full inflation with
those parachutes once they land and by
the way the the booster will land on a
landing pad in a specific location the
crew capsule will land somewhere in the
area now they they know where they think
it's going to land they have a bunch of
vehicles I believe it's those rivian
trucks stationed on a grid pattern and
they are all ready to zoom in to
retrieve Jeff Bezos and his crew through
as soon as that Landing happens we are
taking bets on who will emerge first I
think Jeff Bezos is going to be the
first to open that hatch uh but but John
and Tom I'm curious uh who you expect to
see first well I would see Mrs Funk
lady's first uh uh to exercise
it was Jeff Bezos who was the first in
the capture I think so maybe he'll be
the first to exit too Jonah too two
minutes two minutes plus uh here I think
it's important as Mr stanovic mentioned
we have wind in Van Horn and as Emily
mentioned there are three parachutes out
in the oceans of Cape Canaveral and Cape
Kennedy this was always a very serious
issue depending on where the astronauts
came down in the water it could be
distant from an aircraft carrier so we
talked about this a little bit earlier
let's do it again because I always find
this part the most fascinating we're at
T minus two now then after the launch we
get the booster and the capsule and they
separate and they separated about 76
kilometers altitude the capsule is going
to go to about 106 kilometers that's
where they'll experience that zero
gravity their lunch strap they'll take
in the curvature of the Earth but that's
separation Tom and the booster returning
to worth that is quite something to see
yeah well it's going to be something to
see and then again you're going to see
two images up folks going up only 62
miles I would hope that we will have
camera images of not only the booster
and the separated capsule at the same
time and then the turn of the rocket
with John you and I mentioned we're
still not used to so eight minutes after
the launch Tom the reusable new Shepherd
booster should land and I understand we
should get some pictures of that and
we'll do our best to bring them to you
and then 11 minutes after the end after
that Tom the crew capsule lands so this
is going to be very quick once the
launch takes place a lot of this is
going to take place very quickly with T
minus one and we should mention good
morning I'm Bloomberg Radio across this
nation and around the world as well
we'll give you the image as much as we
can for Bloomberg Radio John I'm going
to give it over to you right now as we
really get finally down to the final
countdown for our audience worldwide on
Bloomberg TV on Bloomberg Radio for our
audience on Bloomberg quick take the
mission is officially known as ns60 the
script is like something out of a movie
the richest man in the world taking his
brother an 82 year old Aviation icon and
a teenager in the first human flight for
blue origin it is 54 seconds away we're
gonna hand over and listen into the
command Center and the communications
that take place we will not interrupt
this we are 45 seconds out
[Music]
G minor 16 guidance internal
D minus ten nine eight seven six five
four command engine start two one
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Max Cube
30 000 feet Mach One
[Music]
different doesn't it Gary this is
totally different
all right you can follow along of course
the speedometer in the bottom left
the altimeter in the middle of the
screen there
so far appears to be a nominal flight
all right coming up here on Mikko main
engine cut off that will be followed
shortly by separation and at that point
after separation we're gonna let the
astronauts unbuckle and take in the
freedoms of zero g there is Mikko main
engine cutoff
a beautiful shot
down the new Shepherd rocket look at
that view
unreal
awaiting separation here
tell them that Vision that view never
and here gets old
start to see
and the speedier John is very very
important here this is not orbital speed
of 16 17 18 000 miles per hour but
nevertheless thrust to get up into space
well over a thousand miles per hour and
John the feet being added here out to
the 62 mile point we have passed the
point of the great physics tension of a
rocket in the capsule now waiting for
that separation the separation set to
take place in its entirety Tom in about
four minutes and 30 seconds let's head
back to Emily Chang to walk us through
the next 10 minutes or so Emily
all right John so look on the left hand
corner of your screen you see the
countdown clock the speed going down
when that gets to zero that is the peak
of the flight or apogee as they say in
the space industry that is when uh they
will be feeling those uh three to four
minutes of weightlessness and
immediately after it it hits zero the
speed starts going back up as that crew
capsule starts going back down so there
we are at zero it's happened the capsule
has reached apogee uh we imagine Jeff
Bezos and his crew are floating around
weightless inside that capsule right now
and that they are all feeling that
feeling that is so coveted so rare that
so few humans have felt now you're going
to see the booster coming down first so
uh the lower portion of your screen uh
that will be the booster descending back
to Earth the crew capsule uh will
descend after that John and Tom and a
ridge original image John something I'm
still not used to a booster of a lighter
color and the capsule a brighter white
separating apart as they come up to
apogee and or I should say come coming
down and John is just an absolutely
original idea no one thought of this
Mercury Gemini Apollo just absolutely
stunning Tom and I say it completes in
about three minutes time that's when the
reusable new Shepherd booster actually
lands back down on Earth and then we get
the experience the experience that I
think everyone who goes in space wants
to see we know the cost of it for Virgin
Galactic Tom it's about 200k 250k we
still don't know what this is going to
cost people if they would like to follow
in the footsteps to Jeff Bezos and the
other three you know I got to admit your
one minute warning and you're on a
Boeing flight over to lhr and they tell
you to get back in your seat and buckle
up this is a little more important John
I've got to say this is a little bit
different to the transatlantic flight
that you and I would say let's head back
in and take a listen to the events as
they unfold
is everybody in
First Step
astronaut Oliver
Oliver status check oh sorry blue Patrol
Oliver uh
copy astronaut Wally
about the astronaut demo
[Applause]
[Music]
copy
foreign
astronaut Damon and the returning of the
booster the new Shepherd booster
returning back to worth Tom you can see
the uh coming back down to earth in
about the next 50 seconds that should be
landing time FM radio it's just
absolutely extraordinary the Flame's now
hitting on the ground the booster
Landing here uh I will have to see where
it is in the market looks pretty good
right now uh John let's look at the
Smoke Clear before we go back to Emily
Chang to be sure yeah we look at that
there's the touchdown it's just amazing
it's phenomenal isn't it it's like
parallel parking on Fifth Avenue
even I can't do it let's confirm that
right here for our audience Emily Chang
let's bring it back into the
conversation the reusable new Shepherd
booster is back on Earth just walk us
through what's taking place right now in
the capsule it the booster is back on
Earth and as it was coming down we heard
that Sonic Boom uh that we knew we would
hear if everything was going right it
landed safely the way it was supposed to
on the launch pad and it looks like it's
ready to go back up there John the key
is reusability bringing that cost down
using these Rockets over and over again
when that booster landed we heard cheers
from the crowd you've got a lot of
devoted people employees who have been
working here for years watching this and
now we are watching that crew capsule
float on down those are the drogue
parachutes the small parachutes that are
used especially for vehicles at very
very high velocity they're designed to
slow that capsule down as it speeds back
towards Earth and and these are the main
parachutes we're looking for full
inflation here of the main parachutes
that will slow the capsule down
as it approaches Earth to bring it in
for a safe landing the retrof thrust
system will kick in basically pushing
out a cloud of air below the capsule and
we expect it to land in a cloud of
desert dust
look at that it's getting closer and
closer to the ground just 1600 feet
above the ground right now uh you can
imagine uh this is the culmination of a
live stream for Jeff Bezos for Wally
Funk as John you've been talking about
an icon of Aviation for Mark Bezos Jeff
bezos's brother and for 18 year old
Oliver Damon there you see the crew
capsule descending back to Earth there
are multiple vehicles on the ground in a
grid pattern waiting to zoom in as soon
as touchdown happens here Emily thank
you that capsule Tom Keane 800 feet away
it's just amazing to see and of course
the debate of land versus sea 40 and 50
60 years ago and now routinely done on
land let us listen in right now
and it's touchdown
it's okay and that looks successful to
me I don't know about you yeah we'll
have to see I I believe it is successful
amazing to meet John to see the speed of
which they seem to be dropping and yet a
very gentle Landing the hatch is due to
Open Tom I understand in the next 10
minutes or so so we might have to wait a
little while to see who comes out of
first the pitch is on your screen though
for our audience worldwide if you're
listening on Bloomberg Radio the booster
successfully touching down the capsule
so far at least from what we can see
successfully launching down I believe
you can hear from Jeff Bezos so let's
take a listen you're a very happy Capcom
here as well
let's do a status check astronaut Oliver
astronauts
[Music]
[Music]
I am
unbelievably good
coffee
blue controlled Bezos best day ever
copy everyone go ahead and remain in
your seats crew member seven is on their
way shortly you will hear the cats fall
off gassing
[Music]
everybody
[Laughter]
Tom Kane that looks like a successful
Mission the astronauts checked in the
capsule successfully returning to land
that hatch is due to open in five or so
minutes time
uh the capsule Landing in the Triangle
of the three parachutes laid out on the
Texas desert or the plains I guess I
would call in a light green scrub we say
good morning on Bloomberg Radio on
television it's just extraordinary
images of a return to space Chad
Anderson with us in a perfect time to
speak to him his blue origin is gathered
in celebration here I guess a Flawless
mission is our first take what does that
signal for Mr Bezos for Mr musk what
does that signal for Chad Anderson I
mean they've been Flawless since since
the beginning this is their 16th flight
and they've all they've all been
Flawless
um it's really great to see we now
officially have two suborbital vehicles
online that are taking humans to space
they're going to start doing so
regularly we have SpaceX is taking NASA
to the space station they have private
missions lined up
um uh you know later this year and we
have this is a new era and human space
flight why is NASA focused on the
efforts of Mr musk and not on those of
Mr Bezos
well you know there's been a lot of
comparison between Virgin Galactic and
and Bezos and blue origin actually but
the Ambitions of blue origin are much
more aligned with SpaceX this is the
first step in what they're you know much
larger ambition what does Mr musk learn
from what we've seen this morning
well I think you know he's congrat you
know he's wished them well and I'm sure
that he's he's happy to see this this um
success happen it's happened he's been a
leader in a lot of in a number of other
categories in Tesla as well and he's
happy to see other electric vehicles
coming online I imagine he's got a
similar sentiment here
um you know one company does not make a
market and so it's great to see the The
increased competition
um driving further Innovation Chad let's
go to John Farrow as we see the SUV pull
up to the capsule John two vehicles
approaching the camp show one individual
running towards it so I'm just waving at
the astronauts inside they're going to
open up that hatch any moment from now
Tom any moment now that hatch will be
opened so many of the memories here
folks and it's not only Alan Shepard
being yanked out of the ocean and Gus
Grissom with a capsule uh going down
into the ocean but it's always an
important Mission now I would assume
John that the weightlessness issue here
of the shuttle and the spaces space
station is not an issue when you're up
for 11 minutes I mean what could go what
can happen tell me certainly goes
quickly that's for sure I can see Jeff
Bezos inside reaching for his cowboy hat
Tom I think that's going on right now as
they go to open up that capsule we were
taking bets on who would exit first
something in first I think Jeff Bezos
went in first so I'm pretty sure that Mr
Vegas is going to be first out do they
come or the way some people have
delivered the coverage of this you'd
expect it to be just as large it's the
what next of this Tom it's the what next
to this this was the first time for this
company what next Craig let's go Chad
let's go excuse me Chad let's go to you
quickly here what is the next here that
you observe
I mean there's going to be more of these
flights they've got more lined up and
interestingly I mean it's gonna see it's
gonna be interesting to see where they
price this thing how many people are
going we know that 7 500 people put in
bids in this auction paying up to 28
million and there was thousands of
people who paid you know any variation
um and so it'll be interesting to see
where they end up how virgin responds
and where blue origin goes next John
Let's describe the scene for radio here
we've got a mic up like they use for us
on Bloomberg surveillance make sure they
get of his tone but uh certainly a
different scene than anything I've seen
from NASA before John I can count one
two three four individuals working on
opening up that capsule Tom it's going
to take a couple of moments I think you
can just about see Jeff Bezos inside the
cap show wave it around and giving the
thumbs up as we wait for that to open up
we want to bring in our colleague Emily
Chang as we await this moment Emily your
thoughts on what's developed in the past
hour
John Tom I mean we all have covered a
lot of stories in our lives some of them
are more memorable than others I have to
say this is one for the history books
this is it's hard not to get caught up
in the energy and the history of this
moment I mean it's one small step for
Jeff Bezos perhaps one giant leap for
space tourism and space exploration and
the vision that Bezos has articulated
goes so far beyond just people having a
joy ride in space he is talking has
talked about building this road to space
the infrastructure that other
entrepreneurs can build on he's talked
about the fact that when he started
Amazon
um you know he didn't have to start a
new credit card systems all of that was
in place we had a mail service that
could deliver packages to you space
however is much more undiscovered there
is no infrastructure he wants to build
that infrastructure so so space
entrepreneurs of the future can build a
whole new generation of Amazons out
there and so it'll be interesting to see
what he has to say as he steps off this
flight and whether or not the experience
has changed him or this Vision at all
um but it you know obviously this is a
suborbital flight blue origin working on
orbital flights with the new Glenn that
will be their next big project we spoke
to a lead designer who said they're on
track for that to be done uh before the
end of next year so who knows Jeff Bezos
could be up there again on an orbital
flight I believe that hatch door is
about to open
any moment now to see who comes out of
that capsule first the astronauts inside
are standing up they're standing up Tom
as we await that door to open perhaps in
the next couple of seconds they're going
to descend down a John and you know it's
going to be a great moment the stairs
John frankly looked like the ones we
have for the Gulf Stream the hatch door
has opened to the capsule song
exiting first is Jeff Bezos donning that
cowboy hat but he's been wearing over
the last week or so Tom after him the
first teenager the first human flight
the youngest ever astronaut there Tom
and there you go so we keep talking
about this moment for the 82 year old
Aviation icon just phenomenal and his
brother the last out of the capsule
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
radio it's being filmed it will be part
of their propaganda if you will of the
further flights uh to be had but what US
absolutely stuns me John is this truly
appears to be absolute Flawless
execution again here as successful
launch and landing of the new Shepherd
rocket and crew capsule with our first
human flight crew there Jeff Bezos Mark
Bezos Oliver Damon and Wally funk
foreign
and their families there giving big hugs
all around what a moment so much emotion
from all of them
the the Elation did you see Wally did
you see Wally when she came out you know
this I told you she was just she was
probably gonna do a summer you know
cartwheel as he came out of that capsule
what an incredible incredible day
a successful mission for an s16 for Jeff
Bezos Mark Bezos Oliver Damon and for
Wally Fern Kelly Chang to bring you back
into the conversation we keep talking
about the what next of it what have we
achieved today that was not achieved two
weekends ago
John I have to say from everything that
I could tell this was an extremely
successful Mission this was an
opportunity for Jeff Bezos to
demonstrate blue Origins technology to
the world this is after a 21-year
journey delays design changes losing out
on contracts government contracts
important government contracts to SpaceX
and up to this point SpaceX has very
much been seen as the leader in this
industry SpaceX has orbital rockets and
is already making trips to the
International Space Station and taking
astronauts there this validates that
blue origin has the capability and you
wonder you have to assume certainly that
the folks at Nasa are watching and you
wonder if this changes something for
NASA as well we welcome you all to our
coverage for the Market's opening John
we have to say within the markets and I
want to go to simtena back here but John
we have to say that as we have had this
launch we've had an adjustment in the 10
10-year yield to a lower yield that is
worth noting as we enter a Tuesday
trading year 10 year yield right now 113
on 10s yields in about five six basis
points for the broader Market your
Equity market around the opening power
positive just 0.15 on the open of six
points it's worth highlighting some that
for many many people they do not like
what they hear and what they see around
this story this morning as Emily points
out today that was a successful mission
for this company there are many people
though that would like to see Jeff Bezos
do a whole lot more on planet Earth than
what he's just done in the last one hour
one of the Stark things here folks is
like almost like an athletic locker room
they're breaking out the champagne for
those of you on Bloomberg Radio we can
always describe a champagne moment Tim
stanovic that is one of the Stark
differences here between private
Enterprise you wouldn't see that with
the government NASA effort as well I
mean we're really seeing a private
Enterprise Tim Steven like where does it
go from here
yeah it's a really good question it goes
a lot of different places for blue
origin they have two more of these
flights later this year they're shooting
for late September early October unclear
as we heard earlier how much those are
going to cost the company has much much
bigger Ambitions though beyond space
tourism Jeff Bezos has talked about his
vision for the future he said in the
past that if we can get a trillion
people that's right a trillion people
into the solar system that means we have
a thousand Einsteins and a thousand
mozarts the idea is that the Earth
cannot sustain us in order for materials
in order for energy we have to explore
further you know he was asked earlier
this week or earlier this week about the
idea that why focus on Space when we
have so many problems here at home and
his answer was well first of all I think
we can do both at the same time and
indeed in recent years he has increased
his Investments with his own
philanthropy but it is behind many other
people of immense wealth the other
element of that is that he said it's
always important for us to be exploring
It's always important for us to be
looking ahead and he says we can do both
of those things at the same time I think
it's right to sit on this conversation
Tom you like me Emily I'm sure as well
and Tim too over the last hour we've
built up to this moment this morning for
blue origin a momentous occasion truly
historic but for many people the
frustration the amount of messages that
I've received in the last 60 Minutes
criticizing not just this coverage but
the event itself Emily Chang just to go
over the mission statement of blue
origin that you and I discussed a little
bit earlier this morning I think it's
worth sharing a couple of lines with our
audience blue origin believes that in
order to preserve Earth our home for our
grandchildren's grandchildren we must go
to space to tap its unlimited resources
and energy for Jeff Bezos and others
Emily there is no distinction between
the work that needs to be done on earth
and the work that he thinks needs to be
done in space
absolutely and you know I think that
Jeff Bezos and blue origin uh part of
the opportunity here is for them to
explain that Vision this has been a very
secretive company for 21 years until
today uh only one journalist had ever
visited blue origin headquarters today
they're open to the national press we
are all here watching this moment and
wanting Jeff Bezos to articulate what
that vision is why is he spending so
much of his money exploring space for
this 11-minute trip up and down how does
that help us on Earth and what he has
said is I want to continue living on
Earth this is the best planet we love it
here but we need to protect it we're
going to run out of energy we need to go
to space in order to mine that energy
from the Sun from the Moon we don't need
to go to Mars Mars is inhospitable we
will not enjoy it there we don't want to
live on the moon either we want to live
on these space colonies as he's
described it where it's like Maui every
day and you can go go back and forth to
Earth whenever you want this is hundreds
of years out but he imagines a big
industry in space residential and Light
Industry here on Earth and blue origin
he wants to be a huge part of the
infrastructure and building out that
space economy The Eyes Of The World On
The Desert land just outside of Van Horn
West Texas right now 837 local time 9 37
in New York Times so allow me to check
in on the markets just briefly seven
minutes into the session it has been a
huge 24 hours for this market equities
up by a third of one percent with your
bounce back this is what it looks like
as follows on the S P 500 advancing just
a little bit 12 13 points higher but
once again Tom it's the bond market that
gets your attention and maybe the bond
market Pals in comparison to what we've
seen in the last hour or so but your 10
year right now just south of 114 Tom
down five basis points on the day I'm
gonna brag for the 108th mayor of New
York and for Thomas secunda when they
did their innovation of inventing the
Bloomberg terminal John it was
absolutely original that you could go
from what was called a Monroe Trader out
to convexity and duration math and then
to immediate log analysis of charts I
can tell you John it was just like what
you're watching with Mr Bezos on the
Texas desert the 10-year yield right now
John is a textbook chart of a lower
highs on yield it has been one two three
and on and on back over the last uh 15
days or so it is stunning to see price
up and yield down to a
1.1392 John we have to begin to be on
the 0.99 watch unbelievable for our
audience worldwide on Bloomberg TV and
radio and of course from audience on
blimp a quick take the coverage
continues with Tom Kane myself Jonathan
Farrow alongside our good friends and
colleagues Emily Chang and Tim stanovic
will continue to cover the markets but
also this event Tom I talked about the
late 90s and Amazon are the kind of
people that threw mud at that company
and its valuation why would this company
be valued what it's valued when it's
just an online Bookseller without the
vision of what this could become and I'm
conscious of that particular Moment In
the late 90s and conditioned by it
because I do not want that clip to play
in 20 years time of me repeating that
same error throwing mud at a mission
that's taken place in the last hour
without any imagination on what this
momentum can develop what this moment
can develop into yes Amazon had a crazy
valuation but it became something so
much bigger than just an online
Bookseller and you wonder if Jeff Bezos
can repeat the act on with blue origin
well it's a repeat yeah yeah but it's a
strategic plan to move forward and again
they have that plan in Shepherd a single
engine rocket which will be put on top
of a larger rocket and that will be
called Glenn Chad Anderson knows this
with space capital and continues where
this patient this morning at this
historic moment what's after Glenn do
they make does Jeff Bezos want to go to
the Moon
he does he's he's working with a
Consortium of he's he's partnered up
with a few of the incumbents and is was
competing for a contract that he lost
out on to musk in SpaceX and they've
fought against that and it looks like
they're going to press ahead SpaceX was
the only one that put in a bid that was
affordable frame this and you're very
good at this frame for this now China
doing a Matt Damon equivalency on Mars
we're out on Mars with a helicopter that
goes around there's government interest
there's International interest there's
private billionaire interest as well how
do they dovetail together in 2031
well this is how so many new markets and
nascent markets develop the government
is an early investor in the technology
risk and in the r d and that's what
we've seen over the last 50 or 60 years
in space and then with the retirement of
the Space Shuttle we were basically
saying this has become routine getting
to orbit and has become too expensive
and in order to keep doing this we need
to work with commercial partners and
that's what you know SpaceX 10 years ago
was able to break through kind of the
deadlock of the defense contractors who
kind of had a a tight grip on this
Market yeah and they've lowered the
prices I mean they are allowing NASA to
do more with their limited budget
resupplying the space station taking
astronauts the space station maintaining
station and also going out to deeper
space
missions and exploring exploring the
solar system let's get some final
thoughts from our colleagues on the
ground Emily Chang I want to come to you
first please
John you were asking about lunar
Ambitions and what's so fascinating
about this entire design process that
has of course taken place over 21 years
here at Blue origin is they have built
uh their future ambition going out
hundreds of years into the design of the
rocket that Jeff Bezos sat on today uh
the rocket is powered by hydrogen and
oxygen a very simple mixture and on the
moon what do you find but water hydrogen
and oxygen so the idea is that once a
lot a rocket presumably lands on a moon
a blue origin rocket they can turn
what's on the moon into Rocket Fuel to
get that rocket back to Earth to power
it through the space economy and you
know what I would say is what we have
witnessed today is nothing short of
extraordinary sure I know there are
people out there who are unhappy with
how Jeff Bezos is spending his time but
this is an incredible Fleet the birth of
private space industry the idea that we
don't have to rely on on governments to
get to space that private citizens can
go there if they want to on their own
craft so this up and down suborbital
Mission this is just the tip of a very
long journey it's orbital missions next
perhaps lunar missions after that all
building towards this future space
ecosystem that Jeff Bezos has envisioned
Emily I know you've got to run where
have you got to run to we've got to go
get an interview with Jeff Bezos is that
right
gotta go I have a very important
conversation and we're going to get it
back to you as fast as we possibly I'm
looking forward to that Emily you run
run away it's been great to catch up
thanks for your help this morning Tim
stanovic you've had problems with the
audio all morning I'm going to take
another shot at this and give you a
final word Tim are you there
I'm here and all is good here in Van
Horn you know when the new Shepherd went
up it was silent here in Van Horn I was
able to see the trail left by the uh by
the rocket motor as it uh exceeded uh
hundreds of thousands of feet one thing
that I have been thinking a lot about
though is is what comes next and we know
what comes next for blue origin but
there's a lot that we don't know about
what comes next I mean think about where
we were 60 years ago after Shepard's
journey into space we didn't imagine
that where we'd be sitting we'd be able
to do satellite technology that would
allow me to be talking to you guys or
even potentially imagine that we could
do global Positioning Systems so easily
or use global Positioning Systems to
monitor climate change or what Elon Musk
is doing uh with starlink delivering
internet to areas all over the world the
fact is is even though these
billionaires these entrepreneurs they do
have these Grand Visions the idea of
what we could be seeing in the next 10
20 years we don't even know yet what
that looks like
Tim stanovic thank you so much greatly
appreciate it this morning from Van Horn
at Texas right now as we move forward
and again this with an equity lift in
the market up 228 points and the bond
market with those lower yields we
continue with one final discussion here
on our moment in space and that is the
engineering of our many space programs
Daniel Wood is expert at this director
of space enabled research group at MIT
media lab who dovetails a lot of social
efforts and social policy into grunt
engineering and I say that Danielle with
immense immense respect there's that c
Daniel in Apollo 13 where they're going
to die and the three Engineers are in
mission control and they got the
canister and they're going to purify the
oxygen or the astronauts are going to
die and they all pull out and sink their
kufulanaster slide rules we are so far
removed from the slide rules of a busted
Apollo Mission what is the technology
forward that we will see from this
private Enterprise
it's wonderful to celebrate today I'm so
happy for Wally Funk and for somebody
like her who's had such a long road to
this road of space and we could think
about the technology by asking you know
what has been the road for all the
companies I was in college watching the
Ansari Express I want to appreciate
Anish Ansari who helped fund some of the
early Investments by private companies
trying to demonstrate the ability to put
a human into space through suborbital
Mission several times in a row and what
we're seeing today you know with
multiple launches by private companies
is part of this long journey it's also
been a great coordination between
government and private sector I used to
work for NASA and NASA has within its
Congressional mandate something called
the space act agreement capability
meaning they can make agreements with
organizations that are private sector
organizations to share engineering
knowledge and experience on space flight
officer wood you were a Kennedy Center
Canal I'm gonna I'm sorry it's Cape
Canaveral Professor just so you know for
some of us that are of a certain age you
were an intern there and I'm sure in
your Orlando and your central Florida
you were grilled why are we doing this
explain now why are we doing this in
2021
everyone on Earth is benefiting from the
Investments that governments and the
private sector are making in space I
travel all over the world and I engage
with leaders of countries in Africa
Latin America the Caribbean southeast
Asia countries on every continent are
investing in space infrastructure and
are looking for ways for private
companies to play a role in the space
ecosystem because space brings us many
benefits through observing the
environment understanding responding to
climate change managing our fragile
coastlines and also thinking about
providing services but even human space
flight and microgravity research helps
us transfer benefits from space back to
Earth we understand better how to
recycle water how to recycle air and
make ecosystems that are clean whether
artificial but also on Earth and we also
understand better how our bodies and
plants and animals respond in an
environment like a microgravity which
explains their fundamental physics
better there's also the inspiration side
I am running a program at MIT called
zero Robotics and we're inviting middle
school students from around the country
to learn about space Robotics and how to
code and one day we hope to do this with
a collaboration of the space station and
expose them to the space station which
has been done on the floor in the past
and so these opportunities Inspire the
next generation of leaders as well it's
a great fear here is that we'll be a
success for the elites as you well know
we have two Americas how do we translate
technological innovation how do we
translate as binge Olson and McAfee talk
about the Race Against the Machine how
do we translate this technology over to
the have-nots the technological
have-nots of America
I spent a lot of my time thinking about
how we can do engineering design in a
way that's Equitable advanced
environmental sustainability and
economic Justice this means first asking
Who's involved ensuring that we have
increased diversity and access to
technology it also means designing these
Space Systems in a way that directly
serves the needs of those who've
experienced environmental Injustice or
long-term discrimination it also means
listening to groups like indigenous
communities that have concerns cultural
questions about what humans do in space
for example thinking of the Moon as a
sacred place there's a lot of ways we
can use space technology to provide
services like Disaster Response for
example and we can also then listen to
those who usually don't have a strong
chance to give their view on what we do
in space because we're about to make
some key decisions as a human race and
how we treat the space environment and I
think we need more voices involved in
this going forward Danielle just a final
word from you you mentioned the
public-private Partnerships and I think
it's spot on to point that out but for
many of these efforts they're
increasingly privatized and the gains
will be shared with the shareholders and
I wonder your thoughts on that as we
move away from Strictly a government
effort towards something much more
highly privatized
I think it's so important that we
continue to see government
infrastructure allowing services like
research opportunities for universities
like internationally shared climate data
that's important for everyone around the
world I hope that that becomes a private
sorry a public service that continues
over years to come there will also be
private activities that kind of build on
the government infrastructure I think it
remains to see be seen whether that's
going to be only open to the elite it is
possible for private companies to
consider how they can have business
models that provide further openness to
those who have less access or less
ability to pay this is a choice that
they need to make and I hope they do
make it Professor wood thank you so much
for joining us with the MIT media lab uh
Daniel Wood this morning John I think
we've got to do a market check we always
need to do that with green on the screen
and we can use all the space Innovation
John to say once again I looked for a
window of opportunity
and you missed it thank you 4287 on the
SMP we bounce back seven tenths of one
percent after the choppiness we've seen
in the last 24 hours here's one for you
though Tom take a look at space take a
look at Virgin Galactic and how it's
trading this morning stand by 7.6 in
early trading now the leaders of these
companies when they're asked about the
competition they don't want to talk
about the competition they believe this
is a joint effort to make steps and
progress where we haven't made any
progress for the last couple of decades
I think investors do see it slightly
differently a successful mission for
blue origin and Virgin Galactic south of
30 at 29.90 and down 8 percent on
it's interesting to see Chad Anderson
where this was a final thought here he
has been more than patient space
capitals managing a partner of the
dovetail of all of this Innovation the
NASA that we used to know and maybe the
NASA that's still there with where we're
moving forward and you know we've talked
about the next steps of these people but
to John's Point does Private Enterprise
and private competition get in the way
of space success absolutely not it's
driving it forward we started off in a
place where we had never been to space
then we launched a satellite then we
launched a human and then we landed on
the moon and we've been regressing ever
since and it's only thanks to private
efforts that we are now accelerating
back into so what does NASA think of
this event today I think they think very
highly of this event and they're very
happy to see the success again they are
benefiting from this they are going to
now be able to rely on low-cost
Innovative Partners
leveraging reusable ability and enabling
them to do more with their limited
budgets I mean this this hits on a few
different Notes One the inspiration
front to the competition it's driving
Innovation forward and three we wouldn't
be we wouldn't have the capability that
we have today without space technology
these guys in Texas cowboy hats teach
anybody at JPL anything I'm serious I
mean or it I might not not the media lab
at MIT but MIT Aeronautics the legacy of
Harold Edgerton and the rest of it can
they teach the pros anything it's a
great question and uh good one today so
you better go with it 100 yes and they
learn from each other it's a symbiotic
relationship so NASA has a lot of
Heritage and a lot of great you know
embedded expertise they've been there
and they've done that the private sector
is challenging a lot of the embedded
assumptions and doing things in new ways
allowing them to do things more
effectively and more cost effectively
Chad just quickly investable
opportunities right now let's close
right there is this a single night name
opportunity or do you want to play the
industry as a whole we've gone from a
very limited market uh 10 years ago a
handful of Defense contractors on one
side and the government on the other
there has now been 200 billion dollars
invested in over 1500 unique space
companies over the last 10 years this is
a massive Market opportunity
um all cuts across the infrastructure
the distribution and the applications of
that satellite data in space technology
Stacks such as GPS geospatial
intelligence and Communications this is
a massive Market opportunity that we're
just on the Forefront of
I love asking that question and seeing
an investor Tom lean in just lead in and
give the pitch give the pitch Chad
Anderson there with the pitch space
Capital managing partner Chad thank you
for being with us through the last
couple of hours and as we wrap up our
coverage worst pointing out that there
will be a news conference following the
blue origin space flight the news
conference taking place with Jeff Bezos
coming up at about 11 eastern time I
just didn't know Bloomberg television
and on Bloomberg Radio and I'm sure our
colleagues over at Bloomberg quick take
will be carrying that as well Tom before
we go we've talked about the degree of
criticism we've had we talked about the
degree of support that we've had let me
allow the words of a Bloomberg terminal
subscriber to speak just for a moment
this got sent in moments ago and I'd
like to share it with our audience Bezos
and mask are using their own money to do
things with the US government has not
made a lot of progress on in the last 20
to 40 years this individual goes on to
say I grew up watching a moon landing as
a young child the space shuttle launched
in Florida when in high school and have
a signed picture from Apollo 15 John
Irwin on my wall people saying they
should do more on Earth ignores the
great advances in technology that
pushing into space help drive and if
nothing cows sparking the imagination of
the world's youth to try things that
haven't been done before now if we say
something has been successful today Tom
just as far as that statement's
concerned I think the effort towards
that I think we've seen a success this
morning well yes Mr Bezos said I don't
need to say it Mr Bezos can say it we
can do both and that's always been the
rationalization and they are trying to
do most for our audience worldwide on
Bloomberg television on Bloomberg Radio
on Bloomberg quick take that does it for
our coverage right here I want to turn
to the price section and get you up to
speed and what's going on in this moment
come on oh it's your show I forgot
excuse me my Show's like a minute long
time can you indulge me 60 seconds
please can you let me do it the s p at
42.88 we advance on the dirty points
we're up seven ten to one percent Tom
the Dow doesn't even make it into my
show I'm only doing this just for you
we're advising how many points it's an
epic surge up 400. we're up a little
more than 1.2 percent that needs an
American accent doesn't it the NASDAQ
Cup 40 advancing a third of one percent
but once again Tom is the bond market
that dominates the coverage this morning
your tenure comfortably below 120 at
160. now what I like is your grand Banks
48 is named epic surge I just think
that's great that does it for our
coverage alongside Tom Keane I'm
Jonathan Farrow a special thanks to our
colleagues Emily Chang and Tim stanovic
over at Bloomberg quick take for our
audience worldwide from New York City
with the eyes of the world for the last
couple of hours at least very much on a
small town in West Texas and the desert
just outside of it at Van Horner
congratulations to Jeff Bezos of blue
origin from New York a successful launch
a successful touchdown back to work this
is Bloomberg
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions transport industry
buildings electricity all of those
things everything you need to know about
our changing environment the politics of
global warming we can and we will deal
with climate change in the fight against
climate change when we're green has you
covered
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
French astronomer Alexis bouvard noticed
something strange
the gravity of the inner planets
couldn't account for the orbital
movement of the outermost planet Uranus
his hypothesis there must be a massive
object influencing it
that eventually LED mathematicians to
correctly calculate the location of our
eighth planet Neptune
and this discovery fueled a mad hunt to
discover more planets using this method
to give it an approximation everybody
and their brother have looked for
planets Beyond Neptune I mean the moment
Neptune was discovered everyone wanted
to do it because it was this clear
demonstration that you can use math to
discover objects
unfortunately since then no major planet
in our solar system has been found
but thanks to Modern telescopes
thousands of smaller objects have been
discovered in the past few decades
Beyond Neptune called trans-neptunian
objects or tnos like sedna one nicknamed
The Goblin and another nicknamed Biden
and planetary scientists at the
California Institute of Technology have
noticed some anomalies with these
objects
the first is the fact that the orbits
all lie in the same plane the second is
that they all swing out into the same
direction now the third is where it gets
interesting
large fraction of these orbits that
swing out and to look like they've been
arranged are detached from the orbit of
Neptune
their hypothesis a giant theoretical
Planet Beyond Neptune which accounts for
the anomalies of these objects planet
nine
and thanks to a new telescope equipped
with the largest digital camera ever
built
we may be one sky survey away from
finally finding it
will be a game changer because it's big
and it content type very faint objects
we will find objects all the way from
near Earth asteroids out to
transneptunian objects and Beyond
[Music]
[Music]
after the discovery of Neptune
scientists thought there had to be yet
another planet to account for the
remaining orbital anomalies of Uranus
they called it Planet X
there were hundreds of attempts by
scientists to find this missing Planet
over the next few decades
but as it turns out
they were wrong
astronomers had incorrectly estimated
Neptune's Mass later confirmed by
Voyager in 1989 which did account for
these remaining anomalies
the reason Pluto was initially
considered a planet is because it was an
object that was sort of in the right
part of the sky where Clyde tumbo was
looking for Planet X a predicted object
that was supposed to resolve the
remaining orbital anomalies of Uranus
although Pluto would later be classified
as a dwarf planet
since it was too small and too far away
to have any influence on the outer
planets this was the start of a new era
for discoveries of bodies in the outer
solar system
Pluto is one of what's thought to be
hundreds of thousands of tnos
and the more that are discovered the
more data seems to point to a ninth
planet
[Music]
we see this grouping of trajectories all
these little pieces of debris that are
hanging out in this population of icy
planetesimals Beyond Neptune all of
their orbits tend to be aligned in a
very specific way that is difficult to
ascribe to chance or to describe in any
other way other than the existence of
yet another planetary Mass body hanging
out in the distant solar system
[Music]
the aligned orbits hint at a large body
pulling them in the same direction
they also found each tno to be tilted on
its axis in approximately the same way
and they don't appear to be put there by
Neptune
these orbits should all hug the orbit of
Neptune and many of them don't
why not well the here in planet nine
once again comes back into the fold you
need Planet Nine's gravity as it turns
out to kind of untether these objects
from the orbit of Neptune
there's other circumstantial evidence as
well
if you compare the sizes of discovered
exoplanets planets outside our solar
system the majority fall into categories
known as super Earths or many Neptunes
on average
each star if you look up in the night
sky has at least one planet and most
planets that inhabit this galaxy if you
will are super Earth we use objects that
are a few Earth masses it's actually
quite remarkable that the solar system
as efficient as it was at creating
planets
um
appears to be missing these short period
super earth type objects which are very
common elsewhere
so if Planet 9 does exist and is super
earth size it would make our solar
system similar to the majority we've
observed
to make all these calculations and
determine the potential orbit of planet
nine
the team at Caltech put collected data
into computer simulations
as far as the math allows us to
calculate uh it's about five Earth
masses okay so it falls in between an
earth type planet and an ice giant such
as Uranus or Neptune
they also estimate that it's on a 20 000
year orbit around the sun
that's 10 times further away than
Neptune is from the Sun
we can calculate the orbit and the mass
of planet nine to a pretty good
approximation what we cannot do is tell
you where it is on the night sky
fundamentally it's all just gravity it's
a different type of Dynamics okay which
allows us to infer the existence of
planet nine then was the case with
Neptune with Neptune you could say it's
right there and get the orbit kind of
wrong here you have information about
the orbit not so much the information of
where it is on the night sky so that's
why we're stuck uh kind of observing a
whole swath of the sky which takes a
long time isn't indeed difficult to do
that massive swath of Sky makes finding
such a faint far away object like
finding a needle in a haystack
planet nine is
millions of times less bright on the
night sky than Neptune that's
really really dim I mean if you really
think about it Neptune is not something
you can observe with your naked eye you
need a telescope to see and planet nine
is millions of times less bright
critics say that the team at Caltech
have an observational bias having not
looked in enough quadrants of the sky at
different times of year to conclude that
there is in fact orbital clustering
essentially more data is needed
the good news is we are kind of entering
the next generation of such surveys now
with the uh commissioning and the
construction of the Vera Rubin telescope
in Chile
so I think that's going to be a game
changer in this in this problem
the Vera Rubin Observatory is a new
telescope that'll be coming online in
the next couple of years to complete the
widest most detailed survey of the sky
ever conducted
this Legacy survey of space and time or
lsst may finally tell us once and for
all if Planet 9 is out there
Riven Observatory is a Next Generation
survey telescope that is set to observe
the entire night sky every few nights
repeatedly for 10 years the idea being
we can build up not only a deep image of
the sky but also a multi-color movie
unlike telescopes like the Hubble Space
Telescope the Reuben observatory's field
of view is extremely wide and thanks to
its giant three gigapixel camera which
is the size of a small car
it can also detect incredibly faint
objects lurking in the outer regions of
the solar system
so then narrow field of view telescopes
like Hubble can take a closer look
because it's a survey telescope we have
a plan to go and do this survey across
the night sky but then also process all
the images and reduce those to catalogs
so that astronomers can come along and
then they can look at the catalogs and
they can do searches for unusual objects
or things that match what they're
looking for just using the catalogs that
we're producing
that'll help scientists solve the
mysteries of Dark Matter Dark Energy map
the Milky Way and inventory moving
objects throughout the solar system like
tnos
so for example in the solar system
almost every population of object that
you can think of in the solar system we
will detect about 10 to 100 times more
of
we will take 2 million images over 10
years which is actually 4 million actual
pictures of the night sky so each image
is 3.2 gigapixels and we take about 1600
images per night that's about 20
terabytes of data per night foreign
to find objects within our solar system
the telescope will take two images of
every patch of Sky separated by an hour
and from the motion of the points of
light over that hour they'll be able to
distinguish between faint stars and
objects within our own solar system
that's a problem for planet nine though
objects that are far beyond Neptune will
be difficult to detect from the motion
of only an hour
another problem is planet nine may be in
the northern hemisphere sky
due to the frequent clear skies and low
light pollution
Reuben Observatory is strategically
located below the equator in Chile and
will mostly see southern hemisphere
Skies
but if it is there
Urban Observatory is equipped to find it
colleagues who believe in
even colleagues who
really hard to say definitively that
it's out there
we have to go and look so one of the
things that lsst can do is actually
contribute by surveying more of this guy
so people are already looking for planet
nine but given the fact that you have to
look at a large amount of sky and you
need to look for very faint kind of
objects that's kind of can be a slow
process so lsst will be able to do that
much more quickly so within the first
year of of surveying the sky lsst could
see if there was a planet nine within
its survey footprint down to the
magnitudes that we can see
the other thing though that we can do is
provide further constraints on what the
orbit could be because a lot of the
constraints so far come from these also
relatively rare
very distant objects
and we'll find a lot more of those too
we'll also be able to tell if it really
is just a bias in the observing data
even if the planet isn't found it may
give astronomers more data to find it
during future surveys
or it may show that there are other
explanations for the orbits and tilts of
these tnos as some scientists have
argued
either way a hunt to find Planet 9 will
undoubtedly lead to the location of new
undiscovered tnos and whatever else is
in our neighborhood
from the perspective of daily life No
One's Gonna Change their daily habits
you know start brushing their teeth more
or whatever you know because there's a
planet hundreds of times this as far
away from the Sun as is the Earth but at
the same time look I mean it is part of
human nature to explore right it is it
is part of human nature to ask the
question of what's out there what lies
beyond the ocean what lies Beyond this
hill what lies Beyond this planet War
lies Beyond the Edge of the solar system
um there's something deeply satisfying
about asking and answering these
questions that I think is is really
important to kind of our Collective
Human Experience
foreign
World On Demand
foreign leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
the bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions transport industry
a building's electricity all of those
things everything you need to know about
our changing environment the politics of
global warming we can and we will deal
with climate change in the fight against
climate change when we're green as you
covered
building new things has led to some of
Humanity's biggest leaps forward we made
tools Forge New materials and learned to
produce them for millions and then
billions with every new innovation comes
new Industries new economies new
challenges and we're always looking for
what comes next
the industrializations phase I think
will be one of the great economic booms
of this century
space offers a whole new environment to
create things things we can't make on
Earth gravity in general is something
that we all just take for granted
because it's just always here it affects
everything what becomes interesting is
what happens when you take that away
private companies are creating new
materials 3D printing tools even living
tissue and developing the technology to
build entire factories in space
if successful for-profit manufacturing
could lead to a new Gold Rush
launching the business of space to its
next giant leap
Elon Musk and Richard Branson and you
know Jeff Bezos and many other
industrialists they're making big
Investments to go up there but there has
to be a why there has to be a reason to
go to space we want to see a very robust
commercial Marketplace in space but the
other thing that we have to do is we
have to prove we have to prove the
industries that ultimately are going to
be able to take advantage of the
microgravity environment of space in
space we're opening the way to private
Enterprise since the 1980s companies
have been investigating the unique
properties of microgravity yielding
major breakthroughs in the areas of
biomedicine and Advanced Materials
research and now some are looking to
start production Manufacturing in space
has at its core the following idea this
extraordinary environment with a
completely different set of
environmental factors than the earth can
enable you to manufacture things that
you couldn't manufacture on Earth that
have value
our economy has historically been a you
know a value-added economy right we take
raw material and we turn it into steel
and we sell that steel for a profit
finding new ways of making things is
historically the makings of economic
boom three two one zero
July of 2019 spacex's CRS 18 launched
with over a dozen new research projects
including investigations being conducted
by Goodyear and Adidas
both companies hope that studying their
products in microgravity could unlock
new opportunities
also aboard the mission is a biomaterial
3D printer and with it the chance to
print whole human organs
go ahead
so you were working with the DMC to go
ahead and get our Command window open a
little early correct
yes bandwidth is available
okay so I'm just testing where the
numbers are and um
making sure they're too hard
[Music]
Christina we should be good to go
hands-free now
copy the thumbs up we do want to start
by opening up the cassette kit
it's just past 3 AM and the team at
techshot is prepping their initial
printing Run for the newly arrived bio
fabrication facility or BFF fueled by
coffee and the type of food you might
expect to find at 3am the team is
working directly with astronauts aboard
the ISS all from the comfort of techshot
headquarters located just outside
Louisville Kentucky now we want to
double check the smart pumps are in the
up position
we're going to be sliding the cassette
in and we just don't want to bump them
with the cassette I see that looks great
um we are good to go ahead and put the
door back on
we'll be able to do some printing
definitely
from the outside the BFF doesn't look
that much different to traditional 3D
printers but inside these smart pumps
are being loaded with living cells and
for the company all eyes are focused on
the inaugural drop Paving the first
biological brick on the long road to
printing human organs
currently there's over 113 000 people on
the organ donation list and 22 people
are dying every day because there's not
an organ available BFF has that
long-term potential to someday maybe be
able to provide some hope and a cure for
some of those people this is John John
Bellinger the C the CEO of techshot a
comp
eted over 30 years ago while his latest
project just succeeded in its initial
test prints the BFF has a long way to go
before it's printing anything as complex
as a human liver or heart techshot is
demonstrating the BFF technology with
this current flight and we anticipate
being able to print organs and
structures might be five to ten years
out bio princes have been on Earth for
over a decade and can print things like
ear and nose cartilage that are living
tissue but for complex systems like
organs the difficulty has been printing
the vascular networks within the tissue
itself without vascular tissue to
distribute the needed nutrients any
printed cells would die off well before
they could be used
and techshop believes that gravity is a
big part of the challenge
so let's just say that you want to
create something that has one layer of
cells and then on top of that a
different layer of cells and on top of
that like a third layer of cells so one
way that you could do that would be to
just print one cell in a layer and then
your second layer with another type of
cell and then your third layer with
another type of cell but depending on
those materials over a short period of
time those cells may not stay in those
layers they may settle out and then end
up combining you know you think of you
know printing if you try to print with
water here on Earth you know what would
happen it would just squirt out like out
of a water gun and that is because in a
gravity environment you know everything
wants to just squirt out and wet out and
spread out in the microgravity
environment you don't have to worry
about any of that so you have a much
wider range of materials that you can
print with to combat the effects of
gravity on Earth researchers have used
scaffolded structures in order to
support the growing cells
the problem is a lot of ways that that
is accomplished isn't necessarily the
best for biology it can limit the types
of materials that you can use and it can
also limit the types of cells that can
really thrive in that environment in
microgravity you wouldn't necessarily
have to do that you could have your
different layers or areas or sections of
different types of cells and put them
next to each other and there are no
other forces that are going to cause
them to mix so you have this opportunity
to be able to make these small regions
in three dimensions in a different type
of way and different type of structure
that would be very difficult to do on
the ground
microgravity enabled bioprinting still
has numerous hurdles to cross before it
can produce a product for sale only now
that the printer is operating aboard the
ISS can researchers begin to understand
the correct materials and process
necessary not only to print organs but
to culture and preserve them long enough
to return back to Earth but all at time
and research is part of techshot's plan
techshots business model is to be a tech
engine we're generating new technologies
and then if we feel like that technology
has a potential commercial potential we
spin that off into a different company
or to a different group they liken their
business to Levi Strauss in the 1800s
during the Gold Rush Levi Strauss
started out by providing canvas material
for tents and wagons and when those
miners needed a more durable fabric the
now iconic blue jeans were born the
business model of selling pickaxes as
opposed to going out and panning for
gold really certainly applies to space
and there are many companies at the
component level that are providing
products and services to launch
companies to satellite operators to NASA
one of the challenges in that business
model is you need a gold rush
it's not clear that 3D printed organs
could set off any kind of a gold rush to
space so in order to stay in business
techshot needs to have other projects
making sure it doesn't keep all of its
eggs in one satellite
this is my science fair project that I
started in eighth grade the whole
experiment was to see how the chicken
embryo develop in space without the
presence of gravity
this science project evolved into the
space shuttle project
imagine this chicken egg in the back of
the barnyard
gravity is causing yoke to fall to the
bottom of the egg now the hen has a
natural instinct of turning that egg
around therefore the yolk will fall go
back up to the top and gravity pulls it
back down to the bottom again now what
would happen to that egg up in space
the project was sponsored by Kentucky
Fried Chicken in which their worldwide
headquarters is located in Louisville
and so the the engineer that I worked
with Mark duser he and I are the ones
that decided to start techshot and start
it right here in Louisville Kentucky we
started in a motel it was just two two
rooms and eventually we went into four
rooms of the motel and then as as Tech
shot matured and developed and gained
more projects and more opportunities
then we decided you know we're in this
for the Long Haul and so we built a
world-class research facility here that
we're sitting in today
and here just across the street from
that first motel room techshot is
currently working on 15 active projects
creating technology for NASA the
military and major pharmaceutical
companies all with the goal to support
researchers in microgravity last year
was techshot's best year in its history
I think that's reflective of the
excitement of the new opportunities that
are out there for space and if they're
lucky one of these projects could yield
that Catalyst of a space Gold Rush
but they aren't alone in this race
another company located in Silicon
Valley views making things in space as
core to their mission even down to their
name
this is fiber optic cable it works
because the fiber reflects light over
and over inside the structure and even
if you bend it the light still comes
through the other end but in this
application it's nothing more than a
modern looking lava lamp the best fiber
optic cable is being used to transmit
data all over the world in fact undersea
cables carry 99 of all the data that
crosses oceans optical fiber usually
made from silica is important because it
can transmit data incredibly quickly
over a long distance before needing to
have its signal Amplified but research
done by the US Air Force in the 1990s
proved that it would be possible to
produce a fiber known as z-blan that
could far exceed traditional silica
fiber the only catch it needs to be made
in microgravity
z-blan is an optical glass that has a
transmission window that's about five
times wider than traditional silica
glass and it has a it has a signal loss
that's 10 to 100 times better than
traditional silica glass this is a
yo of May have made base a company with
a mission to create a new industrial
foothold in space and its CC bland is
potentially the first material that can
be made in space and sold on Earth so
this is a preform of Z blend it starts
out as this nice dog bone cylinder and
then it gets inserted into a furnace
this gets thinner and thinner thinner
than the width of your own hair and then
you start pulling that and so if
everything works out you get a spool
like this from our earlier test runs
basically looks like fishing line
while it is possible to produce sea
Bland on Earth it's nowhere near the
potential of what you can produce in
microgravity earthy Factor zebling
suffers from tunic crystals in the in
the material and basically what happens
is when light or power goes through
these don't Crystal domains they reduce
each time creating a power loss
throughout the the length of fiber
you're going through microgravity
suppresses these formations and doing so
creates more of a mono crystalline
structure so you have all these domain
uh drops and you have less of a power
drop over that length of fiber
you know you can go transatlantic and
trans-pacific without having repeaters
in the lines like traditional fiber
lines do today
you can imagine providing 5 10 50 times
more bandwidth down the same line of
fiber by by using Z Bland instead of
silica that you begin to you begin to
scratch the surface of the of the
economic potential of zebling they
estimate that a kilogram of z-blan could
sell for tens if not hundreds of
thousands of dollars and that high price
per kilogram is important when it comes
to space Manufacturing
historically a barrier to doing a lot of
commercial activity in space has been
that it costs so much money to get to
space do things and then come back
you know it can literally cost like tens
of thousands of dollars a kilogram to
launch operate and return and that's why
things like Z blend are so attractive
because we can sustainably sell them for
tens of thousands of dollars a kilogram
meaning at some point whole factories
could be created in space
receiving raw material from the ground
and shipping microgravity enabled c-blan
back to Earth
but the problem is it's all still
theoretical made in space has been
working on Z Bland for over four years
and has flown four missions to test
their manufacturing techniques with more
planned in the future but they still
expect to be a few years away from
producing a product that could be sold
on Earth let alone scaling that to
larger Industries it's very interesting
um and a little counter-intuitive
the most successful companies in space
are the companies that consistently say
how can I do this on Earth
there have been many products that
started with the vision of actually
Manufacturing in space and ended up with
a discovery phase in space and
Manufacturing on Earth and that's good
news for consumers that's good news for
the end users of those products because
that reduces costs you don't build your
manufacturing plant on the most
expensive real estate you can possibly
get a hold of you build your
manufacturing plant where you can
manufacture economically for made in
space though discovering the first
product that can truly be made in space
is more than just profit and loss the
establishment of space manufacturer
z-blan as a product line
is is core to our vision right that's
that's the industrialization of space
right there that's the Netscape moment
of low earth orbit commercialization if
in our research development for zeblance
say we found ways of improving z-blan
that we could actually apply to rust
really like apply in a gravity field we
would be excited about that you know for
us we'd take the profits from that and
plow that back into doing more cool
space stuff
smaller companies also invest
ing that can be Eastern space they've
already laid the groundwork for a whole
new way of thinking about in-space
Manufacturing and they call it arcanote
so arcanon is is one of many steps
toward those broader Visions Argonaut is
a more of a capability than a thing the
capability can enable virtually
anything you can think of in terms of
structures in space you can build large
things small things that are optimized
it doesn't really matter archonaut
Blends robotic manufacturing with 3D
printing allowing it to create and
assemble products in space meaning
instead of flying something like say a
satellite to space you could create them
there but before made in space can use
arcanort as an in-space Factory it needs
to turn its Vision into a sustainable
business
there is no shortage in space of
Visionaries what I really want to try to
achieve here is to make Mars The
Impossible The Visionaries that we are
seeing succeed are the The Visionaries
that that attach their Vision to an
incremental pathway
[Music]
I'm very fortunate to work closely with
NASA for a number of years in developing
uh gravity independent Manufacturing
Technologies and the first one of those
technologies that we really tackled was
3D printing International Space Station
has its own 3D printer and look at this
astronauts created the first object to
be made with it it's a white printer
part the first print that we did was a
little a plate for the printer and it's
a NASA and it said maintenance based on
it is it fair to say like the person you
made in spaces in marketing I mean
the first we actually kind of joked that
the first thing we did was demonstrate
that you could make like self-repairing
robots in space to date made in space
has created over 200 objects aboard the
ISS and with its second printer named
the additive manufacturing facility they
were able to not only prove their
technology but turn it into a business
we struck kind of an interesting deal
with them where we actually retained
ownership of the device and and actually
operated as a service and you know
printed parts for NASA for other
individuals for companies for schools so
really starting to build almost this
machine shop in space kind of business
model the approach that we've taken at
made in space has been to have these
really great this really inspiring big
Vision we take those big that big vision
and we decompose that into digestible
chunks like Steps like along that path
toward these fantastic Futures and that
first incremental step for arcanote is
to change how we think about
manufacturing satellites
Argonaut 1 Project is a free-flying
satellite which will manufacture 10
meter booms and those 10 meter booms
will have solar arrays on them which
allow a small sat to manufacture on the
order of about a kilowatt of power
the Arcana 1 Mission will look
where logic aims to reduce the cost of
putting satellites into orbit while
satellites have been getting smaller if
you need a satellite that'll require
lots of power you'll most likely need a
massive solar array but large arrays are
difficult to fit into rocket payloads
the so-called tyranny of the Fairing and
it gets expensive one way around this
problem was to spend heavily on
Engineers to devise solutions for
folding arrays into compact
configurations
then deploy at their full size once in
space but all at work and extra weight
on a rocket can add tens if not hundreds
of millions of dollars to a launch cost
archonaut gives satellite makers a new
Option include a 3D printer and robotic
arm onto their existing satellites and
arcanort build their very large solar
arrays in space this could reduce the
cost of getting power hungry satellites
into orbit and potentially open up whole
new Industries to space
probably the most significant factor for
the financial success of a space-based
or space related business is economies
of scale the more activity there is the
more feasible it is
both made in space and NASA hopes that
arcanal will help reduce the cost of
doing business in space but it's still
unclear whether larger and cheaper solar
arrays is the answer to finding scale in
production a successful strategy for
manufacturing in space is to demonstrate
capabilities and to have adaptable
capabilities that can serve different
customers when you combine that robotica
assembly and additive manufacturing it
really opens the door for customization
for clients remember folks may say hey I
actually don't need that much power
because of my mission I need but I need
a big antenna or I need a large radiator
Argonaut because it's general means that
I can provide those Services
quickly and at low cost so we hope that
folks see what we're doing and are
inspired by it and say hey this is what
I need so yeah it'd be great if somebody
came to us and said this is the thing
that we want to make if we're like oh my
gosh that's that's the killer app
the hope for arkanot just like with
zeblan and organ printing is that one of
these businesses can be that spark for
space industrialization
I think once people see the potential of
microgravity I think a lot more people a
lot more commercial entities will get
involved in space research because I
think it is such a unique environment
that that different way of thinking
leads to Innovation and so I think you
see so much excitement so much interest
because the potential to come up with
new products new Innovations is real
the ability to manufacture in space
means that we kind of break the tyranny
of the of the launch variant right and
we can now make structures that are
really enormous like big structures that
are on the size and scale the things
that we're we're comfortable with and we
interact with on Earth you know on a on
a you know a consistent basis you know
like larger buildings multi-story
buildings nothing like that exists in
space but we need to be able to make
structures and spacecraft and habitats
that are that size if we are really to
to you know sustained sustainably move
into space move into low earth orbit and
Beyond
and this industry enters low earth orbit
we'll begin to explore the next
financial future the Moon Mars even
asteroids contain potentially invaluable
resources on the next giant leap we'll
explore the private companies developing
the technology needed for off-world
mining but in order for it to become a
business it'll take another giant leap
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
it sounds like a movie a space rescue
mission an out-of-control satellite a
team of Engineers but it's not
foreign
scientists based near Oxford in England
will spend the next few months trying to
do something that's never been achieved
steer a spacecraft in orbit to grab a
satellite that's tumbling around the
earth at almost eight kilometers per
second
guided using an array of laser and
radiometric positioning devices Astro
scales LCD chase a vehicle will use
delicate Thruster movements to match the
target's chaotic spinning motion so it
can latch onto it with a robotic arm
they're not just doing this to prove
they can this is a business venture and
success could give Britain's space
industry a head start in the race to
solve a problem that's threatening the
viability of future space investment
there are more than 8 000 tons of
useless space junks zipping around the
planet made up of around 26 000 objects
wider than 10 centimeters that could
smash a satellite to bits in a collision
that could knock out vital functions
from Earth observation to disaster
management navigation weather
forecasting and remote Communications
it already happened in 2009 when an
active iridium communication satellite
collided with a defunct military
satellite made by Russia the U.S China
Russia and India have added to the
debris Problem by testing their ability
to blow up a satellite with a missile
the assortment of orbiting rubbish now
ranges from Tiny scraps of discarded
rocket stages to Envy sat an observation
satellite as big as a London bus and
solar arrays wider than a soccer pitch
that's been drifting out of control
since it failed almost a decade ago
there are more than 1 900 active
satellites in low earth orbit now Elon
Musk and others plan to launch as many
as 10 000 more to offer broadband
internet services from space
that investment boom could be
short-lived if more collisions Cascade
into further smashes that cause a
massive debris that leaves the most
useful portion of space unusable for
centuries
the world got a wake-up call in 2019
when a European satellite was forced to
change its position in orbit to avoid
colliding with a communication satellite
operated by Elon musk's SpaceX
if British companies can Corner the
market for pulling space junk out of
orbit it would be a rare cause for
celebration in a National Space industry
that's faced years of under investment
the UK's departure from the European
Union has been painful for the country's
space industry which traditionally
leaned on European partners for
engineering expertise and help with
managing complex projects
the UK is the foremost military power in
Europe and a permanent member of the U.N
security Council with a nuclear
deterrent yet France whose economy is
similar in size to Britain's spends far
more on space and has its own
well-funded National Space Program
alongside its involvement in the
European Space Agency
brexit means cooperation with the EU in
Secure government Communications cyber
security and new areas like Quantum
Computing is now effectively over
Britain has been denied access to the
top tier of Galileo Europe's answer to
the U.S military's GPS after investing
hundreds of millions of pounds in the
navigation system and supplying many of
its major components
through all the confusion over Britain's
future in space one thing everyone seems
to agree on is there's an opportunity to
carve out a niche in cleaning up orbit
and managing Space Traffic
the UK has expertise in space law and
regulation powerful military radar and a
center for monitoring space weather
its diplomats have been working quietly
for years to build Global support for
Norms of behavior in space from
designating clear orbits to ensuring
spacecraft owners pull down their
equipment at the end of its life so it
burns up on re-entry musk and Jeff Bezos
could be among the first to spend
serious money on removing space junk the
first generation of their satellite
Broadband constellations will need to be
replaced after five or six years and
they'll need someone to sweep the orbits
clean to make way for thousands of newer
more sophisticated satellites here the
UK's shoestring space budgets might turn
out to be an advantage astroscale says
it's had to produce its Solution on a
small budget that low cost could finally
be what convinces the owners of
satellites to open their wallets and
subsidize a new push for cleaner safer
Skies
this is how we move I'm Tom Pfeiffer for
more on the future of travel follow us
on quick take and Bloomberg
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
civilizations
[Music]
capable of communicating with us
in impact on ourselves of contact with
another intelligent civilization is now
being discussed by serious thinkers the
world over
it seemed to me just Perfectly Natural
that we would not be the only
manifestation of of life in the cosmos
out there is a million other
civilizations and they're all a lot
smarter than us
we now know without a doubt that the
possibilities for life are are literally
innumerable
and we haven't begun to look we have way
more places still to go
so we take very large telescopes and we
point them at nearby stars or nearby
galaxies and look for that special kind
of radio signal that we think is only
produced by technology
it's time to commit to finding the
answer to search for life beyond Earth
we are life we are intelligent we must
know
foreign
we are literally doing an experiment to
find out what the answer is rather than
doing what we've done for Millennia
which is to ask the priests and the
philosophers what we should believe
about life beyond Earth
Dr Jill Tarter is part of a movement
known as seti the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence
she's dedicated her life to it
she's also the inspiration behind Jody
Foster's character in The sci-fi movie
contact so if it's just us
[Music]
seems like an awful waste of space
today seti is a mission involving
scientists from around the world so what
city searches look for is
electromagnetic radiation like radio
light that is different than the radio
signals that we get from natural objects
like stars and galaxies and quasars and
consistent with the kind of light or
electromagnetic radiation that's
produced by technology
Andrew Simeon heads up a team at
Berkeley University we're up to 8.8
petabytes at Greenback for 10 years they
will be scanning the cosmos as part of a
hundred million dollar privately funded
initiative technological sources have a
very interesting property which is that
they can compress electromagnetic energy
in time or in frequency so you can have
a lot of energy a lot of radio energy at
just one place on the radio dial and
that's something that nature doesn't
tend to do
the team's work is the most
comprehensive search ever undertaken in
nearly six Decades of seti efforts
and technological advances mean that the
search is finally building momentum
what we've done for a number of years is
to go to a large radio telescope
presumably a national facility and rent
time or figure out a way to piggyback on
other people's observations and so we
wanted to get to a situation where we
were doing seti 24 7.
290 miles Northeast of San Francisco is
the Allen telescope
a cluster of small dishes dedicated in
large part to seti research the Allen
telescope array is the first time we've
ever built a large radio telescope out
of a lot of small dishes
the joy of having small dishes is that
they look at a large area on the sky all
at once
ultimately we'd like to have 350 of
these six meter dishes here right now we
have 42.
foreign
alongside more telescopes more powerful
computers offer a chance to expand the
search
quantity of data produced is staggering
with our our next generation of radio
telescopes we'll be ingesting as much
data from just one telescope as is
coursing through the entire internet at
any given second
so we collect a massive amount of data
from the telescopes that we observe with
and some Snippets of that data are
actually brought back to our lab here at
Berkeley there's this like gradual
roll-off that we actually have to look
for the sorts of signals that we're
trying to find and to do that we develop
powerful algorithms including algorithms
that use things like machine learning
and artificial intelligence
scientists now know that most stars have
planets Jill Tarter believes this
radically increases the chances life is
out there
[Music]
when I was a graduate student we knew
about nine planets those in our solar
system
but we didn't know about planets around
other stars not at all
today we know that there are more
planets out there than Stars
every Star has on average at least one
planet and usually more so that is a
huge game changer the universe seems a
lot more potentially bio-friendly and
now lots of people are interested in the
question of life beyond Earth
there are more stars and grains of sand
in all the beaches in the world if you
look at one of these grains of sand and
say that's the sun and the third planet
around its habitable
and you look at
the beach I mean how could it happen in
one grain of sand and not in others
so we're very optimistic about seti
it's probably just a matter of us being
able to recognize what a very Advanced
civilization would look like
Lawrence Doyle was part of the NASA team
that used the Kepler space telescope to
hunt for planets outside our solar
system but now he's bringing the search
back down to earth there are various
kinds of intelligence but the one that
seti is going to detect is going to be
communication intelligence everything
communicates all animals and even plants
communicate it's just a matter of how
complex is that communication
I thought well why aren't we studying
non-human communication on Earth
so as a proxy for an extraterrestrial
signal we proposed starting with
bottlenose dolphins and humpback whales
and squirrel monkeys to kind of design
an intelligence filter for seti so that
we can recognize the general rules of
intelligence
so we've devised various ways of looking
at a signal a message and analyzing how
complex what the relationships are
between signals
human linguistics
the relationships are called syntax
if you're missing a word you can recover
it if you're missing two words in a row
you can still recover three you can see
it gets harder if you go up to nine
there's still a possibility you could
fill in those words but there's very low
connection if you're missing 10 words
you might as well just guess a word from
the dictionary so we go up to ninth
order entropy that is there are still
connections nine words away of grammar
and syntax all animals all people all
extraterrestrials they have to follow
these rules if they're transmitting
knowledge to each other
and if and when we get a message we can
recognize the complexity of that
communication system
we can say okay we go up to ninth order
entropy word entropy
squirrel monkeys probably go up to
second order
uh humpback whales we don't know yet we
haven't got enough data
extraterrestrial signal comes in and
they go up to not 20th order entropy
and we are going to know that their
communication system is to ours is ours
is the squirrel monkeys
foreign
[Music]
we are connected to this huge Cosmos and
we want to know what else might have
evolved out there
were we to know for sure that the
Universe actually many many times has
given rise to some sort of organism like
us that thinks and asks questions about
the universe itself I think it could
very much change our our perspective on
science and our perspective as humans
and I think the ultimate outcome of that
change in in perspective could be truly
truly amazing indeed
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I think I'm the only non-billionaire
that's doing this
[Music]
I mean you've got Jeff you got Richard
Branson you've got Elon and then you're
me I mean how is it that a guy from the
bottom of New Zealand that was once
coined by Mick Jagger as the the bumhole
of the planet can launch stuff into
orbit how crazy is that Peter Beck
really likes Rockets
foreign
liquid rocket engines hybrids the sheer
challenge of the engineering the
problems that you have to solve and it's
kind of what gets me going so much so
that he started rocket lab a small new
space startup often living in the shadow
of the bigger companies like SpaceX
but Peter's mission is a little closer
to home than Mars with rocket lab Peter
aims to make launching Rockets into
orbit as common as picking up your mail
the most important thing that can be
done in space right now is to make space
a domain that everybody can access
we started on day one with an absolute
clean sheet paper and you know we wrote
two requirements on that piece of paper
and that was must be launched really
really frequently and must be affordable
but the most important thing here is
getting to orbit like a freight train
just getting to orbit so so frequently
that you can use space as a domain to
build commercial infrastructure
so that's things like put it into net in
space so that every square inch of the
planet has internet and you know that's
that's truly game changing for
developing countries
always knew he'd do this for a living
one day even when his guidance counselor
disagreed my parents were called into
the school you know they believed that
my aspirations for a career were totally
ridiculous and unachievable and that I
should pursue a trade in in plumbing
because I was quite good at my hands
Peter ignored this advice and instead
built this a rocket bike
I did about a hundred miles an hour in a
night of a mile it's an amazing feeling
actually it's an ever-increasing
acceleration so where you point is where
you go and you just hold on
Days Later Peter has a staff of over 200
and Rocket lab is five launches away
from being in the black we we
successfully completed all our test
flights and we're now into full
commercial operations we're trying to
get to what launch one a month this year
and then next year we'll try and get to
one every two weeks and then we'll keep
doubling down on that rocket Lab secret
innovation
they were the first to replace aluminum
with stronger and lighter materials like
carbon fiber as well as employ radical
production techniques like 3D printing
we've got a factory full of rockets and
we started 3D printing engines when
people were making bottle openers and
cats Prosthetics nowadays if you look at
all the startup space companies they're
all printing their rocket engines and
they have one more little secret
location the great thing about New
Zealand is it was a it's a small island
nation in the middle of nowhere so that
launch site is the only private orbital
launch site in the entire world and it
has more launch availability than
America does as a country
you know the biggest thing to be done in
space is yet to even be thought of
because nobody's had access to the
domain to be able to experiment and
innovate we're just getting started the
definition of success for me is to
receive a text message from one of my
staff saying hope you enjoyed your lunch
Pete by the way another one launched
another one on the pad we can get to
that point where it launches that
commonplace that uninteresting and that
frequent in the world that we all live
in is a definitely an incredibly
different place maybe a better place I
certainly hope better plays it would be
a total fail if it's the worst place
[Music]
iron gold copper minerals are the
lifeblood of the world's economy from
the Arctic Circle to the Sahara Desert
the 1.7 trillion dollar mining industry
supplies raw materials needed for
everything from skyscrapers to
smartphones but mining also comes with
an increasingly critical environmental
cost one that may require us to think
about off-planet Solutions before it's
too late
Mission
asteroids moons and planets and our own
solar system hold an essentially
Unlimited Supply of untapped resources
the first trillionaires
will be those who mine asteroids
resources like gold platinum and rare
earth metals make some of those
asteroids incredibly high priced but the
most valuable elements may be our most
basic one what you want to mine in space
is what you need a lot of
and while humans have been mining for
thousands of years mining in space
requires new Innovative Technologies to
realize any potential business and
economic opportunities
such Technologies might just allow
Humanity to expand operations off Earth
and take that next giant leap
[Music]
these tiny dots represent the millions
of asteroids in our solar system
over the past two decades government and
private aerospace companies have been
investigating their composition location
and even possible payoffs to mine them
this one known as bennu has an estimated
value of 669 million dollars
ryugu 82 billion dollars
better yet an asteroid called Davida
which is valued at more than a hundred
trillion dollars and the reason for
these high price tags they're made up of
valuable metals like platinum gold and
iron we believe that asteroids have
Platinum Group Metals rare earth metals
in high percentages than you might find
on the moon for instance
only once in human history has an
asteroid sample been brought back to
Earth on the Japan Aerospace Exploration
agencies Hayabusa mission in 2010 and
even then the return sample was merely
dust particles and the total cost of
that mission approximately 250 million
dollars
one problem is that compared to the Moon
there's very little gravity
so somehow you have to attach yourself
to the asteroid
whereas on the moon the gravity will
hold your processing equipment in place
so the general answer to the question
can we bring
materials mind and space back to Earth
the general answer is no
bringing things from space to Earth only
makes sense if what is retrieved is so
extraordinarily valuable and just not
available on Earth and even returning
the most valuable asteroids could
drastically devalue those materials
take asteroid 16 psyche for instance
NASA is constructing a probe to launch
in 2022 to study the potato-shaped
object which is roughly 95 Metals
nicolian platinum and even gold some
estimates value the asteroid at 700
quintillion dollars
NASA says it may be the inner core of a
developing planet that somehow lost its
outer layers offering incredible insight
into how planets are formed
if someone did manage to bring large
amounts of this asteroid back to Earth
Supply the resources would Skyrocket
meaning we'd have more of the material
than we would have use for causing the
price to crash to almost zero
once we erode the Rarity of a high value
metal or mineral the value of that
terrestrially could drop significantly
experts agree that a more likely
scenario is materials mined in space
will stay in space jump starting a whole
new money-making industry any space
fairy Nation will have looked at what's
called in-situ resource utilization
which is a very common space term
meaning you use the resources where you
are so taking that model of
um if you need it in space mine it in
space what would you be mining mostly
you need fuel
there's something else much more
valuable for use in space that's
abundant on Earth
water
not only can water sustain human and
plant life for future manned space
missions the components of water
hydrogen and oxygen can also be
separated and reassembled to make fuel
the zero emission fuel called hydrogen
fuel is the same used in spacecraft
propulsion and Fuel Cell Vehicles
hydrogen fuel research in this new space
race could also Spur new technologies
that can help fight climate change by
speeding the elimination of fossil fuel
use on Earth and there's already a high
demand for it
and an immediate business opportunity
for risk tolerant companies wishing to
make a fortune
in a 2018 paper by industry government
and academic experts they estimated that
for an initial 4 billion dollar
investment in a moon water mining
operation which is about the cost of a
luxury hotel in Las Vegas about 2.4
billion dollars in Revenue could be
generated annually the sort of business
case 101 for mining in space is if
you're going to launch something from
Earth it's going to cost you about
10 or 20 000 dollars per kilo to get it
into space so if you need water for
something
in space and you can produce it for less
than ten thousand dollars a kilo then
do it in space
do you know how to launch Alliance Ula
they have put a price on water in space
they have said we'll give you this
amount of money for the water which
means people who are going out and
trying to produce that water now have a
customer
in 2016 the Ula announced it's willing
to pay around three thousand dollars per
kilogram for propellant in an orbit less
than two thousand kilometers in altitude
called Low orbit compared with the
estimated price of four thousand dollars
per kilogram to deliver the propellant
from Earth
most experts believe the Moon is a
logical starting point for this it has
more gravity than an asteroid making it
easier to land and its poles are thought
to hold vast amounts of water ice that
potential volume of water has made it
the focus of NASA's Artemis program
which aims to land astronauts on the
moon's Southern pole and also make the
space agency a critical first customer
for any water harvested on the moon
India Israel
the U.S Europe
everyone is now sort of focusing on the
moon and all of these government
programs are looking to set up shop for
a water mining
fueling station on the moon could
ultimately make current space Ventures
much cheaper and make future space
missions possible although entirely
theoretical at this point here's how it
could play out water is mined on the
moon and a fueling station is set up
this would provide the first customers
most likely government agencies with
water for human consumption and fuel for
spacecraft water derived fuel could also
be harvested on an asteroid vehicles or
propellant transports then carry the
fuel from the surfaces to a stable
storage point between the Earth and the
Moon
fueling stations can also be set up in
low earth orbit making it accessible to
satellites and other spacecraft as of
now satellites that run out of fuel are
decommissioned extra fuel would allow
them to stay in their orbits increasing
their lifespan
since using a rocket to get fuel out of
Earth's atmosphere is expensive
refueling in low earth orbit can greatly
improve the size type and cost of
missions in Space the commercial launch
industry like SpaceX would also benefit
from these fuel Depots the use of lunar
base propellant and commodities may also
provide a stepping stone for
interplanetary exploration but while
there has been a renewed interest in the
Moon it hasn't been easy in just 2019
missions to the Moon Surface by both
India and Israel resulted in landing
failures and the technology to mine and
extract these potential water reserves
on the moon and Beyond is still on
proven but some entrepreneurs are still
optimistic
the answer is yes the technology exists
we can put something together we can
send something to the Moon that can mine
water so we we are sort of like a
Trailblazers trying to figure out what's
going on in the moon what's below the
surface me honeybee robotics they design
drills used in NASA's past Mars missions
and have sampling and Mining systems
going on future plan missions to the
Moon Saturn's moon Titan Mars Moon
Phobos and Jupiter's moon Europa we've
been focusing on developing high-end
fully autonomous drilling systems from
literally iPhone size all the way to the
size that cannot fit inside this vacuum
chamber behind me
and that's why NASA has long relied on
their expertise unlike your everyday
drill from the hardware store their
drills overcome the numerous limitations
of space which include extreme
temperatures and low gravity that means
you have to be very very imaginative
very Innovative to solve these problems
you're essentially trying to do what we
do here on Earth but with a fraction of
the power with a fraction of a mass with
a function of the volume and drilling is
unforgiving if you get stuck
if something goes wrong there is no
second chance
the difficulty in drilling would delay
placement of the second probe until the
next day
one of their innovative ideas called
planetvac uses use impressed gas to
shoot material into a sample container
its ergonomic design allows it to be
inside the foot of a Lander
and was chosen to go with nasa-funded
payloads to the moon and Mars Moon
Phobos
for Mining and extracting water on the
moon they created the planetary
volatiles extractor or pvex and it not
only drills it mines
it's based off a drill that removes a
cylinder of material called a coring
drill but it's not just any coring drill
it's a it's a system with heaters on the
inside so you drill down the required
depth you heat up the material that's on
the inside of a coring drill and Ice
turns into vapor and vapeg moves up the
coring drill into a cold finger so
you're capturing water vapor like for
example in your freezer when you have
condensation vivex is a mining system it
can actually get into the soil it can
actually extract water it can actually
capture this water in a separate
container we have all the pieces
together and we can go to the moon on
Mars and mine it
when it's tested on the moon which may
happen in the next couple of years pvex
will be the first end-to-end mining
system deployed in space and they have
even more futuristic Ambitions to use
the pvex drill
like this one that not only extracts and
stores water but uses it to propel
itself like a flying kettle
wine or it stands for The World is Not
Enough it's a James Bond stuff it's very
futuristic it's a new concept of space
exploration the main idea is to send
hundreds of low-cost wine spacecrafts
all over the solar system to give a
clear atlas of asteroids that have water
resources
honeybee robotics is one of the many
startups that NASA is depending on to
develop new innovative ideas there is a
strong strong private public partnership
with NASA right now to come up with
lenders but we can send twice a year but
we'll put payloads to them on payloads
like instruments like Rovers and also
humans we're doing it it's happening
right now very very exciting times
by giving out multiple contracts NASA
reduces the cost for themselves and the
entire industry we want to have numerous
providers that are competing against
each other on cost and Innovation
driving down the cost and increasing
access to space and industrializing
[Music]
startup transastra with a new infusion
of two million dollars from NASA has
teamed up with other space startups and
educational institutions to prove its
process for harvesting and utilizing
water from asteroids without even
touching them Optical mining is our
patent-pending process for using highly
concentrated sunlight or light from
another source to excavate the surface
without having to use digging tools to
dig into it and this is very important
in space especially for asteroids to
help develop and prove this technology
they've teamed up with the Colorado
School of Mines it's known as the
optical mining test bed first they put
the simulated asteroid in a vacuum
chamber to recreate the conditions of
space
then they use liquid nitrogen to cool a
surface inside the tank called a cryo
trap then they turn on a giant light
bulb which imitates sunlight that they
then concentrate into a beam resulting
in very high temperatures the beam of
light hits the asteroid Target fractures
a sample and then water and other
materials are released and Frozen onto
the cryo trap the volatile materials
which include water methane carbon
dioxide other valuable materials that
are common and cheaper on the ground but
very valuable in space trapped on our
cryo trap that's pretty nice the same
way that we would trap those chemicals
in space for a real asteroid mining
mission
[Music]
Optical mining bypasses a daunting task
of trying to land on an object with such
low gravity that it could simply break
apart when touched and there's no drill
to potentially get stuck but for this to
work they're targeting smaller asteroids
the size of a beach ball for their Tech
demonstrator model with plans to
accommodate rocks the size of a cubic
tennis court and bigger in future models
we think the right thing to do is to
Rendezvous with the asteroid match
rotation with it
put a thin film bag around it cinch that
bag down and then de-spin the asteroid
and now you have the asteroid in a
container so you can work with it in a
practical way
transastera believes that harvesting
water on asteroids will not only make
space travel more affordable for Private
Industry but it will make NASA's
proposed missions to take astronauts to
the Moon Mars and even asteroids
possible within a budget that the U.S
Congress may be willing to provide
and we can cut out hundreds of billions
of dollars and actually make it possible
for NASA to do all those exciting
missions in a period of just 20 years or
so
um by harnessing the asteroids now
what's really cool about it is that by
using public-private partnership and
working with companies like transastra
the infrastructure for space resource
harvesting and Commercial transport in
space can be developed so by NASA doing
it this way and NASA becoming the first
user of these resources and this
infrastructure for its exploration
missions then that infrastructure is
Left Behind for industry and that can
create massive Industries in space like
it even becomes cost effective to build
a space hotel transastra and partner
momentous will be on a two-year contract
with NASA to build that asteroid Mining
and in-space transportation prototype
called mini B to provide Optical mining
in space
we live in a very exciting time where
we're going to be able to take that to
space and the resources of pace are
literally Unlimited and those unlimited
resources are what some universities are
betting on
the Colorado School of Mines where
transastera does its Optical mining
research they now offer a graduate
degree in space resources
our space resources program is the first
of its kind in the world
fear is anticipated to be a growing
number of jobs directly in space
resources but the the skills and
practices of space resources can be
applied to lots of other things a huge
benefit to space mining research is that
a lot of this technology can be
beneficial here on Earth
like their 3D printer that uses
materials on the moon or Mars to make
structures and is modeled after startup
icons 3D printer that is used to make
homes on Earth
their penetrometer is a tool on the end
of a robotic arm that's being developed
to take measurements on the moon but has
occasions for mining companies and even
a Rover in a lunar test bed that can
drill and Prospect for resources has its
benefits there are places on Earth where
mining companies and Equipment
manufacturers are looking at applying
smart robotic systems in terrestrial
lines they could go into places that are
not safe for humans
they could work in much more confined
toxic environments than a person could
and one country is doing just that and
hopes to leverage their expertise in
robotic systems for mining remote in
hospitable locations that are almost
mars-like
foreign
ly the administrator of NASA when the
head of the Australian space agency
visited
was saying
that the U.S is looking to Australia to
be doing development in this area of
extracting resources in space one of the
reasons why we in Australia want to get
into this area is because of the
strength of our mining industry the
strength of our mining Automation and
the strength of our mining research
we see it as a way that Australia can
establish a niche space capability
Australia's High wages have caused some
of the largest mining operations in the
world to seek cost savings by using
automation
Rio Tinto the world's second largest
mining company has fitted operations in
Australia with fleets of autonomous
trucks drills and even the first
driverless freight train Network
adapting these Technologies could prove
useful to space programs and the use of
space technology and mines such as
robotics would be useful on Earth the
Australian Center for Space Engineering
research at the University of New South
Wales in Sydney was founded in 2010 and
has 15 PhD current or graduated students
researching space resource Ventures
related to Australia's needs and
expertise
what we're trying to do at the moment is
to reduce the risk perceived by a large
company mining company for instance
when they approach this type of venture
I think one of the main reasons that
terrestrial mining companies should be
looking at this problem is that they
will benefit their terrestrial
operations by learning some of these
lessons so if they look at the way that
you need to automate on the moon that
will help their terrestrial operation if
you look at the way you would analyze
risk for this type of mind they must
learn new lessons which should hopefully
flow back to their risk analysis for
terrestrial Minds
although mining companies have
terrestrial mining expertise and
monetary advantages only time will tell
who will be the first to provide a
fueling station in space in terms of
making it happen
I actually don't think it'll be a
startup I don't think it'll be a space
agency and I don't think it'll be a
mining company but I think it will be a
big company
probably driven by a high net worth
individual
a company like blue origin SpaceX a
company like that not necessarily then
but something like that proving that
this kind of mining is feasible could
trigger an influx of profit-minded
companies migrating of the earth just
one industry that would stake a claim on
the vast wealth of space
not only is the universe a place for
exploration for private companies it's a
new resource
key which will unlock new possibilities
in technology manufacturing living and
working both at home and beyond Earth
and all of this will be the result of
our next giant leap
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions transport industry
buildings electricity all of those
things everything you need to know about
our changing environment the politics of
global warming we can and we will deal
with climate change in the fight against
climate change when we're green
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
the great sci-fi art of the mid-20th
century teased a vision of the future
with one distinct element in common a
life for humans in outer space whether
vacationing on an exotic new planet or
commuting to the moon for business space
travel seemed like it was just around
the corner
yet here we are a half century later and
only about 500 human beings have ever
left the bounds of Earth's atmosphere
but thanks to a set of ambitious private
companies betting on the promise of
space tourism that long-awaited future
could be here sooner than we think
[Music]
most of the history of space flight
governments have been the prime force
behind nearly every aspect from planning
to funding to crew selection foreign
but as early as the 1980s proposals for
commercial space tourism began to emerge
along with innovative solutions for
getting people there such as the wild
concept of sticking a 74-person
passenger cabin in the cargo bay of a
NASA space shuttle although various
non-astronauts have been selected for
Missions over the years true space
tourism didn't happen until 2001. when
an entrepreneur named Dennis Tito
coughed up an estimated 20 million
dollars to hitch a ride with the Russian
Federal Space Agency for a week-long
vacation aboard the International Space
Station 20 years later we're seeing a
new contender in this final frontier of
Tourism private companies it's becoming
a private Enterprise
situation still very high risk with the
high reward potential reward but you
know government is really out of the
business of flying people now and it's
it's really going to be companies like
Elon Musk and Jeff Bezos and Richard
Branson that that do that heavy lifting
commercial space tourism is usually
about taking the non-astronaut the
private citizen into an orbital or
sub-orbital flight so you get a short
amount of microgravity experience and
you can float and take some photos and
then you come back this was something
that technology had gotten to a point
where the private sector was going to
make a business out of this
there are multiple companies that want
to get to the place where they fly
people into space
the first of these is blue origin
founded in 2000 by Jeff Bezos using the
autonomous rocket system new Shepard a
tribute to the first American in space
blue origin plans to launch up to six
passengers at a time offering a rarefied
treat of 62 mile high views and a
momentary experience of weightlessness
booking officially kicked off in May
2021 with the very first seat to be
auctioned off for charity meanwhile
Richard Branson's Virgin Galactic has
also been pursuing a viable form of
suborbital Tourism aiming for a launch
in 2022 once Sir Richard himself has
taken a flight I'm hoping to be able to
go to space I'd love to be able to
coincide it with the moon landing and go
to space
so I've got the whip on the team and
we'll see how he goes
claims to have lined up over 600 seat
reservations so far including Justin
Bieber and Leonardo DiCaprio virgin has
projected that the final cost of the
ticket will be at least 250 thousand
dollars or roughly fifty thousand
dollars for each of the five minutes or
so of weightlessness that you'll get to
experience although costly both
companies offerings aim to make
sub-orbital flight a regular form of
Adventure travel eventually driving down
costs at scale to expand the customer
base beyond the orbit of celebrities and
billionaires the third major Contender
is Elon musk's SpaceX which has set its
sights even higher on orbital flights
which are a whole nother level of
complexity and energy and danger when
you go suborbital if you're just going
to go up above the Von Carmen line which
is 100 kilometers or about 62 miles you
only need to get up to maybe 5 000 miles
an hour to get up there and you go
basically straight up and then straight
back down you don't have the re-entry
heating that you would see coming in
from an orbital so when you go orbital I
don't care if you're a baseball or a
battleship you've got to go 17
500 miles per hour not just five
thousand miles an hour the energy is
involved Are Much Greater by doing that
SpaceX has gone another level up and
that's what they're doing with the
inspiration for visit inspiration4.com
for your chance to go to space
inspiration 4 is the first planned all
civilian Mission into orbit slated to
launch in late 2021 the crew will bring
their own set of diverse perspectives
and backgrounds and experiences to test
how a group of different people namely
people who aren't professional
astronauts could fare in space
until now astronauts have had to be
physically perfect and this mission is
changing that and so I feel incredibly
honored to to be representing those who
aren't physically perfect
at age 10 I was diagnosed with bone
cancer and I was treated at St Jude
Children's Research Hospital and I spent
a year there undergoing intense chemo
and also surgery that ultimately saved
my leg I now work at St Jude as a PA a
physician assistant and I work with
Leukemia and Lymphoma patients the kids
we work with are are so brave and they
are very excited to watch me go to space
because this is showing them that you
know they they're capable of doing this
as well hey Lee along with three other
crew members we'll spend three days in
space orbiting the Earth every 90
minutes before landing back off the
coast of Florida well when you think
about access the first the astronauts
for the United States came from the test
pilot side and and so women weren't
allowed to be a part of that we have
somebody in their 20s somebody in their
30s somebody in their 40s and somebody
in their 50s and so there can be access
in all kinds of way whether you're
talking about age whether you're talking
about gender what do you talking about
race and ethnicity and all of those
things
the first time you know people are going
up into space and not sent there by
superpower like the United States or
Russia or China well that's like really
significant
um and you know you you've got to you
know be very thoughtful about it the
whole game plan right now is to make
space like really affordable and you
know accessible for everybody so you can
have fishing buddies going to space
someday but the first is special
um and so with that we wanted to have
you know a crew selection process that
could make space available to Everyday
People
getting to space is only the first step
for space tourism the next challenge is
what to do and where to stay when you
get there
Axiom space is planning to launch the
first segment of a new commercial space
station in 2024. their two billion
dollar project called ax station will
become the first free-flying private
International Space Station
or to use a more consumer-friendly term
a space Hotel
Axiom isn't the only company out to make
your space stay a little more
comfortable iglow Aerospace has been
building what they call expandable
habitat technology like their b330 an
inflatable pod module that expands once
in orbit there's even one attached to
National Space Station right now they've
been testing it and you take it up and
it's rather small and then you inflate
it and it seems to be working very very
well this is likely to be the first kind
of tourist hotel that you're going to
see up in space first of all it's easy
to carry instead of this giant tin can
with all of that the Inflatables are
lighter you can just blow them up and
they they get a nice big size for about
you know half the less than half the
weight probably
but even as space missions become
accessible to civilians the risks of
going to space are incredibly high and
you could die a thousand ways that we
can think of in a thousand other ways
that we can't think of this is Michelle
Hanlon she's a space lawyer at the
Mississippi school of law focused on
protecting humans in outer space now I'm
not an attorney for any of the space
tourists so I haven't been privy to
their private
account that the FAA requires certain
waivers to be in those contracts so for
example the FAA says well we're not
going to make you make your spacecraft
to a certain safety level we are going
to make you spacecraft operator make
sure that you inform your space tourists
of all of that hazards that you know of
that I'd imagine a very long waiver all
the ways you can die in space
and you have to understand that there's
health risks and you have to indemnify
the US government if you are launching
from the United States so those are
things that we know a space tourist has
to sign and has to wait so now let's go
back and think about our space flight
participants the FAA calls space
tourists space flight participants they
don't call them astronauts why is that
important if you're not an astronaut
there's no obligation to rescue you if
something goes wrong it's a lot of money
to set up a rescue launch if it can even
be done it's something really important
to think about and that difference as we
as we cross this threshold from having
uh astronauts in space to having real
people like me in space and when we are
able to make it to space reliably enough
there's still a host of other legal and
ethical issues to consider before space
tourism can truly take off
there are so many gaps in space law that
we are going to have to put in a lot of
sort of basement ideas and so for
example the outer space treaty is a
treaty that offers principles and
guidelines for State activities for the
activities of national governments
doesn't talk about private entities
doesn't talk about humans in space so
now if something goes wrong so let's
think about all the times hotels on
Earth are sued right so slip and Falls
you step on something on in the bathroom
you see the hotel and it becomes a
private lawsuit because of the vagaries
of international law if something
happens in space well boy you can sue
the state that launched your spacecraft
you can sue the company that brought you
there you can sue the hotel you can sue
the individual you can sue every
government related to that because the
way the the outer space treaty in the
outer space regime have set this up is
that anything that happens in space
first has to go through a diplomatic
channel before you think about suing in
a court of law and so every single slip
and fall and Ace in a a space hotel is a
diplomatic Nightmare and so we really
need to figure that out before we before
we start sending a lot of people there
you think about human rights in space
here we don't think about a human right
to oxygen because it's kind of all
around us and free it's not in a space
Hotel so what happens if something
happens in the oxygen depletes who gets
the oxygen first and then of course
let's not even think about the labor how
do you treat your labor in a space hotel
where that person it may be there for
two or three years without committing
back to Earth so a lot of things to
think about
space habitats are more likely in the
near future to focus on Research
missions and be a home for experiments
that can't happen as easily back on
Earth uh space hotels I I think they
Garner a lot of headlines and a lot of
news but at the same time that's not the
first thing that you're going to see
happen they don't offer the compelling
business case I think that you'll see
from a place that wants to manufacture
Pharmaceuticals or a new type of Crystal
or some type of filament or Fiber Optic
Cables and other things that you can do
in microgravity the things that are
actually you know a high value
uh finished good when you get that back
to Earth and you sell it for a very very
huge profit margin that's what's likely
to happen in space as opposed to having
a a real estate platform that you sell
to a tourist a space Hotel it's really
interesting and it will probably happen
but it's not likely to be at the
Forefront of space Commerce
even if space hotels are right around
the corner don't get too excited about
booking a trip in one it's not a cheap
ticket to ride to space and and it's
going to be you know Millionaires and
billionaires and and that sort but at
the same time you know the point was
made that in the early days of Airline
trips that was also a completely
unaffordable ticket for most people
those people who flew were people of
means and over time it becomes
affordable to the masses and I think
that's the goal for all the
entrepreneurs in space as well to get
those costs down to a point where it's
not 10 million or 5 million dollar or
three hundred thousand dollar ride into
subordinable space when it becomes more
like buying a first class ticket to go
to Europe from the United States so that
that's the goal and you know the
question is can can we get to that point
given the immense operating costs of
getting to space it may be years if ever
until space tourism becomes a profitable
Venture for any of these companies
Virgin Galactic the only publicly traded
company of the three has had a
particularly Rocky year initially riding
on the momentum of a SPAC deal but more
recently beset by launch delays and
major funders including Branson himself
selling large quantities of their stock
in the company
Space is really really really hard and
it's an absolute cliche but it's one
that happens to be very true it's just
really hard to do that's also the reason
that you've seen the delays that you
know virgin had talked about flying
years and years ago and it became such a
crazy point that Richard Branson
actually stopped talking about it when
he was asked because it was never going
to be when he predicted but it's not
insurmountable and you know investors
have stepped up because this is
something that is doable foreign
despite the astronomical dangers and
costs of getting to space it may
ultimately follow the course of other
once fanciful modes of travel
Wright brothers having you know what was
by modern standards a very unimpressive
first flight you know at Kitty Hawk I
mean you know you had like less than 20
years later you had your first Airborne
ambulances being used to to save lives
fundamentally the world is a more
interesting place when people can go and
dance Among the Stars and such The Lure
of space is in a it's in our DNA it's
that that exploration bug we are an
exploratory species and we want to go
out there and see what's out there that
Vision that I had in 1969 of seeing
normal human beings traveling to space
it's finally beginning to happen when
you get a bunch of people up there and
they can all see it for themselves
that'll create even yet another
revolution in how we treat our planet
and the way we think about it
so while 2001 came and went without
quite looking like Stanley Kubrick's
ultimate space fantasy 2021 might
finally be the year we're catching up
access the financial World On Demand
foreign hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
most people who visit la come to see
something like this
but I come to see stuff like this so
This grimy part of La is Hawthorne
California it's not a lot to look at but
it is where all the aerospace companies
are located the old ones the new ones
like SpaceX and then even newer
companies like the one we're gonna visit
today that are trying to build Rockets
faster and cheaper than ever before
[Music]
foreign
relativity in its two Founders Tim and
Jordan have a plan to make rockets
faster and cheaper than anyone else to
do this they're looking to build every
part of a rocket its engine its fuel
tanks and its body with giant 3D
printers the relativity is building the
first autonomous rocket Factory and
launch service the basic problem that
these guys are trying to solve is that
Rockets remain very expensive and hard
to make
SpaceX is the cheapest most Nimble
rocket company around and it charges
about 60 million dollars per launch so
raw materials and propellant are five
percent or less of the cost 80 to 90
percent are labor and then the rest are
kind of operational fees and things on
the launch side and so it's really how
do you take that raw material make a
rocket that's actually going to work and
then fly it in the most efficient way we
believe autonomous manufacturing which
is how we think of 3D printing really
gets us to that point where we save a
lot of money
at this point you may be thinking dear
God not another 3D printing thing but
here's the deal relativity wants to sell
its rockets for 10 million dollars each
hitting that low low everyday price can
only happen if machines replace humans
on the factory floor and to put a novel
Twist on its 3D printers relativity is
making its own metal with this guy's
help
so I'm Sam Thomason I'm the lead
materials engineer at relativity I've
been in charge of sourcing Alloys
designing Alloys and tailoring all of
our processes to get the best material
properties out of all the parts that
we're printing we are looking at the
structure of the materials on a micron
level and so we want to see ductility
strength performability all that stuff
foreign
[Music]
it's insane to try and build a rocket
it's even more insane to have to build
the world's largest 3D printer along the
way but there's some reason to think
that these two guys in their 20s have a
chance at succeeding the founders both
built rockets at USC after school Tim
took a job at Jeff bezos's rocket
company blue origin where he specialized
in 3D printing rocket Parts Jordan ended
up at SpaceX working on engines
relativity has only been in business for
a couple of years and hopes to fly its
first rocket in 2021 they've raised
about 10 million dollars in funding and
count Mark Cuban as one of their
investors tell me how you first made
your pitch to Mark Cuban What did the
what it was the subject line in the
email the subject line was 3D printing
an entire rocket space is sexy bit any
bit within five minutes like his email
game is crazy
with a bit of luck okay with a few
thousand metric tons of luck these guys
hope not just to make rockets but to
alter the course of how and where humans
make all kinds of stuff
so we think a fully automated 3D printed
Factory with intelligent manufacturing
with a small footprint is what we need
when we're going out to Mars and
colonizing outside of space so
relativity's long-term mission is we
want to 3D print the first rocket on
Mars This is like a stepping stone
towards this future can you take it to
this you know a million people living
and working on Mars you're going to need
industrial technology to complement that
being able to send these machines and 3D
printers will really leverage and
augment what they're able to set up
early on
foreign
[Music]
our generation's biggest problem climate
change is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions transport industry
buildings electricity all of those
things everything you need to know about
our changing environment politics of
global warming we can and we will deal
with climate change in the fight against
climate change when we're green has you
covered
thank you
from the U.S China trade War a
controversial security law in Hong Kong
building in the South China Sea to
China's Global infrastructure projects
there is undeniably a cold war-like
battle for influence on all fronts
and that includes space
we're in a space race today
just as we were in the 1960s
good morning everyone we go live now to
Blue Origins facility it's about 30 35
miles from where I am in Van Horn Texas
to here at press conference before
astronauts who have safely returned to
Earth as well as Ariana Cornell who is
director of astronaut sales let's listen
in
side pieces represent the road to space
and our feather logo is the crossbar
and at the top a tiny blue sapphire
to remind these folks that they are from
planet Earth
and that they have a mission to protect
this home
with that said Oliver would you join me
[Applause]
[Applause]
make this easy
[Laughter]
I practiced
let me say something
Oliver
you have received a special gift of the
astronaut perspective
I know that you will
do good things with it and make the
world a better place
congratulations
[Applause]
Mark could you join me please
I'm so excited for you guys
[Laughter]
yeah I know you want to I'm going to
hand you this
Mark I hope this experience will help
you to continue to do the great things
you're doing for humankind
congratulations
Jeff join me please
[Applause]
there are a few people I know more
deserving of this Jeff
seriously and I don't know what you're
going to do next but I can't wait to
watch
congratulations
[Applause]
and Wally would you join me please
oh
60 years Wally
and I get to pin this on
wow the best bit I've ever had in my
life and I've had lots of them
well you continue to inspire us
um thank you so much for doing that God
bless you and congratulations thank you
more to come
foreign
the first four of millions to follow
again
the newest International astronauts the
crew of new Shepherd congratulations all
four of you
so without further Ado uh how was it
Jeff what was it like was everything you
imagined uh I'm gonna answer that
question but just real quick please I I
want to thank a few people
um first of all all of the engineers at
Blue origin who have toiled hard to get
this done the people who build the
vehicle all of our manufacturing people
this is a big team they've been working
on it for many years and they have done
an extraordinary job of building the
most reliable most beautiful uh most fun
I mean I can vouch for that I'll get to
that in a second vehicle and we owe them
a deep gratitude and
uh the people who kept us safe today who
operated the vehicle our trainers
everybody it's just huge uh I also want
to thank the town of Van Horn this is a
small and amazing little town
um and uh you know we're making a dent
in it and we appreciate you for allowing
us to be part of your town
and uh and then
I also I want to thank uh
every Amazon employee and every Amazon
Customer because you guys paid for all
this so seriously for every Amazon
Customer out there and every Amazon
employee thank you from the bottom of my
heart very much it's very appreciated
and uh you know now on to how it felt oh
my God
my expectations were high and they were
dramatically exceeded the uh the we were
talking about this a little bit uh in
the car right on the way back and
I don't know the the the zero g piece
may have been one of the biggest
surprises because it felt so
normal it felt so like almost like we
were as humans evolved to be in that
environment which I know is impossible
but it felt so Serene and peaceful and
the floating it's actually much nicer
than being in full one gravity
um it's a very pleasurable experience
just from this year just the way it
feels the tactfulness of it
that it you know the the most profound
piece of it for me was looking out at
the Earth and looking at the Earth's
atmosphere every astronaut everybody
who's been up into space
they say this that it changes them and
they look at it and they're kind of
amazed and awestruck by the earth and
its beauty but also by its fragility and
I can vouch for that
um when I look out you know when we're
sitting in this room and we're driving
our cars and we're moving around the
planet in our normal ways the atmosphere
is so gigantic you know where these tiny
little things and the planet the
atmosphere is so big but when you get up
above it what you see is it's actually
incredibly thin it's this tiny little
fragile thing and as we move about the
planet we're damaging it and you know so
that is
um you know that's that that's a very
profound it's one thing to recognize
that intellectually it's another thing
to actually see with your own eyes how
fragile it really is and that was
amazing who wants to add
Oliver you want to tell us how it was
our first paying customer
you get feel like you got your money's
worth sir
no it was so amazing to see it from
above and to move around like yeah I
totally agree it feels so natural like
almost like we should be doing this and
I hope that we are one of the first and
let's hope that many many more people
can do this because this experience you
should share with more and more people
it's so amazing and a special
congratulations to you on becoming the
youngest person to have ever flown thank
you
you brought with you up there the next
generation of Space Explorers but
certainly another flag up there the
Netherlands to everybody out there the
Netherlands there's the new Dutch flying
man there you go
Mark you should say that you told me in
the car about the g-forces I thought
that was really interesting
well I was uh I was surprised I mean
they had told us what you know the what
the g-forces would feel like on the way
up and
um you know again it's one of those
things that you hear about you
anticipate but
um you know you really feel them on the
way up it was incredibly exhilarating
and then
um you know on the way back down what I
had not anticipated so we hit five G's
briefly on the way back down
um and that's that's a lot of pressure
and unfortunately during the um the the
uh the status check for each each
astronaut by the time they got to
astronaut demo which was the name I was
flying under we were at five G's and so
they were like astronaut demo how you
doing dude okay I had a hard time had a
hard time responding but uh I'm not sure
what that video footage will look like
probably not very pretty but by the way
it was so exciting if you haven't
figured it out yet uh well Wally might
be the oldest person ever in space and
Oliver the youngest person ever in space
my brother is the funniest person ever
in space uh for sure I have before I
want to do a couple of more things
before we maybe go to next questions
which is I want to recognize two people
who here in the audience we are honored
today to have
uh Alan Shepard's daughters Laura and
Julie could you stand up just briefly so
we could say
and of course uh Alan Shepard was a
Apollo Moonwalker and has a gigantic
list of accomplishments but for our
purposes today uh the thing that is most
interesting about Alan Shepard is that
he is the namesake for this vehicle new
Shepherd and that is because the pro the
mission profile that we did today is
very similar to the one that Alan flew
when he became the first American in
space I guess 60ish years ago so that is
uh we're very honored to have you guys
here and thank you for joining us it's
incredible I I got some pictures with
them backstage and I know those are
getting blown up big thank you
so and I have a couple things to show
let's can we start you want to talk
about the couple of things we flew like
dude go ahead oh we did
um so we had the opportunity to bring
with us uh was actually on loan from uh
the Explorers Club uh we were able to
fly with a piece of canvas from the
right flyer
um so the the plane that the Wright
brothers flew we brought a piece of that
canvas with us which was really powerful
as well as a bronze uh Medallion uh that
was made from uh the first uh hot air
balloon flight in 1783 which was the
first time
um man ever uh you know left the Earth
in controlled flight so we were very
thrilled to be able to bring both of
those along with us and we brought those
precious objects back yes we did and the
Explorers Club will be pleased here
they're very happy about that and we
have one more thing which I would
actually just like to show you if you
could who has the goggles could you
please bring them up to me
yeah would you hold that for me
all right
these are Amelia Earhart's goggles
the one she flew across the Atlantic
with solo and you can see she put tape
over them to kind of make have less
light come in uh because it was just so
bright all the day and she was flying
for so long and they're just I I like to
think that if Amelia were here it should
be very very proud of Wally
foreign
[Laughter]
wherever you are we hope you're watching
all of this thank you
and while on that note
Wally
uh oh I'm sorry oh please go ahead thank
you Lauren just reminded me I have one
more thing which is and Christina I
might need your help on this but Mom
could you come up for a second where's
my mom
okay you don't have to come up I can
come to you
I have
I wore this
I wore this necklace
and it is a virgin feather and I word up
into space and now it's for you
[Applause]
I would put it on her myself but I would
okay
and now Wally last but not least Amelia
Earhart what a lovely uh transition an
aviation icon and now an aerospace a
space icon what was it like
I can't tell you I had such a good
instructor he chose us through
everything that we were going to do so
when I went up this morning
the noise wasn't quite as bad and we
went right on up and I saw Darkness I
thought it was going to see the world
but we were quite high enough and
I felt great it I felt like I was just
laying down I was just laying down and
I was going into space and I want to
thank you sweetheart because you made it
possible for me
I've been waiting a long time to finally
get it up there and I've done a lot of
Astronaut training through the world
Russia America and I could always beat
the guys on what they were doing because
I was always stronger and I've always
done everything on my own
and
I didn't do dolls I did outside stuff
and I and I threw airplanes that were 19
000 some hours
I loved it and I loved being here with
all of you and
the
family
and
the the four of us we had a great time
it was it was wonderful I want to go
again fast
[Laughter]
and then when I got off the ship they
gave me the tail end of one of the
balloons and I'm gonna cherish that
forever
uh and by the way we can confirm that
Wally once again in training
outperformed the men on the mission
100 I was going to say she
three boys up to the top of the crew
accessor Everybody saw that there's
video footage
indeed darling you did you did well so
Wally Funk now the world's uh oldest
astronauts who have ever gone to space
and perhaps the first founding member of
our blue origin uh frequent flyer
program
foreign
when I do lectures or wherever I am
around the world in the United States
I'm only 45.
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you're being generous I keep seeing
everybody every time somebody says oh
she's 82. I think there's a typos you're
28 Wally we know this well now well
thank you so much for for giving us your
impressions but let's see it with our
own eyes I'd like to roll the tape of
what it was like
[Music]
space
[Music]
dude look Oliver
that's great can you move your head a
little while yeah
I love it
look at the Blackness of space
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
he wants a Skittle
[Music]
s
it goes
oh
try again
[Music]
oh he's so good oh wow
incredible enjoy that oh I love it I
love it
it's a little different
oh wow
[Applause]
go ahead Mark I would say that was a
good catch
Wally was it everything you expected and
more you've been waiting as you said six
years to experience this I I loved every
minute of it I just wish it a little
longer because I have been in space
before I'm not in space but up in that
area and could do a lot more rolls and
twists and so forth but there was not
quite enough room for all four of us to
do all those things it was great I loved
it I could hardly wait to go again amen
yeah next next stop for you is the moon
Wally
any other Impressions now having seen
the video of it is it is it one of those
things where you just took it in and
it's hard to compare to video what are
other Sensations that come from having
seen that right now it felt way cooler
than it looked
well so after of course they're uh there
are four minutes of weightlessness the
fun that you had of course we got you
buckled back in and you descended under
those beautiful three parachutes I think
we've got another video here of your
descent back to our beautiful West Texas
Valley Why Don't We Roll that right now
that moment felt pretty good I'm not
gonna lie that's true when you see the
three main shoots out that's relaxing
well that's because it's actually dust
kicked up by a cushion of air that makes
you only hit it about one mile an hour
it feels like if you were to stand up in
your chair just kind of plop
laughs
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh my God
our family was happy to see us that's a
good sign what was that moment like
coming back and seeing your your friends
and your family here you have supported
them or they have supported you that is
your dreams to get to this point Oliver
your father is here Joseph thank you so
much for being here what was that like
yeah well he was a bit more emotional
than I would have thought like everyone
in the ground was way more emotional
than we were we were just having fun
it's so true
yeah yeah I think that our uh our family
has been extremely supportive through
all of this and I think that
um you know they're uh I know my wife
was an absolute Rock leading up to this
which made
um you know the adventure uh much easier
for me but I know that when we came down
it was sort of uh time to let those
emotions out a little bit so uh it was
it was great to see everybody and yeah
it was a little more emotional than I
had anticipated as well Jeff yeah I mean
um you know for I wasn't that nervous
but my family was somewhat anxious about
this and uh so it was it was so sweet
actually when to get hugged by them
after landing especially my kids and
Lauren and my mom and dad and really all
of you guys you know we have a bunch of
close friends here too and uh it just
makes me realize how much I love you and
how much I'm loved
and Wally your friend Mary is here
yes I am so happy she's here she knows
what I'm going through she's been she
was one of my flight students and I've
had many have been watching the live
post launch press conference uh down
from Culbertson County Texas you're
watching quick take stock right now
we've been following the blue origin
launch very closely today I'm Jennifer
zapasaja here in New York alongside my
quick take stock co-anchor for today
kriti Gupta uh and we are going to be
starting off covering all things space
related with our very own Tim stenovic
who is down in Van Horn Texas who has
been watching this whole entire really
exciting historic day play out Tim is
with us also joining us is Andrew
Shannon co-founder and CEO of procurium
which launched the first pure space ETF
in 2019 under the ticker UFO uh thank
you all for being here Tim really
exciting day for you let's just start
with you
um what's your reaction to what you
heard from those new Aster knots who we
have now as part of this this world
it sounds like they're literally on
cloud nine still so excited to have been
able to do this the flight was just over
10 minutes and they spent a few minutes
in weightlessness and we saw a video
during that press conference that
actually showed what they were able to
do most notable to me was really to hear
from Wally Funk she's 82 years old she's
really been preparing her entire life
for this moment to be able to go to
space and she trained as an astronaut
for the Mercury crew and she ultimately
the program that she was part of wasn't
was was ultimately canceled she wasn't
able to go to space but they put her
through every test that the the her male
counterparts and the Mercury crew were
put through she outperformed every
single one of them she just now sang
that she is ready to go back as far as
things were on the ground here in Van
Horn where I am 30 some odd miles away
from the launch side I was able to see
the rocket take off right over my left
shoulder we heard Sonic booms as the
capsule made its re-entry but we heard
them significantly later then they heard
them on the ground just because of how
far away way we were but it did seem
like at that moment that time certainly
stopped here coming up to that moment
guys we had so many people come and talk
to us and just ask us where we were
going to be watching from this was the
event here in Van Horn it attracted not
just International media but also
tourists who wanted to come and and see
the launch so a really exciting day here
in Van Horn
well Andrew let me bring you in here
because we've witnessed a very historic
moment here but let's bring this to the
market so bring this back to the market
is this the moment that we're going to
remember as the start of a lot of space
investing particularly through ETS
what's your Market take
this year has already proven to be a
pretty phenomenal year for investment in
the space industry both from private
companies to SPAC companies looking to
successfully dspac
um and certainly just new investors
coming into this industry so this is
truly an inspirational moment it's
fantastic to see another phenomenal
success happen today on the anniversary
the 52nd anniversary of the lunar
Landing another great achievement for
the overall space economy
so where does the Innovation go next
Andrew where does the investment into
the Innovation go next in your opinion
now that we've seen Branson and Bezos
both accomplish this
so now we have space tourism it's here
and if you can afford a ticket you can
get online and possibly be one of these
next future astronauts so yeah that's a
phenomenal thing for the space tourism
industry looking at Blue origin one of
their goals is to see permanent colonies
and settlements on the moon and they
want to help you know participate in
that they also want to be the roadway to
space and to the extent that they're
able to use these reusable Rockets dust
them off really quickly after they land
and send more things into outer space
they're helping to lower the cost of
launch and for the overall industry that
can bring new customers new new
governments and agencies and even
individuals that want to experience
space or bring their business to space
it makes it that much more realistic so
we're at this new commercialization for
the space industry and this is just one
of the many companies that are looking
to to have a big footprint in that area
manager help us understand what that
commercialization of space actually
looks like Adam Jones and Morgan Stanley
says that the space economy is going to
Triple by the year 2040. that's his base
case to just under 1.1 trillion dollars
uh what does that look like to you help
us help us make sense of it
so when you look at the the projections
and the current space economy today
which in 2019 the numbers came to
roughly 424 billion dollars for this
industry roughly a third of that was
represented by satellites and
Communications companies and if you look
at the projections of Adam Jonas or uh
Bank of America Merrill Lynch was just
projecting roughly 2.7 trillion by 2045.
they believe that roughly half of that
growth will actually continue to come
from Communications and satellites so
you know someone looking to to play the
space industry UFO has many companies
um providing that satellite exposure and
something that many people don't truly
understand how important satellites are
in our everyday lives whether you're an
individual a business or a government
Andrew let's talk about the players in
this market we've got Amazon we've got
Virgin Galactic we've got Tesla to some
extent SpaceX Elon Musk Company by
extension let's talk about who else can
really get involved here are we talking
about Lockheed Martin more Aerospace
defense companies are we talking about
potentially big Tech uh driving into the
space too what are your thoughts about
those new people who are now going to be
benefiting from this drop in barriers of
Entry
we're seeing players come from around
the world space is truly a global
industry in UFO we have roughly 35
companies with over 80 percent of the
weight of the index is actually focused
on these Pure Play names so companies
deriving a majority of their actual
revenues from space so you have
companies like Garmin which is a
specialist in GPS Trimble which is
helping companies uh track their assets
around the world uh SCS which is a big
Communications company out in Europe MDA
a Canadian company which just recently
IPO that helps build the Canada arm
which is something that's used in space
to help make repairs so there's you know
robotics there's satellites there's
companies that are helping with launch
as well so you really have a very
Diversified Group of companies from
around the world that are that are
leaving this charge to make space more
accessible Andrew do you worry at all
about the unpredictability and
potentially volatility though of the
industry because you know today the the
launch went well but you know we could
see things change depending on different
launches I mean how can how much does
that concern you
safety is as absolutely something that
needs to be one of the most important uh
milestones and and focuses for any of
these companies that want to operate in
space and you know some people choose to
play Space by picking an individual
company and putting all their eggs in
one basket UFO was designed to provide
investors with instant diversification
to over currently 30 publicly traded
space companies from around the world so
um you know I don't necessarily believe
that this industry is a zero-sum game
and you could have potentially many
winners but certainly also companies
that fail so this is something that you
know an investor that wants to own a
security that has the ability to have an
index that rebounds reconstitutes as the
players change over time as new Space
Industries come into the marketplace and
can become accessible for investors UFO
is something that investors can can
invest in to give them a reduced company
risk as opposed to trying to put all of
your eggs in just one basket
uh Andrew paint the picture for us
decades from now I mean this is
something I'm eager to ask you because
if we were to think back to 60 years ago
and Alan Shepard's First Flight uh into
space as an American we couldn't imagine
that 60 years later we'd be sitting here
Elon Musk would be sending tiny
satellites up into the sky to provide
internet access to the entire world
using satellites because there was no
internet then so what I'm saying is we
don't even know I think what the future
holds so so as somebody who looks at
this closely what does that Vision look
like to you
so we've made incredible strides and if
you took space away from our everyday
lives today it would not look anything
like it does now we are so reliant on
Space right now certain technologies
that people are investing tremendous
amounts into like blockchain 5G Internet
of Things cloud computing these in many
cases are relying upon satellite-based
systems but where do we go from there
well certainly space tourism has become
one of these more emerging Industries
but think about infrastructure it's
extremely expensive to send things into
outer space to the extent that we can
have a wide network of stations whether
they're permanent colonies on the moon
and Mars which are already projects that
are being developed today to building
out your larger space stations where you
can have governments and agencies and
militaries and companies come to do
research and to actually build things in
outer space Manufacturing in outer space
can become potentially a very large
industry in the future because when you
don't have to deal with gravity pulling
things down you can build very large
structures so robotics
um you know uh different types of things
that we will be needing to use in order
to build out this infrastructure are
other areas that could be incredibly
important 3D printing if you're able to
actually develop the tools that you need
in outer space as opposed to having to
send up these items every time you want
to use them all these can be
revolutionary game changers and also
don't sleep on what militaries are doing
around the world China wants to build a
permanent lunar research base by 2028 in
a potential permanent military base by
2030 and doing some of this in
conjunction with Russia it's not just
the US that has aspirations for space
this is truly something that countries
around the globe want to have a large
presence and Military
surveillance security are all things
that need to be considered and things
that are being worked on today
absolutely a lot to pay attention to
Andrew Shannon co-founder and CEO of
pure procure am thank you so much for
joining us on this historic day and Tim
we're going to say bye to you down in
Van Horn Texas for us thank you both for
being with us today
up next we'll keep the Space theme going
with David Rubinstein but we'll also
talk about his interview with the head
of JP Morgan's wealth management arm
which is sending a warning to retail
investors we'll be back in two minutes
you're streaming quick take stop
our generation's biggest problem climate
change is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions scrams or industry
buildings electricity all of those
things everything you need to know about
our changing environment the politics of
global warming we can and we will deal
with climate change in the fight against
climate change when we're green has you
covered
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
billionaire Jeff Bezos and three others
are resting comfortably as you can see
back on Earth after blue Origins first
flight to space with passengers aboard
and it went off without a hitch as we've
been following all morning the capsule
reached an altitude of more than 62
miles before descending it's a milestone
in the company's effort to make space
tourism viable with me now to discuss
the future of space travel as a business
and so much more as David Rubinstein
co-founder of the Carlyle Group and host
of Bloomberg wealth with David
Rubenstein David thank you so much for
being with me on this historic day so
you have interviewed Jeff Bezos before
about his passion for space he's had it
since he was young how significant is
this day for him
well to him this is one of the most
significant things he's doing with his
life uh he built a great company he's
the richest man in the world and he
would say I'm he's happy with that but
he thinks that when history is recorded
what he will have done in space will be
more significant and he regards it as a
much more serious accomplishment uh of
what he's done with his life so far but
but happening here on Earth I mean how
does he how does he push back against
that well he does give away a lot of
money uh he's giving away a lot of money
for homelessness and other kinds of
things and things relating to climate
change but he has so much money more
than 200 billion dollars so he he
doesn't give it all away uh to that kind
of thing but he does do some of the
things in that area but most importantly
he has a vision I remember when I met
with him when he was just starting uh
Amazon and he had a vision of selling
everything over the internet and I
thought it was ridiculous of course
um he now has a vision of space travel
and I didn't think realistically when he
started it he could do it but he's
pulled it off you know never
underestimate Jeff Bezos he's really
incredible what he pulls off do you see
a potential investment opportunities in
space I mean we were just talking to
somebody about this
um what do you see as a future
uh it's a great opportunity I have
invested in that area personally I will
continue to do so because clearly space
travel and things related to it will be
quite important in the future I've
invested in things relating to the next
space station that's going to be built
the International Space Station we have
now ultimately will come down there'll
be a new Space Station built largely for
Americans and I think that's going to be
an opportunity an opportunity to travel
in space is going to be important so I
think it's a good opportunity and
clearly look at SpaceX it's going to be
doing another uh series of things that
are quite extraordinary so you have
SpaceX you have Virgin Galactic and you
have uh blue origin all quite impressive
but there are many other companies
aren't as famous that are out there
going to do quite well and that's where
you're investing right now I am doing
some investing there and I think it's
likely to do quite well and what do you
make of sort of the Space Race that we
are seeing between Jeff Bezos Richard
Branson Elon Musk I I wonder what's your
take on that well competition is
generally a good thing and it's no
different than the competition you have
in other areas of of business so we have
competition virtually every area of
business this gets a lot more attention
because it's so unique and so different
and we remember the space travel of the
1960s and 70s and how that was so
historic and while we haven't had that
recently now people are getting to
relive that and many people didn't live
through that you're too young to have
lived through that but people didn't
know that people that didn't live
through that are now getting the chance
to live again and see the excitement of
space so what we saw today was Jeff
Bezos going up and you could argue
risking his life and risking his
brother's life because you go 62 miles
up in space you know something good has
to happen to make sure you come down
successfully but it worked out and so I
think his family was nervous about it
but it worked out so it's safe to say
you're looking forward to the next
opportunity well I'm looking for the
investment opportunities I'm not sure
that I am probably a good candidate to
go up in space but somebody older than
me went up today and so maybe I'll do it
myself who knows I know Wally Funk was
very excited about that um David you
know we also wanted to talk to you about
a number of other things you have a new
interview out today and you know we're
talking to you today a day after we saw
a pretty historic not historic but a
pretty record Market sell-off I wanted
to get your take on that first where are
we at in the economic recovery whenever
you have a weekend and you get some bad
news the first day things that happened
Monday is there's a sell-off so we had
some bad news people got nervous about
the Delta variant but the truth is the
Market's a comeback and regained about
half the losses from yesterday today and
I suspect the markets are still in
pretty good shape and will be as long as
interest rates stay low now people are
worried about the Delta variant they
should be but generally I think country
is coming back and the economy is coming
back so well there might be a blip or
two occasionally in in moving back into
a full kind of a work environment I
think generally we're heading in that
direction so I'm not that worried about
the Delta variant relatively speaking
and I do think the economy and the
markets are going to come back and did
your guest Mary Callahan erdo she's from
JP Morgan what did she think about where
we're at right now with the market
because yesterday I mean it spooked a
lot of people's stocks are rebounding
today but I wonder what she said when
you spoke with her well Mary is the head
of asset management and uh private net
worth private wealth management for uh
JP Morgan and that's a gigantic area
she's managing about three trillion
dollars and in recent years as more and
more people get wealthy they want people
to help manage their money and so on the
show we're talking about what people
should do if they don't have their own
family office but they want to give
money to somebody to manage for them and
that's what she really does she manages
money for a lot of very wealthy people
and us do other organizations but theirs
is about the biggest in the world and I
wanted to play a little bit of sound
from your interview with her and talk to
you out of it so let's listen to a few
minutes
if you look over the past year I mean
many people have had average balanced
portfolios up 30 percent and then of
course that's what they become
accustomed to and they want to hear from
someone that's going to say I can get
you another 30 percent
but if something sounds too good to be
true that's probably another rule you
should maybe add to the to the rule if
it's too good to be true High likelihood
that it is
so um I I'm not sure if you heard that
David but of course you did the
interview she's talking a little bit
about where to invest diversifying your
portfolio what else did she have to say
for new investors for retail investors
who are still you know new to this game
right now well I think there are three
different things we talked about
together and I guess three rules that I
would give to people about managing
their wealth which I think she agrees
with and she said as well number one uh
make sure you have experts who know what
they're doing manage your money don't
try to be an expert yourself when you're
really not to diversify don't put all
your eggs in one basket and three don't
lose what you have a lot of times people
think they're Geniuses and they made
money in area a and they're going to
make money in investing and that rarely
happens there are very few people who
are geniuses in investing as well as
other things and so her point is make
certain you know what you're doing have
good people diversify and don't try to
make fortunes on one or two Investments
remember if you make six or seven or
eight percent a year compounded over
four or five five six years that's a
fair amount of money so just make
certain you don't lose what you have and
that's one of her main messages and
she's speaking specifically to people
who are new in in the industry correct
yes a lot of times people make a lot of
money in one area and all of a sudden
they're worth a lot of money what do
they do with it well they might turn it
over to their cousin to manage or the
cousin may not be an expert or they
might turn it over to a child to manage
a child might not be an expert her point
is make sure you have people know what
they're doing and she's one of the
biggest in the world in doing this
managing money for wealthy people lots
of people do it and Mary Erdos has done
it as well as anybody she oversees the
the entire JPMorgan private net worth uh
investment arm and in addition to what
you spoke to her about she talked to you
about how new Bankers uh need 72 hours a
week of of training when they're
starting off I think that was really
interesting because we're speaking at a
time where a lot of Bankers are leaving
the industry because of burnout I mean
what do you think about what it is that
she said well I don't think you can do
anything great 40 hours a week in other
words you can work 40 hours a week but
if you're really going to master a
subject it takes more time than that and
if you're not prepared to do that you
can do something else but if you want to
be at the top of the profession which is
very competitive like private and wealth
management it's going to get put in the
hours and and it takes a while uh nobody
ever won a Nobel Prize 40 hours a week
if you're really going to be great and
really make a real difference in the
world it puts in more hours and 40 hours
now some people may not want to do that
they have family reasons other personal
reasons not to not to do that that's
okay but if you really want to be a
superstar in one area like private net
worth management you really have to uh I
think put in the hours and that's what
she was saying so it's a little bit
specific to exactly what it is that
she's doing you have to learn what
you're doing you just can't say to
somebody comes in I'll manage your money
for you and not know what you're doing
you have to make certain you know what
they want you have to know what the
available options are and you have to
make certain that they have a realistic
expectation of what you can do for them
and we're hearing some other Banks
though are offering things like pelotons
or other gifts to get Bankers to to
stick around young Bankers to stick
around so you know people taking
different approaches
well in the end I think peloton's why
they might be very nice will not
probably get people to do some things
that they probably otherwise wouldn't do
on the whole and generally if you're
going to be really good in the private
wealth management business it just takes
time and energy and you really want to
have be trained by people that know what
they're doing and and so some places
like JPMorgan can really train you very
well
well David we really appreciate you
coming on and talking to us about this
upcoming interview that you are having
that's going to be airing actually soon
uh David rubensen thank you so much for
your time and there's a promo right
there you can watch JP Morgan's Mary
Callahan Erdos share her wealth
management tactics on Bloomberg wealth
with David roomside tonight at 9 00 PM
Eastern all right we'll be right back
this is quick take stock
foreign
World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions transport industry
buildings electricity all of those
things everything you need to know about
our changing environment the politics of
global warming we can and we will deal
with climate change in the fight against
climate change when we're green as you
covered
thanks
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
right now because while equities have
bounced back today the Bitcoin sell-off
is continuing down right now hanging
around that crucial 30 000 level just
shy about 29 000 handle and that's a
level a lot of Bitcoin Watchers are
talking about Jen it's hard to believe a
Bitcoin has hit this record almost 65
000 mid-april and here we are today I
know and really we've been talking about
the fact that that thirty thousand
dollar mark is really where people are
going to be paying attention to our
colleague John authors is saying that
the sell-off in Bitcoin is stunningly
similar to the last Bitcoin crash he
makes the argument that history is
repeating itself which you know this is
something we look at in financial
markets history always repeats itself
and now the question here though is just
how far it'll drop because the last time
it was a brand new kind of exciting
asset class people were diving in and
the people pulled out for that same
reason the question now is is this a
kind of post-pandemic return to normal
Vibe or what are we talking about here
right and what about these other
cryptocurrencies that we're seeing uh
kritty yeah yeah well I mean hey look
ethereum whatever that Dogecoin oh there
you go sorry we have a weird ticker my
bad uh so ethereum is really going to be
the one that people are watching right
now Jen because this is the one that has
a lot of different kind of blockchain
Technologies on it your nfts are of
course using ethereum so that's the one
a lot of people are watching right now
but when Bitcoin starts to slide it
takes everything down with it that's
pretty clear today yeah and we're seeing
a lot of that over the past few days
pretty uh that'll do it for quick take
stock today thanks so much for your time
we'll be back here tomorrow Tim will be
back here tomorrow I'm Jennifer
zabasacha in New York
[Music]
thank you
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions transport industry
buildings electricity all of those
things everything you need to know about
our changing environment the politics of
global warming we can and we will deal
with climate change in the fight against
climate change when we're green as you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
used to think that the brain controlled
all our movement so when you had a
spinal cord injury if you lost that
communication between the brain and the
spinal cord it's really nothing you can
do unless you regenerate that connection
it turns out the spinal cord has much
more of the sophisticated role than we
thought before
we can stimulate the neural networks in
the spinal cord we can help the spinal
cord relearn how to do things I was able
to do before injury
I was supposed to be an individual that
was going to live and die from this
chair coming with the epidural
stimulator it's so close to the point of
just move this leg
your growing the ability to recovery
I really think like that it's going to
give me the availability to get out of
this chair
[Music]
growing up we started out with go-karts
and then we got into bicycles and
everything my Grandpa took me to my
first Supercross race
seen that and instilled me with this
want that that's what I wanted to do my
career was at the point where I was
amateur Pro there's a couple races and
then I had my Pro points where then I
could race the stuff that you see on TV
I went out and I was testing a new
motorcycle that I just got
and it was a like a hundred foot jump
right off the face of that jump I
remember the motor just locked up
it had me pinned and then it just
can just tumble tumble tumbling
some people came up to me like you know
you okay and I'm like no I don't think
so can you get up I was like no
you're paralyzed from the waist down
your complete injury you can't feel
anything you're not going to regain any
Mobility any function from here on out
you're gonna have to have daily care
more than likely if you're gonna live
from a wheelchair and just that was a
lot to swallow
basically how I took it was that from
that point on my life was starting to
end
versus it continuing to be an adventure
that was how it felt to me
[Music]
when I got that prognosis the first
thing I went to was looking at centers
that offered rehab and locomotor
training and which were the top ones
that was where I kind of heard through
the grapevine that they had a guy in
Louisville that was going through the
procedure for the epidural stimulator
and they were seeing some very
interesting things happen
we were doing a series of experiments we
implanted an individual with the
epidural stimulator it was laying down
and he on his own tried to move
voluntarily he tried to move his toes
and he wiggled his toe I said
holy
sh we did not anticipate that we tested
it the stimulator off and they cannot
move when you turn the stimulator on
they're able to
this dude's gotta got a switch that just
makes it normal that's how it was making
me perceive it our whole theory about
how the motor system works was
challenged
[Music]
so the traditional way of thinking about
a spinal cord injury is that the brain
is the primary controller of movement
and function but it turns out the spinal
circuitry is as smart as the brain it
can learn it can remember it can forget
and it can make decisions
how we actually walk is this circuitry
already has in it the ability to
generate patterns to walk
as devastating as a spinal cord injury
is that circuitry still has the ability
to do that but it loses what we would
call state of excitability
so the epidural stimulator is an
off-the-shelf pain stimulator that's
used in people for pain it has a lead
that's placed in the lower spinal cord
and it generates an electric field so
the stimulator actually helps those
neurons that are still viable that are
still alive to be able to function like
they did before
it's five days a week
two sessions a day I started with a toe
and then it started with the ankle and
then it started with a leg
12 sessions in I got my first Holt of
Independence and standing it's gotten to
the point now where it just happens
naturally I just Lean Forward on my
Walker and think that I want to stand
and I stand in my legs they hold me
when you immediately turn it on you
don't really notice but once you get a
couple volts up it's like you feel the
body charged and ready when you're
trying you feel that go through your
head from your brain down your spine to
that leg
[Music]
give them some body weight support keep
them balanced and then people move their
legs in a walking like pattern that
sends the right information about
walking back to the spinal cord which
it's expecting and because the spinal
cord's smart and it can learn it starts
re-learning how to walk again with that
information and the person thinking
about walking and over time in some
people they are able to step
independently and in two people walk
completely independently from physical
assistance but just use a walker or
canes to walk over ground
the biggest thing is filling it because
after injury you feel nothing and when
you execute those movements you feel
them it's gonna be a really quick move
shift and unload there you go I exploded
a vertebrae what is known before all
this is there's no way no how that I'd
ever be able to take a step again but
that's wrong
The Next Step really needs to be to
design one that is very specific for
this use
so the device that we envision is akin
to a smartphone it can be voice
activated it says Okay I want to stand
now so you have your stand program I
want to walk now you have your walk
program it has closed loop feedback the
blood pressure is monitored do all of
this as autonomously as possible
[Music]
this is not a cure there's not going to
be a silver bullet for this there's not
anywhere I think in the near Horizon
where we're going to completely
regenerate this spinal cord after an
injury but if we can make an incremental
change in function it improves their
participation in life
one of the things that hits you when
you're in the hospital am I ever going
to get married you might have kids and
at this point I'm married
an epidural stimulator program gave me
the ability to stand at my wedding
as soon as she started walking down the
aisle the emotion just hit me like I'm
not I don't really cry but man I was
bawling
[Music]
even getting to dance with my mom I mean
that was
that was so awesome
and I feel so close to the kids thing
like I know it's I know it's coming
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions scrams or industry
buildings electricity all of those
things everything you need to know about
our changing environment the politics of
global warming we can and we will deal
with climate change in the fight against
climate change when we're green as you
covered
[Music]
defects in retinal genes cause a
devastating form of childhood blindness
gene therapy is really I think at the
Forefront of treating retinal
degenerations
there are now over 20 clinical trials
addressing various diseases in ways that
we didn't really think possible before
come on having to make a decision on his
behalf has been a real struggle this
treatment could change our lives this
could stop a truly terrible disease
as we tackle the problem of childhood
blindness this is going to be a real
breakthrough in our ability to change
the course of the disease in a way we
never thought possible
[Music]
Maverick is my firstborn child he has
been the most amazing child to raise
from the day that he was born I didn't
have a lot of experience with babies
before I had him but I just noticed that
he had a Blank Stare checked his
tracking vision and it was non-existent
we went through all the genetic testing
and it came back positive for Libra's
congenital amaurosis with a specific
genetic marker of rpe 65.
the cones and the rods in the eyes don't
allow for light perception so he is
legally blind with specifically low
light blindness
he also doesn't have peripheral vision
or Vision below his waist it's almost
tunnel vision
[Music]
up here is my home
and these are my pillows this is my high
patch
it has to be the right lighting for him
to see once the sun goes down his world
is very dark
we take him inside turn on all the
lights until it's time for bed
[Music]
Maverick's condition is degenerative
there is no time frame of when the
degeneration will take place
but it is a well-known fact that he will
be completely blind in later years he
took his thoughts quite some time to
subside into sense of fire and sulfur a
torched landscape
in December of 2017 the FDA approved
gene therapy for Maverick specific
condition and so we went and talked to
Dr Nagel shortly after it was approved
Maverick was six years old when I first
met him and this family for a long time
had struggled with getting a diagnosis
and then we're very excited finally to
hear that there was a treatment
look sterna is a gene replacement
therapy whereby we're delivering a
normal healthy copy of the rp65 gene to
patients who have two defective copies
this medication is a virus which has
essentially been modified so its only
job is to deliver the genetic material
we deliver this virus with a very fine
needle underneath the retina and then we
have a healthy copy of a gene that's
been missing and the cells that normally
make it
unfortunately with this disease the
cells that absorb the light the
photoreceptors are constantly
degenerating and there gets to be a
point where there simply Aren't Enough
cells to function even if we were to
deliver that Gene back
so it makes a lot of sense to treat
earlier pediatric patients young
patients when they have those cells
there and just need the normal copy of
the gene to make the protein and thus
function again so treatment early in
children is really the way to go to
achieve the best results here at
Children's Hospital Los Angeles we've
treated 17 patients so 34 eyes we have
data that the treatment effect is stable
without any loss in function five years
ago there were no treatments for this
disease and for the bulk of retinal
degenerations these patients if they're
lucky got a diagnosis with genetic
testing but beyond that there wasn't
much that we could do aside from get the
most out of the vision that they have
since they have the approval of externa
that's really opened the door to not
just treating this relatively rare
retinal degeneration but essentially any
retinal degeneration
this has been probably the most
difficult decision that I've ever had to
make in my entire life it makes me very
nervous because it is so new if it
doesn't go well it's my fault because I
chose to do this to my child
I honestly feel like I hit the jackpot
when I had Maverick I don't know any
other seven-year-old kid that could
handle everything that he has been
through with such appreciation for life
you know he is willing to do or try
anything
all right here we go
after today our life could potentially
change forever
[Music]
love you
he might go back home and for the first
time have fun with his friends by the
pool as it's getting dark ride his bike
at dusk go trick-or-treating these are
the sort of improvements that really
change a child's life and the motor
confidence that comes with ambulating
and interacting with the environment in
a way that they couldn't before I think
really has lifelong consequences
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
days for the corrected DNA to be
absorbed
so at seven days he could potentially
see again
[Music]
it just comes in very small doses and it
could take up to four months they said
[Music]
Maverick had his two surgeries and we
are home the first day that I really
noticed that something was different was
riding in a car and he said Mom
I'm just looking outside and I'm seeing
what is outside the Windows like I've
never been able to see through the
windows
seems so small but it was really
life-changing for him to be able to look
out of a window ready okay listen to me
one more game of tag Maverick sit ready
one more game one two three four five
[Laughter]
[Music]
in the past seven years we don't even
come in the backyard at night this is
It's a true Miracle you cannot stop me
[Music]
okay I got Maverick
all right Willow come here get him
[Music]
he has a whole new level of Independence
and he is ready to conquer anything that
is given to him
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
foreign hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
at bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions scrams or industry
buildings electricity all of those
things everything you need to know about
our changing environment the politics of
global warming we can and we will deal
with climate change in the fight against
climate change when we're green as you
covered
[Music]
[Music]
everything I do comes from seeing
patients and not having an answer for
how to help them right now all of us are
using mobile technologies and computers
for typing and texting and sending
messages generating language folks with
lockdown syndrome don't have any way to
do that
Gregory had brain damage I don't think
he'll ever be able to do this and Dr
Melanie said it is
foreign
[Music]
building new things has led to some of
Humanity's biggest leaps forward we made
tools Forge New materials and learned to
produce them for millions and then
billions with every new innovation comes
new Industries new economies new
challenges and we're always looking for
what comes next
go for lunch the industrialization of
space I think will be one of the great
economic booms of this century
space offers a whole new environment to
create things things we can't make on
Earth gravity in general is something
that we all just take for granted
because it's just always here it affects
everything what becomes interesting is
what happens when you take that away
private companies are creating new
materials 3D printing tools even living
tissue and developing the technology to
build entire factories in space
if successful for-profit manufacturing
could lead to a new Gold Rush
ing the business of space to its next
giant leap
Ellen mask and Richard Branson and Jeff
Bezos and many other industrialists
they're making big Investments to go up
there but there has to be a why there
has to be a reason to go to space we
want to see a very robust commercial
Marketplace in space but the other thing
that we have to do is we have to prove
we have to prove the industries that
ultimately are going to be able to take
advantage of the microgravity
environment of space in space we're
opening the way to private Enterprise
since the 1980s companies have been
investigating the unique properties of
microgravity yielding major
breakthroughs in the areas of
biomedicine and Advanced Materials
research and now some are looking to
start production Manufacturing in space
has at its core the following idea this
extraordinary environment with a
completely different set of
environmental factors than the earth can
enable you to manufacture things that
you couldn't manufacture on Earth that
have value our economy has historically
been a you know a value-added economy
right we take raw material and we turn
it into steel and we sell that steel for
profit finding new ways of making things
is historically the makings of economic
boom three two one here
in July of 2019 spacex's crs-18 launched
with over a dozen new research projects
including investigations being conducted
by Goodyear and Adidas
both companies hope that studying their
products in microgravity could unlock
new opportunities
also aboard the mission is a biomaterial
3D printer and with it the chance to
print whole human organs
spark BFF on site four
go ahead
so you were working with the DMC to go
ahead and get our Command window open a
little early correct
yes bandwidth is available
okay so I'm just pressing where the
numbers are and um
making sure they're too hard to stop
Christina we should be good to go
hands-free now
copy the thumbs up we do want to start
by opening up the cassette kit
it's just past 3 AM and the team at
techshot is prepping their initial
printing Run for the newly arrived bio
fabrication facility or BFF fueled by
coffee and the type of food you might
expect to find at 3am the team is
working directly with astronauts aboard
the ISS all from the comfort of techshot
headquarters located just outside
Louisville Kentucky now we want to
double check that the smart pumps are in
the up position
we're going to be sliding the cassette
in and we just don't want to bump them
with the cassette I see that looks great
um we are good to go ahead and put the
door back on
we'll be able to do some printing
definitely
from the outside the BFF doesn't look
that much different to traditional 3D
printers but inside these smart pumps
are being loaded with living cells and
for the company all eyes are focused on
the inaugural drop Paving the first
biological brick on the long road to
printing human organs
currently there's over 113 000 people on
the organ donation list and 22 people
are dying every day because there's not
an organ available BFF has that
long-term potential to someday maybe be
able to provide some hope and a cure for
some of those people this is John
Bellinger the CEO of techshot a comp Co
founded over 30 years ago while his
latest project just succeeded in its
initial test prints the BFF has a long
way to go before it's printing anything
as complex as a human liver or heart
techshot is demonstrating the BFF
technology with this current flight and
we anticipate being able to print organs
and structures might be five to ten
years out bio princes have been on Earth
for over a decade and can print things
like ear and nose cartilage that are
living tissue but for complex systems
like organs the difficulty has been
printing the vascular networks within
the tissue itself without vascular
tissue to distribute the needed
nutrients any printed cells would die
off well before they could be used
and techshop believes that gravity is a
big part of the challenge
so let's just say that you want to
create something that has one layer of
cells and then on top of that a
different layer of cells and on top of
that like a third layer of cells so one
way that you could do that would be to
just print one cell in a layer and then
your second layer with another type of
cell and then your third layer with
another type of cell but depending on
those materials over a short period of
time those cells may not stay in those
layers they may settle out and then end
up combining you know you think of you
know printing if you try to print with
water here on Earth you know what would
happen it would just squirt out like out
of a water gun and that is because in a
gravity environment you know everything
wants to just squirt out and wet out and
spread out but in the microgravity
environment you don't have to worry
about any of that so you have a much
wider range of materials that you can
print with to combat the effects of
gravity on Earth researchers have used
scaffolded structures in order to
support the growing cells the problem is
a lot of ways that that is accomplished
isn't necessarily the best for biology
it can limit the types of materials that
you can use and it can also limit the
types of cells that can really thrive in
that environment in microgravity you
wouldn't necessarily have to do that you
could have your different layers or
areas or sections of different types of
cells and put them next to each other
and there are no other forces that are
going to cause them to mix so you have
this opportunity to be able to make
these small regions in three dimensions
in a different type of way and different
type of structure that would be very
difficult to do on the ground
microgravity-enabled bioprinting still
has numerous hurdles to cross before it
can produce a product for sale only now
that the printer is operating aboard the
ISS can researchers begin to understand
the correct materials and process
necessary not only to print organs but
to culture and preserve them long enough
to return back to Earth but all at time
and research is part of techshot's plan
techshots business model is to be a tech
engine we're generating new technologies
then if we feel like that technology has
a potential commercial potential we spin
that off into a different company or to
a different group they liken their
business to Levi Strauss in the 1800s
during the Gold Rush Levi Strauss
started out by providing canvas material
for tents and wagons and when those
miners needed a more durable fabric the
now iconic blue jeans were born the
business model of selling pickaxes as
opposed to going out and panning for
gold really certainly applies to space
and there are many companies at the
component level that are providing
products and services to launch
companies to satellite operators to NASA
one of the challenges in that business
model is you need a gold rush
it's not clear that 3D printed organs
could set off any kind of a gold rush to
space so in order to stay in business
techshot needs to have other projects
making sure it doesn't keep all of its
eggs in one satellite
this is my science fair project that I
started in eighth grade the whole
experiment was to see how the chicken
embryo develop in space without the
presence of gravity
this science project evolved into the
space shuttle project
imagine this chicken egg in the back of
the barnyard
gravity is causing yolk to fall to the
bottom of the egg now the hen has a
natural instinct of turning that egg
around therefore the Yoke will fall go
back up to the top and gravity pulls it
back down to the bottom again now what
would happen to that egg up in space
the project was sponsored by Kentucky
Fried Chicken in which their worldwide
headquarters is located in Louisville
and so the the engineer that I worked
with Mark duser he and I are the ones
that decided to start techshot and start
it right here in Louisville Kentucky we
started in a motel it was just two two
rooms and eventually you went into four
rooms of the motel and then as as Tech
shot matured and developed and gained
more projects and more opportunities
then we decided you know we're in this
for the Long Haul and so we built a
world-class research facility here that
we're sitting in today
and here just across the street from
that first motel room techshot is
currently working on 15 active projects
creating technology for NASA the
military and major pharmaceutical
companies all with the goal to support
researchers in microgravity last year
was techshot's best year in its history
I think that's reflective of the
excitement of the new opportunities that
are out there for space and if they're
lucky one of these projects could yield
that Catalyst of a space Gold Rush
but they aren't alone in this race
another company located in Silicon
Valley views making things in space as
core to their mission even down to their
name
this is fiber optic cable it works
because the fiber reflects light over
and over inside the structure and even
if you bend it the light still comes
through the other end but in this
application it's nothing more than a
modern looking lava lamp the best fiber
optic cable is being used to transmit
data all over the world in fact undersea
cables carry 99 of all the data that
crosses oceans optical fiber usually
made from silica is important because it
can transmit data incredibly quickly
over a long distance before needing to
have its signal Amplified but research
done by the US Air Force in the 1990s
proved that it would be possible to
produce a fiber known as z-blan that
could far exceed traditional silica
fiber the only catch it needs to be made
in microgravity Z blend is an optical
glass that has a transmission window
that's about five times wider than
traditional silica glass and it has a it
has a signal loss that's 10 to 100 times
better than traditional silica glass
this is a is a rush the
knee with a mission to create a new
industrial foothold in space and its CC
Bland as potentially the first material
that can be made in space and sold on
Earth so this is a preform of Z blend it
starts out as this nice dog bone
cylinder and then it gets inserted into
a furnace this gets thinner and thinner
and thinner than the width of your own
hair and then you start pulling that so
if everything works out you get a spool
like this from our earlier test runs
basically looks like fishing line
while it is possible to produce sea
Bland on Earth it's nowhere near the
potential of what you can produce in
microgravity Earth manufacture zebling
suffers from tunic crystals in the in
the material and basically what happens
is when light or power goes through
these don't Crystal domains they reduce
each time creating a power loss
throughout the the length of fiber
you're going through microgravity
suppresses these formations and doing so
creates more of a mono crystalline
structure so you don't have all these
domain uh drops and you have less of a
power drop over that length of fiber
you know you can go
transatlantic and trans-pacific without
having repeaters in the lines like
traditional fiber lines do today
you can imagine providing 5 10 50 times
more bandwidth down the same line of
fiber by by using Z Bland instead of
silica that you begin to you begin to
scratch the surface of the of the
economic potential of z-plant they
estimate that a kilogram of z-blan could
sell for tens if not hundreds of
thousands of dollars and that high price
per kilogram is important when it comes
to space Manufacturing
historically a barrier to doing a lot of
commercial activity in space has been
that it costs so much money to get to
space do things and then come back
you know it can literally cost like tens
of thousands of dollars a kilogram to
launch operate and return and that's why
things like z-blan are so attractive
because we can sustainably sell them for
tens of thousands of dollars a kilogram
meaning at some point whole factories
could be created in space
receiving raw material from the ground
and shipping microgravity enabled c-blan
back to Earth
but the problem is it's all still
theoretical made in space has been
working on z-blan for over four years
and has flown four missions to test
their manufacturing techniques with more
planned in the future but they still
expect to be a few years away from
producing a product that could be sold
on Earth let alone scaling that to
larger Industries it's very interesting
and a little counter-intuitive
the most successful companies in space
are the companies that consistently say
how can I do this on Earth
there have been many products that
started with the vision of actually
Manufacturing in space and ended up with
a discovery phase in space and
Manufacturing on Earth and that's good
news for consumers that's good news for
the end users of those products because
that reduces costs you don't build your
manufacturing plant on the most
expensive real estate you can possibly
get a hold of you build your
manufacturing plant where you can
manufacture economically for made in
space though discovering the first
product that can truly be made in space
is more than just profit and loss
the establishment of space manufacturers
zeblan as a product line
is is core to our vision right that's
that's the industrialization of space
right there that's the Netscape moment
of low earth orbit commercialization if
in our research and development for
zebly and say we found ways of improving
z-blan that we could actually apply to
rust really like apply in a gravity
field we would be excited about that you
know for us we'd take the profits from
that and plow that back into doing more
cool space stuff and while a company is
also investigating other materials like
sea Bland that can be produced in space
they've already laid the groundwork for
a whole new way of thinking about
in-space Manufacturing
and they call it arcanote
so arcanon is is one of many steps
toward those broader Visions arcanada is
a more of a capability than a thing the
capability can enable virtually
anything you can think of in terms of
structures and space you can build large
things small things that are optimized
it doesn't really matter arcano Blends
robotic manufacturing with 3D printing
allowing it to create and assemble
products in space meaning instead of
flying something like say a satellite to
space you could create them there but
before made in space can use arcanort as
an in-space Factory it needs to turn its
Vision into a sustainable business
there is no shortage in space of
Visionaries what I really want to try to
achieve here is to make Mars The
Impossible The Visionaries that we are
seeing succeed are the The Visionaries
that that attach their Vision to an
incremental pathway
[Music]
I've been very fortunate to work closely
with NASA for a number of years in
developing gravity independent
Manufacturing Technologies and the first
one of those technologies that we really
tackled was 3D printing International
Space Station has its own 3D printer and
look at this astronauts created the
first object to be made with it it's a
white printer part the first print that
we did was a little a plate for the
printer and it's a NASA and it said
Maiden space on it is it fair to say
like the person you made in spaces in
marketing I mean
the first we actually kind of joked that
the first thing we did was demonstrate
that you could make like self-repairing
robots in space to date made in space
has created over 200 objects aboard the
ISS and with its second printer named
the additive manufacturing facility they
were able to not only prove their
technology but turn it into a business
we struck kind of an interesting deal
with them where we actually retained
ownership of the device and and actually
operated as a service and you know
printed parts for NASA for other
individuals for companies for schools so
really starting to build almost this
machine shop in space kind of business
model the approach that we've taken at
made in space has been to have these
really great this really inspiring big
Vision we take those big that big vision
and we decompose that into digestible
chunks like steps like along that path
toward these fantastic Futures and that
first incremental step for alt is to
Stitch lights
Argonaut 1 Project is a free-flying
satellite which will manufacture 10
meter booms and those 10 meter booms
will have solar arrays on them which
allow a small sat to manufacture on the
order of about a kilowatt of power
the Arcana 1 Mission will launch in 2022
it's part of a public-private
partnership with NASA and the project
aims to reduce the cost of putting
satellites into orbit while satellites
have been getting smaller if you need a
satellite that'll require lots of power
you'll most likely need a massive solar
array but large arrays are difficult to
fit into rocket payloads the so-called
tyranny of the Fairing and it gets
expensive one way around this problem
was to spend heavily on Engineers to
devise solutions for folding arrays into
compact configurations
then deploy at their full size once in
space but all at work and extra weight
on a rocket can add tens if not hundreds
of millions of dollars to a launch cost
archonaut gives satellite makers a new
Option include a 3D printer and robotic
arm onto their existing satellites and
the arcanort build their very large
solar arrays in space this could reduce
the cost of getting power hungry
satellites into orbit and potentially
open up whole new Industries to space
probably the most significant factor for
the financial success of a space-based
or space related business is economies
of scale the more activity there is the
more feasible it is
both made in space and NASA hopes that
arcanor will help reduce the cost of
doing business in space but it's still
unclear whether larger and cheaper solar
arrays is the answer to finding scale in
production a successful strategy for
manufacturing in space is to demonstrate
capabilities and to have adaptable
capabilities that can serve different
customers when you combine that robotica
assembly and additive manufacturing it
really opens the door for customization
for clients you know folks may say hey I
actually don't need that much power
because of my mission I need but I need
a big antenna or I need a large radiator
Argonaut
because it's general means that I can
provide those Services
quickly and at low cost so we hope that
folks see what we're doing and are
inspired by it and say hey this is what
I need so yeah it'd be great if somebody
came to us and said
I want to make if we're like oh my gosh
that's that's the killer app
the hope for arkanot just like with
z-blan and organ printing is that one of
these businesses can be that spark for
space industrialization
I think once people see the potential of
microgravity I think a lot more people a
lot more commercial entities will get
involved in space research because I
think it is such a unique environment
that that different way of thinking
leads to Innovation and so I think you
see so much excitement so much interest
because the potential to come up with
new products new Innovations is real
the ability to manufacture in space
means that we kind of break the tyranny
of the of the launch variant right and
we can now make structures that are
really enormous like big structures that
are on the size and scale of things that
we're we're comfortable with and we
interact with on Earth you know on a you
know a consistent basis you know like
larger buildings multi-story buildings
nothing like that exists in space but we
need to be able to make structures and
spacecraft and habitats that are that
size if we are really to to you know
sustain sustainably move into space move
into low earth orbit and Beyond
and this industry enters low earth orbit
we'll begin to explore the next
financial future the Moon Mars even
asteroids contain potentially invaluable
resources on the next giant leap we'll
explore the private companies developing
the technology needed for off-world
mining but in order for it to become a
business it'll take another giant leap
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the space race isn't just Global
superpowers duking it out for bragging
rights and technological Supremacy
anymore
private companies lots of them are
rushing to commercialize not just a
final frontier but the act of getting
there
I'm a sports Guy this is like March
Madness it's one and done I got one shot
to get to the end or else I'm either
going to fail run out of money or be be
gobbled up by someone else and whoever
figures out how to make launch safe
affordable and convenient is going to
take the next giant leap
foreign
in this decade and do the other things
not because they are easy but because
they are hard
60 years into the Space Race the way we
leave Earth has changed remarkably zero
all engine running liftoff
we have a liftoff 32 minutes past the
hour
space seemed like a vast Black Desert
but now we're ready to make the Desert
Bloom
I'm talking about Opening space up to
business to private Enterprise opening
space up to Commerce and experimentation
and development why to improve the
quality of life on Earth
25 years after Ronald Reagan signed the
commercial space launch act the desert
has begun blooming I think if you're a
young person in 1969 you saw people
walking on the moon and 50 years later
we still haven't gone back I think
that's a little disappointing I think
they took that their hopes and dreams of
their youth and are applying in today's
Marketplace and I think they're having a
fantastic success in the world of rocket
launch there are two very distinct races
going on
the first are the large rocket companies
like SpaceX Virgin Galactic and blue
origin Jeff Bezos has reportedly invest
in billions already in blue origin and
will invest billions more
SpaceX has also raised billions of
dollars and acquired very large
contracts from NASA as well in order to
fund both development and operations of
its vehicles
of the SpaceX Falcon 9 Rockets but they
aren't the only players in the game
there's a heated race picking up between
small and medium launch companies
there's a subset of the community not
named SpaceX not named Blue origin
trying to figure out okay how can we get
there fast companies like rocket lab
relativity Firefly and virgin orbit
right now there are more than 100 small
launch companies competing not just to
get to space but to see who can get
there most reliably
cheapest and then repeat it over and
over and over again
ideally end up with their business in
the black
because entire new Industries rely on
these launch companies getting payloads
into orbit
any missteps can spell disaster not just
for a rocket but an entire company
there is a 200 plus billion dollar
commercial space industry right now
today there are a couple of huge markets
that have been very profitable the most
profitable is a satellite industry in
2018 the global space economy was
estimated to be around 360 billion
dollars
277 billion of that is a satellite
industry which has actually grown over a
hundred billion dollars over the past
decade and for those satellites to get
to space they need to be launched on a
rocket Global launches in 2018 increased
by 46 over the number of launches a
decade ago in many respects it's never
been easier to put a satellite into
space in terms of the cost and the
availability of rockets to ride into
orbit and a new era of smaller cheaper
satellite technology is creating this
boom
once a year out in a desert of northern
Utah the small satellite or small Sac
conference comes to Logan it has all the
trademark features of an industry trade
show bright lanyards tons of Swag but
the deals happening here are carving out
what the future of the space economy
will look like I've been coming to this
conference for 20 years and seen it Grow
from 300 people to over 3 000. so it is
exciting to see that transition as we
move into the next phase traditional
satellites are often powerful behemoths
size of school buses costing hundreds of
millions if not billions of dollars to
build today the proliferation of small
SATs cubesats even Nano SATs can cost as
little as ten thousand dollars and can
be built with similar Hardware that goes
into your cell phone they range from the
size of a Rubik's Cube up to about the
size of a dorm room refrigerator and so
that's a big difference and so some of
these launch Ventures want to launch a
few dorm size refrigerators and others
want to launch dozens of cubesats and so
they're trying to divide the market that
way those satellites are providing
Imaging of the earth they're potentially
providing telecommunications services
and they're attracting quite a lot of
investment tens hundreds of millions of
dollars even billions of dollars the
Earth's insatiable need for
communications and internet is really
what's driving this huge number of
satellites that are going into orbit in
the next five to seven years there's
going to be thousands if not tens of
thousands of new satellites in orbit in
in the next five to seven years the
question is are they able to actually
provide business services that will be
successful the idea is that entirely new
business models as well as revenue
streams will be propped up by the data
these small SATs collect the Imaging and
data collected from these small SATs
will be used by everyone from hedge
funds to Telecom Giants to the US
government just think of how much of
photos you can get with your Android or
iPhone have improved from the first
generation to the current generation
similar things happening in small sets
market research says small sat
manufacturing will nearly double by 2020
with nearly 8 000 new small SATs in
Space by 2026. the issue was always
small satellites have a lot of
capability but there's not a good
affordable way to get them into orbit
and that's where the small launch
companies see a promising business
fact that a small launch vehicle is much
cheaper in Toto than a large launch
vehicle on the order of 5 or 10 million
dollars as opposed to
50 to 100 million dollars and there are
more customers say you have a small sap
that you want to launch into orbit think
of the big companies like SpaceX as a
bus and the small and medium launch
companies like rocket lab as a taxi with
large launchers you're at the back of
the bus after the needs of What's called
the primary which is the main payload on
the rocket like a big government
satellite your small sat is just
piggybacking off that primary since they
bought the majority of the rocket with
small launches like rocket lab you and
your small sat can dictate more of your
terms on when and how you'll fly and
you'll pay for the whole ride so booking
a taxi for a small sat gives you more
flexibility about when and exactly where
you want to go into orbit but it's more
expensive sometimes a Rideshare on a big
rocket and the chance to save on your
launch expense is more suitable
depending on the satellite its Mission
and the budget far more important is
that orbital inclination or the angle of
the satellite's orbit relative to the
equator it's much easier to move a
satellite into a higher or lower orbit
than to change its inclination and
that's why all launch customers have to
decide how their mission priorities and
budgets can align when choosing how to
get to space it's getting to the point
that hitching a ride on the really big
Rockets it works for some people it
doesn't work for all business cases and
so you've got small set Ventures that
say we want our own rides those
customers will determine which of these
small rocket companies succeeds and
which of the companies will fail this is
not the internet where you build up a
huge user base and then you figure out
how to monetize them later launch
doesn't work that way you've got to
build up a backlog of customers out of
the more than 120 small and medium-sized
launch companies out there just one is
successfully launching rockets for
customers right now and that is rocket
lab people can actually rock on up to us
and we'll fly them that's a great
competitive advantage to have over you
know folks that are still developing a
vehicle
The Backs rocket lab has raised over 280
million dollars from outside investors
with a valuation of more than one
billion dollars and is currently flying
a rocket every 30 days it looked like it
was the hardest thing to do was to go
from zero to first successful orbital
flight but really going from first
successful orbital flight through to
producing one every month has been equal
amount of of stress and energy and
complexity and toughness
and obviously we completed our test
flights and moved into full commercial
operations with the first flight of its
business time and then and then straight
on the heels of that we flew our NASA
Mission and now uh we're you know we're
building and launching one vehicle every
every sort of 30 days every month and
while other rocket companies are looking
to build their customer base rocket lab
can't meet the rising demand for
launches our biggest issue is is we
can't build enough Rockets um that is
that is our challenge we've built four
and a half acres of new factories
um and you know we're pushing every in
every direction we can to to build more
capacity we fear that there aren't you
know we are the only dedicated solution
available in the marketplace right now I
don't know in an affordable price so we
see a tremendous amount of of demand so
the demand is there that's not the issue
the issue is figuring out how to provide
reliability scale and Cadence while
keeping prices as low as possible and
each company has its own approach every
company has a unique way way to building
their rocket you know whether they're
using liquid solids fuels or a
combination of the two whether they're
3D printing their stages everyone has
their unique approach to getting to a
rocket however the bottom line is good
business in space is exactly like good
business on earth a focus on customers
incremental successes and a vision
that's supported by a real business
model is what works in space just as it
works on Earth
one of the companies who believes they
have a successful business model is
Firefly a medium-sized launch company
based out of Austin Texas
so I'm going to run through this part of
the procedure okay please set them and
press logic to the next pressure
increment we will go in 10 psi
increments starting from ambient
with a window of one
so in the next six months Firefly is
going to launch this rocket we've been
working on it for for years now and
we're going to have that cathartic
moment where we launch the rocket and
everything's going to go great but the
outlook for Firefly wasn't always so
Rosy this is a very difficult business
there are a lot easier ways to make
money in the world than building a
rocket company and you have a lot of
setbacks you have technical setbacks you
have Financial setbacks but the most
challenging one for me has been the
financial setbacks
Firefly like many other rocket companies
is familiar with financial setbacks
Vector one of the more well-known launch
startups ran into Financial woes in the
summer of 2019 and saw their CEO depart
amid uncertainty about the company's
future back in 2017 Firefly then known
as Firefly Space Systems was saddled
with financial instability and filed for
bankruptcy that's when Silicon Valley
investment fund noosphere ventures
swooped in bought their assets and
rebranded the company to Firefly
Aerospace
I've learned a lot about the types of
investors that you want to have involved
in this that learning has made us I
think very strong to to push through
this time as an investor and as sort of
you know one of the financial sort of
people behind the company I try to
encourage the team to think Beyond
simply building a product by building a
business thank God we went bankrupt
frankly we have a better product now I
have a better partner who lets me do
what I'm good at doing and he funds the
project and I'm not off you know
humping.com guys legs please give me
another hundred thousand dollars
now after two years of r d they're about
to launch their first rocket our plan is
to have five launches next year all five
of them will be from Vandenberg Air
Force Base in California
[Music]
but the next thing is start adding
technology as an established company and
reusability and continuing to drive the
cost down and we want to do things in a
in a different way
companies like Firefly are hard-pressed
to differentiate themselves to stand out
to investors and attract customers
were differentiated by our payload class
even among small launchers we're a big
small launcher so our first rocket Alpha
is capable of carrying a thousand
kilograms whereas our competitors are
more in the 500 kilograms and less area
that bigger payload means they can
service bigger clients such as NASA and
other federal agencies like the U.S Air
Force we are on track to be able to
provide NASA lunar lander capabilities
landing on the moon in the 2021 time
frame and these would typically be
launched in early 2021
Firefly has restructured and rebuilt its
organization from the ground up but the
question remains if they can remain
competitive when it comes to price we
currently have a backlog of about 1.3
billion dollars and a pipeline of over
three and a half billion dollars for our
launch Services alone if we fly
according to our projected flight rates
we expect to be cash flow positive by
the end of 2020.
we're very conscious of cost that's what
one of the fundamental tenets of new
space so Firefly will try to be
competitive with anyone and we take all
competition seriously
that competition comes not only from
other small and medium launch companies
but large ones as well like SpaceX who
announced a small sat solution priced as
low as 1 million dollars for payloads up
to 150 kilograms which equates
approximately fifteen thousand dollars
per kilogram to color something orbit
coincidentally that is exactly the same
as the Firefly unit economics for our
Alpha vehicle Firefly believes they can
deliver something that Elon musk's space
giant cannot unlike SpaceX where those
satellites will be one of many quite
possibly one of 60 our partners will
have the same unit economics but will
have a much more custom
dedicated offering it could be one of
four one of five satellites in our
fairing Rideshare is not the best
opportunity for a lot of small satellite
customers in some ways it's like
hitchhiking you don't get to go exactly
where you want to go and you don't get
to go on your own time schedule and
that's important to a lot of customers
in five years time Firefly plans to not
just be launching a rocket but a family
of rockets we are interested in building
a multi-billion Dollar business and in
order to do that we know that we need to
be cost competitive with whatever the
market throws at us not just simply what
the competition is doing today
and one of those competitors is in Long
Beach California virgin orbit is an
offshoot of Richard Branson's Virgin
Galactic space company and while they're
a medium-sized launch company just like
Firefly and Rocket lab their approach to
getting a rocket into orbit is a bit
different
version orbit is a dedicated small
satellite launch vehicle that is seeking
to revolutionize the small satellite
Market we're utilizing our flying launch
pad it's a Boeing 747 400 aircraft that
we modified and it has an attached
rocket under the left wing of the plane
it's a two-stage rocket liquid oxygen
kerosene rocket that has been flown
before and and has many successes
some of those other successes are by
their sister company Virgin Galactic who
has used this launch pad drop technology
for space tourism instead of small
satellites which they believe is a
Difference Maker in the industry
everything we built around the air
launch system is meant to mitigate
against you know long-term delays for
example an air launch system can fly in
most weather conditions because we're
air launch our Cadence is very quick so
it only takes four to six hours to
really fuel the rocket attach to the
plane and take off on a mission and
having that flexibility having that
quick Cadence turnaround time is
critical to making sure that payloads
can get to orbit when they want to get
there that flexibility is what most
small launch companies hope will set
them apart that responsive rapid launch
to exactly where you want to go that
appeals to government users government
Mission scientific missions government
military missions government intelligent
missions are all exploring the potential
for lower total cost small all launch
vehicles that can do exactly what they
need when they need it
successful full duration test launch
virgin orbit already has a backlog of
customers
of course we see the market expanding
there's a lot of potential out there so
we certainly could see ourselves
providing even more launch support than
between 20 and 24 a year and of course
that is a more mid to long-term goal one
the future for companies like rocket lab
Firefly and virgin orbit looks promising
but what about the hundreds of smaller
launch companies out there well
everybody survive probably not there's
not enough demand for 100 some odd
rockets that are currently in
development we absolutely believe that
the window to invest in launch has
already closed there are some investors
who made some early good plays here that
are going to work out very well but at
this point the the industry is well past
that kind of venture capital investment
stage in our opinion so we see it
shaking out to maybe 10 companies
surviving the launch industry is
unforgiving
um it's not very tolerant of failures on
behalf of iron space I wish to express
my deepest apologies to our customers
for the loss of their payload
and telling them how sorry I am if
you're having a bad a bad run of luck
you don't get a whole lot of patience
out of the market before people start
using other Rockets the technology of
space activities is fascinating the
technological challenges are
extraordinary the competence that it
requires to conduct operations in space
is intimidating
the launch industry has an energized
passionate collection of Engineers
Venture investors and designers
singularly focused on moving private
Enterprise off the planet it's not just
a new industry but a new way of seeing
the world and working above it once you
have that cheap access to space now you
have entirely new business models that
close that didn't before you have an
entirely new use cases for space as an
environment you have an entire ecosystem
of support services that are developing
to support those satellites that are
that are being launched in the next five
to seven years and so that has kind of
unlimited amount of Economic Development
economic growth possibility there you
know I kind of like and where we are
right now to to the very first
beginnings of the internet where we were
just starting to send emails that that's
really where we are in space we're just
starting to send emails and if you if
you think if you go back when you know
you just started sending emails and if I
send to you all of the stuff that was
going to occur because of the internet
you would you wouldn't believe me right
you would think that's just crazy but
that that's where I think where we're at
right now as we've sent our first email
and now space has opened up to
innovators to to really try new things
that's why perfecting a world of launch
is just the beginning Rockets aren't
just providing a platform for space
flight but a platform for Innovation as
we figure out the business of how we get
to space the next problem is where do we
stay on the next episode of giant leap
the International Space Station is
nearing its retirement and NASA wants to
open the door for commercial companies
to develop the technology and the
business to create our next space
habitats
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
gold copper minerals are the lifeblood
of the world's economy from the Arctic
Circle to the Sahara Desert the 1.7
trillion dollar mining industry supplies
raw materials needed for everything from
skyscrapers to smartphones but mining
also comes with an increasingly critical
environmental cost one that may require
us to think about off-planet Solutions
before it's too late booster ignition
asteroids moons and planets and our own
solar system hold an essentially
Unlimited Supply of untapped resources
the first trillionaires
will be those who mine asteroids
resources like gold platinum and rare
earth metals make some of those
asteroids incredibly high priced but the
most valuable elements may be our most
basic one what you want to mine in space
is what you need a lot of and while
humans have been mining for thousands of
years mining in space requires new
Innovative Technologies to realize any
potential business and economic
opportunities
such Technologies might just allow
Humanity to expand operations off Earth
and take that next giant leap
[Music]
these tiny dots represent the millions
of asteroids in our solar system
over the past two decades government and
private aerospace companies have been
investigating their composition location
and even possible payoffs to mine them
this one known as bennu has an estimated
value of 669 million dollars
ryugu 82 billion dollars
better yet an asteroid called Davida
which is valued at more than a hundred
trillion dollars and the reason for
these high price tags they're made up of
valuable metals like platinum gold and
iron we believe that asteroids have
Platinum Group Metals rare earth metals
in high percentages than you might find
on the moon for instance
only once in human history has an
asteroid sample been brought back to
Earth on the Japan Aerospace Exploration
agencies Hayabusa mission in 2010 and
even then the return sample was merely
dust particles and the total cost of
that mission approximately 250 million
dollars
one problem is that compared to the Moon
there's very little gravity so somehow
you have to attach yourself to the
asteroid
whereas on the moon the gravity will
hold your processing equipment in place
so the general answer to the question
can we bring
materials mining space back to Earth the
general answer is no
bringing things from space to Earth only
makes sense if what is retrieved is so
extraordinarily valuable and just not
available on Earth and even returning
the most valuable asteroids could
drastically devalue those materials
take asteroid 16 psyche for instance
NASA is constructing a probe to launch
in 2022 to study the potato-shaped
object which is roughly 95 Metals
nicolian platinum and even gold some
estimates value the asteroid at 700
quintillion dollars
NASA says it may be the inner core of a
developing planet that somehow lost its
outer layers offering incredible insight
into how planets are formed
if someone did manage to bring large
amounts of this asteroid back to Earth
supply of the resources would Skyrocket
meaning we'd have more of the material
than we would have use for causing the
price to crash to almost zero
once we erode the Rarity of a high value
metal or mineral
the value of that terrestrially could
drop significantly experts agree that a
more likely scenario is materials mined
in space will stay in space jump
starting a whole new money-making
industry Any space-faring Nation will
have looked at what's called in-situ
resource utilization which is a very
common space term meaning you use the
resources where you are so taking that
model of
um
if you need it in space mine it in space
what would you be mining mostly you need
fuel
there's something else much more
valuable for use in space that's
abundant on Earth
water not only can water sustain human
and plant life for future manned space
missions
the components of water hydrogen and
oxygen can also be separated and
reassembled to make fuel the zero
emission fuel called hydrogen fuel is
the same used in spacecraft propulsion
and Fuel Cell Vehicles hydrogen fuel
research in this new space race could
also Spur new technologies that can help
fight climate change by speeding the
elimination of fossil fuel use on Earth
and there's already a high demand for it
and an immediate business opportunity
for risk tolerant companies wishing to
make a fortune
in a 2018 paper by industry government
and academic experts they estimated that
for an initial 4 billion dollar
investment in a moon water mining
operation which is about the cost of a
luxury hotel in Las Vegas about 2.4
billion dollars in Revenue could be
generated annually the sort of business
case 101 for mining in space is if
you're going to launch something from
Earth it's going to cost you about
10 or 20 000 dollars per kilo to get it
into space so if you need water for
something
in space and you can produce it for less
than ten thousand dollars a kilo then
do it in space
the United launch Alliance Ula they have
put a price on water in space they have
said we'll give you this amount of money
for the water which means people who are
going out and trying to produce that
water now have a customer
in 2016 the Ula announced its willing to
pay around three thousand dollars per
kilogram for propellant in an orbit less
than two thousand kilometers in altitude
called Low Earth orbit compared with the
estimated price of four thousand dollars
per kilogram to deliver the propellant
from Earth most experts believe the Moon
is a logical starting point for this it
has more gravity than an asteroid making
it easier to land and its poles are
thought to hold vast amounts of water
ice that potential volume of water has
made it the focus of NASA's Artemis
program which aims to land astronauts on
the moon's Southern pole and also make
the space agency a critical first
customer for any water harvested on the
moon Israel
the U.S Europe
everyone is now sort of focusing on the
moon and all of these government
programs are looking to set up shop for
a water mining future
fueling station on the moon could
ultimately make current space Ventures
much cheaper and make future space
missions possible although entirely
theoretical at this point here's how it
could play out water is mined on the
moon and a fueling station is set up
this would provide the first customers
most likely government agencies with
water for human consumption and fuel for
spacecraft water derived fuel could also
be harvested on an asteroid vehicles or
propellant transports then carry the
fuel from the surfaces to a stable
storage point between the Earth and the
Moon
fueling stations can also be set up in
low earth orbit making it accessible to
satellites and other spacecraft as of
now satellites that run out of fuel are
decommissioned extra fuel would allow
them to stay in their orbits increasing
their lifespan
since using a rocket to get fuel out of
Earth's atmosphere is expensive
refueling in low earth orbit can greatly
improve the size type and cost of
missions in Space the commercial launch
industry like SpaceX would also benefit
from these fuel Depots the use of lunar
base propellant and commodities may also
provide a stepping stone for
interplanetary exploration
but while there has been a renewed
interest in the Moon it hasn't been easy
in just 2019 missions to the Moon
Surface by both India and Israel
resulted in landing failures and the
technology to mine and extract these
potential water reserves on the moon and
Beyond is still unproven but some
entrepreneurs are still optimistic
the answer is yes the technology exists
we can put something together we can
send something to the Moon that can mine
water so we we are sort of like a
Trailblazers trying to figure out what's
going on in the moon what's below the
circus meet honeybee robotics they've
designed drills used in NASA's past Mars
missions and have sampling and Mining
systems going on future plan missions to
the Moon Saturn's moon Titan Mars Moon
Phobos and Jupiter's moon Europa we've
been focusing on developing high-end
fully autonomous drilling systems from
literally iPhone size all the way to the
size that cannot fit inside this vacuum
chamber behind me
and that's why NASA has long relied on
their expertise unlike your everyday
drill from the hardware store their
drills overcome the numerous limitations
of space which include extreme
temperatures and low gravity that means
you have to be very very imaginative
very Innovative to solve these problems
you're essentially trying to do what we
do here on Earth but with a fraction of
the power with a fraction of a mass with
a function of the volume and drilling is
unforgiving if you get stuck
if something goes wrong there is no
second chance
the difficulty in drilling would delay
placement of the second probe until the
next day
with their innovative ideas called
planetvac use Compressed Gas to shoot
material into a sample container its
ergonomic design allows it to be inside
the foot of a Lander
and was chosen to go with nasa-funded
payloads to the moon and Mars Moon
Phobos
for Mining and extracting water on the
moon they created the planetary
volatiles extractor or pvex and it not
only drills it mines
it's based off a drill that removes a
cylinder of material called a coring
drill but it's not just any coring drill
it's a it's a system with heaters on the
inside so you drill down the required
depth you heat up the material that's on
the inside of a coring drill and Ice
turns into vapor and vapeg moves up the
coring drill into a cold finger so
you're capturing water vapor like for
example in your freezer when you have
condensation vivex is a mining system it
can actually get into the soil it can
actually extract water it can actually
capture this water in a separate
container we have all the pieces
together and we can go to the moon or
Mars and mine it
when it's tested on the moon which may
happen in the next couple of years pvex
will be the first end-to-end mining
system deployed in space and they have
even more futuristic Ambitions to use
the pvex drill
like this one that not only extracts and
stores water but uses it to propel
itself like a flying kettle
wine or it stands for The World is Not
Enough it's a James Bond stuff it's very
futuristic it's a new concept of space
exploration the main idea is to send
hundreds of low-cost wine spacecrafts
all over the solar system to give a
clear atlas of asteroids that have water
resources
honeybee robotics is one of the many
startups that NASA is depending on to
develop new innovative ideas there is a
strong strong private public partnership
with NASA right now to come up with
lenders but we can send twice a year but
we'll put payloads to them on payloads
like instruments like robbers and also
humans we're doing it it's happening
right now very very exciting times
by giving out multiple contracts NASA
reduces the cost for themselves and the
entire industry we want to have numerous
providers that are competing against
each other on cost and Innovation
driving down the cost and increasing
access to space and industrializing
[Music]
startup transastra with a new infusion
of two million dollars from NASA has
teamed up with other space startups and
educational institutions to prove its
process for harvesting and utilizing
water from asteroids without even
touching them Optical mining is our
patent-pending process for using highly
concentrated sunlight or light from
another source to excavate the surface
without having to use digging tools to
dig into it and this is very important
in space especially for asteroids to
help develop and prove this technology
they've teamed up with the Colorado
School of Mines it's known as the
optical mining test bed first they put
the simulated asteroid in a vacuum
chamber to recreate the conditions of
space
then they use liquid nitrogen to cool a
surface inside the tank called a cryo
trap then they turn on a giant light
bulbs which imitates sunlight that they
then concentrate into a beam resulting
in very high temperatures the beam of
light hits the asteroid Target fractures
a sample and then water and other
materials are released and Frozen onto
the cryo trap the volatile materials
which include water methane carbon
dioxide other valuable materials that
are common and cheap here on the ground
but very valuable in space trapped on
our cryo trap that's pretty nice the
same way that we would trap those
chemicals in space for a real asteroid
mining mission
[Music]
Optical mining bypasses a daunting task
of trying to land on an object with such
low gravity that it could simply break
apart when touched and there's no drill
to potentially get stuck but for this to
work they're targeting smaller asteroids
the size of a beach ball for their Tech
demonstrator model with plans to
accommodate rocks the size of a cubic
tennis court and bigger in future models
we think the right thing to do is to
Rendezvous with the asteroid match
rotation with it
put a thin film bag around it cinch that
bag down and then de-spin the asteroid
and now you have the asteroid in a
container so you can work with it in a
practical way
transastera believes that harvesting
water on asteroids will not only make
space travel more affordable for Private
Industry but it will make NASA's
proposed missions to take astronauts to
the Moon Mars and even asteroids
possible within a budget that the U.S
Congress may be willing to provide
now we can cut out hundreds of billions
of dollars and actually make it possible
for NASA to do all those exciting
missions in a period of just 20 years or
so
um by harnessing the asteroids now
what's really cool about it is that by
using public-private partnership and
working with companies like transastra
the infrastructure for space resource
harvesting and Commercial transport in
space can be developed so by NASA doing
it this way and NASA becoming the first
user of these resources and this
infrastructure for its exploration
missions then that infrastructure is
Left Behind for industry and that can
create massive Industries in space like
it even becomes cost effective to build
a space hotel transastra and partner
momentous will be on a two-year contract
with NASA to build that asteroid Mining
and in-space transportation prototype
called mini B to provide Optical mining
in space
we live in a very exciting time where
we're going to be able to take that to
space and the resources of pace are
literally unlimited and those unlimited
resources are what some universities are
betting on the Colorado School of Mines
where transastera does its Optical
mining research they now offer a
graduate degree in space resources
our space resources program is the first
of its kind in the world
fear is anticipated to be a growing
number of jobs directly in space
resources but the the skills and
practices of space resources can be
applied to lots of other things and a
huge benefit to space mining research is
that a lot of this technology can be
beneficial here on Earth
like their 3D printer that uses
materials on the moon or Mars to make
structures and is modeled after startup
icons 3D printer that is used to make
homes on Earth
their penetrometer is a tool on the end
of a robotic arm that's being developed
to take measurements on the moon but has
app applications for mining companies
and even a Rover in a lunar test bed
that can drill and Prospect for
resources has its benefits there are
places on Earth where mining companies
and Equipment manufacturers are looking
at applying smart robotic systems in
terrestrial lines they could go into
places that are not safe for humans
they could work in much more confined
toxic environments than a person could
and one country is doing just that and
hopes to leverage their expertise in
robotic systems for mining remote
inhospitable locations that are almost
mars-like
recently the administrator of NASA when
the head of the Australian space agency
visited
was saying
that the U.S is looking to Australia to
be doing development in this area of
extracting resources in space one of the
reasons why we in Australia want to get
into this area is because of the
strength of our mining industry the
strength of our mining Automation and
the strength of our mining research we
see it as a way that Australia can
establish a niche space capability
Australia's High wages have caused some
of the largest mining operations in the
world to seek cost savings by using
automation
Rio Tinto the world's second largest
mining company has fitted operations in
Australia with fleets of autonomous
trucks drills and even the first
driverless freight train Network
adapting these Technologies could prove
useful to space programs and the use of
space technology and mines such as
robotics would be useful on Earth the
Australian Center for Space Engineering
research at the University of New South
Wales in Sydney was founded in 2010 and
has 15 PhD current or graduated students
researching space resource Ventures
related to Australia's needs and
expertise
what we are trying to do at the moment
is to reduce the risk perceived by a
large company mining company for
instance
when they approach this type of venture
I think one of the main reasons that
terrestrial mining companies should be
looking at this problem is that they
will benefit their terrestrial
operations by learning some of these
lessons so if they look at the way that
you need to automate on the moon that
will help their terrestrial operation if
you look at the way you would analyze
risk for this type of mine they must
learn new lessons which should hopefully
flow back to their risk analysis for
terrestrial Minds
although mining companies have
terrestrial mining expertise and
monetary advantages only time will tell
who will be the first to provide a
fueling station in space in terms of
making it happen
I actually don't think it'll be a
startup I don't think it'll be a space
agency and I don't think it'll be a
mining company but I think it will be a
big company
probably driven by a high net worth
individual
a company like blue origin SpaceX a
company like that not necessarily then
but something like that proving that
this kind of mining is feasible could
trigger an influx of profit-minded
companies migrating off the Earth just
one industry that would stake a claim on
the vast wealth of space
not only is the universe a place for
exploration for private companies it's a
new resource the key which will unlock
new possibilities in technology
manufacturing living and working both at
home and beyond Earth
and all of this will be the result of
our next giant leap
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
at bloomberg.com webinars
four rooms Earth view
sounds far-fetched at the moment doesn't
it but you know we may be seeing ads
like this in the not too distant future
leading away from Earth has always
captured our imagination as well as
providing the basics for survival these
ideas are a symbol of humankind's unique
creativity and ambition
Advanced base or space station will be
headquarters for the final Ascent of the
moon today the idea of multiple outposts
where we can live and work in space has
never seemed closer
it's about making our lives the best we
can make it it's about as a species
having a path for our future
and the mission to create these habitats
is well underway as private companies
get ready to take that next giant leap
[Music]
the International Space Station it's the
only space habitat we have
one of the first places they take you in
the ISS is the cupola so you can finally
look at the Earth in all its beauty and
it I don't care who you are it's always
stunning it's shocking it's it's amazing
because that's the view you've been
waiting for your entire life
it passes over 90 percent of the world's
population without most of us ever
realizing and at an estimated cost of
150 billion dollars it's the most
expensive object we've ever built you
think about like the Sistine Chapel the
pyramids and the Burj Khalifa or or to
take your pick I mean it far outstrips
those
it's the one and only non-terrestrial
human Outpost we've had a constant human
footprint in orbit for almost 20 years
because of the International Space
Station
the collaboration between 15 countries
started Construction in 1998 and was
pieced together in Space over the course
of a decade
since 2000 it's been a permanently crude
research laboratory a space habitat
that's allowed humankind to live
manufacture and explore beyond Earth
the overarching achievement of the space
station has been education it has
educated us about how to do research
it's educated us about how to live it's
educated us about the harshness of the
environment that it is in and it's about
learning I think
people say what was one of your favorite
Parts about being up there hands down
floating everywhere I went but your
first impressions for ISS certainly is
it's how big it is
the ISS is the size of an American
football field with most of that
footprint taken up by eight solar arrays
these provide enough energy to power 40
homes
station has an American side and a
Russian side as well as contributions
from other nations like Canada Japan and
the European Union
astronauts on board can pass freely
between these sections their living and
working areas are made up of modules
each 4.2 meters in diameter and in total
they have the same volume as the Boeing
747
the three main Labs Destiny Hope in
Columbus are conducting up to 600
ongoing experiments at any one time
and while it's been a collaboration
between governments to build and
maintain the ISS its next chapter will
rely more on private Enterprise today's
a very remarkable day NASA is opening
the International Space Station to
commercial opportunities and marketing
these opportunities as we've never done
before managing and maintaining the ISS
costs 3.4 billion dollars a year that's
over half NASA's space operations budget
aging hardware and space debris will
only add to these costs which is why
NASA is now hoping to pass some
responsibility for the station over to
commercial companies we would like to
see a robust commercial Marketplace in
low earth orbit where space stations
exist outside of NASA the goal being
that NASA could be a customer and we
want to have numerous providers that are
competing against each other on cost and
innovation
with Federal funding proposed to stop in
2025 opening the station to private
Enterprise would free up resources for
the space agency's Ambitions to return
to the moon and Journey to Mars
transferring to a more commercial model
is allowing industry to take over many
of those areas that NASA has
traditionally been responsible for like
the design and operations and
maintenance of Space Systems but the
most exciting part I think is New
Opportunities the iPhones would have
never come from the government for
instance the base technology came from
the government but the way it's used the
way it interacts with consumers
governments aren't really built for that
so I think that'll be exciting to see
how Private Industry uses the same
technology or the same systems but then
use them in a different way
every NASA achievement has been the
collaborative achievement of NASA and
Industry what's going on right now
that's a little bit different is NASA is
turning to companies not to direct them
what to do but it's turning to companies
to build relationships with them because
those companies are attracting
investment from non-space sources and
are bringing a different kind of
innovation to the table
[Music]
in the shadow of NASA's sprawling
Johnson Space Center the headquarters of
startup Axiom space might seem a little
modest but their goal is Big to build
the first commercial space station
led by a former ISS program manager the
team has been involved in every mission
to the station since its Inception we
know it has to be much lower cost to
operate on orbit than ISS is today so
this is key to continuing the heritage
of ISS is to start there so we can
evolve everybody to the next platform I
liken this to the Internet so the
internet was created and we got very
excited and any kid with a good idea and
just the basic programming skills could
go build a program to do something we
have huge companies that grew out of
that and still today there's new ideas
new things being built
the thing about a microgravity
environment is it's Limitless it's like
the data we have access to on the
internet it is Limitless and it is not
immediately obvious to us all the
benefits that that's going to entail but
over time it will become very very
obvious
by 2024 Axiom plans to send a central
node to attach to the ISS that will make
up the core of their new station this
will be followed by crew quarters for 16
people and research and Manufacturing
modules when the ISS is retired this
will break away and additional modules
with a lifespan of 30 years will be
added and swapped out as they age using
a robotic arm and they're hoping to do
all of this for 1 50th the cost of the
ISS
I mean when you talk about our vision it
sounds really simple it really is about
driving the thought process and the cost
down so that anybody that wants to take
advantage of our place in orbit and a
microgravity environment can do so and
that's really it
the International Space Station is a
fantastic vehicle but one of the big
things is they have a quite a few
major components outside which means you
have to do an Eva a spacewalk to go fix
it a spacewalk on a good day is 100
hours of crew time to get ready and
actually go do the the spacewalk so
we're able to take advantage of the
reduced size of components and so our
design is going to have all of the
components are going to be in the
pressurized environment
so we know what the basics are you know
water food
clothing life support and we know how to
handle those but now the next step is
how do we make it more intuitive and we
want to now take advantage of the
Technologies and the and the
capabilities have today to build more
luxury into the experience the objective
is to make the environment the
background for all the users your
everyday doing whatever you want to do
on orbit research manufacturing looking
out the window whatever you're there to
do we want you to be able to do that not
even think about the environment and
it's because of our experience on ISS
and what the team brings to Axiom space
we're able to build that environment you
won't worry about that three two one
release release
fire fire like Virgin Galactic and blue
origin Axiom is hoping to attract space
tourists with tickets starting at 55
million dollars for a 10-day Mission but
that's just one part of the commercial
space station Market that they think
could be worth 37 billion dollars over
the next decade our first commercial
customers are countries Who Have
astronauts in space and want to expand
their activity in space and countries
who do not yet have a human space flight
program who want to send people up and
we've now got both research and
manufacturing companies who want to do
work with us while we're at the
International Space Station and on our
platform after it separates from ISS
human spaceflight is particularly
exciting because it's that slice of
space that is really innocent it hasn't
undergone the crowding that satellites
have had it hasn't already had that
explosive growth it's really ready for
that now
[Music]
the first thing I'm really looking
forward to seeing happen is the face of
our first astronauts on orbit looking
back down on us and knowing that we had
a hand in sending that person to space
and ultimately the separation of ISS
when it's ready to be retired and
deorbited and then we continue in space
independently for me that is a stepping
off moment for Humanity it's almost like
when Neil Armstrong put that first boot
on the moon this will be the first time
that we've gone from a platform of
learning how to live in space to
building our permanent home in space
other private companies also want to use
the ISS as the starting point for their
own Ventures Bigelow Aerospace already
has one of its inflatable structures
attached to the station and others
including Sierra Nevada and nanorax have
put forward proposals space habitats are
expensive I think it's a fast dichotomy
to say okay we're done with the
International Space Station let's move
on to commercial platforms what I think
is much more likely and realistic and
what NASA is certainly driving toward is
an incremental transition where
commercial platforms attach to the space
station or work collaboratively with the
space station the next chapter of cannot
occur without the active engagement of
companies that said that act of
Engagement might not be as customers
might not be as drivers it might be in
service of government mission objectives
we will return American astronauts to
the Moon Not only to leave behind
Footprints and flags but to build the
foundation we need to send Americans to
Mars and Beyond
[Music]
to reach a red planet has opened up a
longer-term market and some companies
are already Thinking Beyond orbiting
habitats like space stations to actually
building on the surface of other planets
I was working in a firm designing
skyscrapers and you know I saw Elon and
England and his Falcon X rocket in the
middle of the ocean and that for me was
a trigger I thought wow this could
actually happen and it's always been my
dream to put a building on the moon or
Mars and if he's going at the pace he's
going it could definitely happen within
my lifetime and I want to be the one to
build it
in this Warehouse alongside startups
from across the U.S Architecture Firm AI
space Factory are refining the
production of Marsha a four-story
structure they created for a NASA
competition to design the next
generation of space habitats on Mars you
know when we started designing our Mars
habitat Marsha I think we looked at
everything that had been done already
and kind of tossed that aside but what
we were given was a set of guidelines
from NASA they think the best way to
build a habitat on mars or the Moon is
to use what they call in-situ resource
utilization so use the materials that
are there if you've seen Sci-Fi movies
you might see like glass and steel domes
on distant planets but the reality is to
ship that kind of material to the moon
and Mars would be so exorbitant
expensive you would never be able to
build in the first place so the idea is
to send the 3D printing robot which can
then harvest the materials you find on a
site and build with that the reusable
print material cereal is a mix of
biopolymer made from recycled plastic or
plants like corn and sugarcane and
basalt a rock found on Mars and Earth
it's the rock that gives us its
Incredible strength we've tested this
material it's three times as strong as
Concrete in compression and it actually
has what we call it a tensile capacity
and prevent itself from being pulled
apart which is something concrete's not
very good at you need to think at all
times how do you optimize the amount of
material that you use and and that's
also why this thing is shaped like an
egg and if you think of an egg it's a
very structurally optimized form it's
very very thin but it provides the
strength that the egg needs and and
that's why this is shaped the way that
it is the X shape as well as the nested
shell structure also accommodates for
extreme differences in pressure and
temperature on the surface of Mars but
more research still needs to be done to
find out how print materials could be
gathered and how 3D printing would work
in a unique environment of space
you're dealing with a completely
different set of of physics and
environments which is very harsh the
cold you know the low gravity the vacuum
of space you know and and finding
solutions for how to build that or do
anything in space that just requires a
high degree of innovation there's no
such thing as Brute Force when it comes
to space like you need to think about
the problem
find a very elegant lightweight
cost-effective
solution the next challenge is really
going to places on Earth literally
taking the dirt that we're finding on a
site and beginning to print with the
dirt we have to perfect this technology
on Earth and then we go prove it out on
the moon
and then finally on to Mars
the first customers could include NASA
and companies like SpaceX who would
lease out these structures for
individual missions but before that AI
space Factory hoped their technology
could be monetized as well as
transformational here on Earth the
challenges of building on Mars forced us
to kind of make this jump in
construction technology which we can now
apply on Earth to build more sustainably
so rather than building with steel and
concrete which are these manufactured
very energy intensive materials to go to
a site have a solar powered array that
would then allow our 3D printer to print
in the most sustainable way possible and
we never would have found these ways
that wasn't for the challenge of
building in space
three two one ignition and liftoff of
the Falcon 9 to the space station on the
first commercial launch from Kennedy
Space centers
historic pad 39a humans have now been
consistently living and working in space
for more than 15 years and if we want to
keep that up what do habitats need to
look like and frankly they can be larger
they can be small but the future of
space habitats really to me comes down
to the ability to persistently maintain
human presence whether that's a few
people or many people that seems to be
the dividing line between where we were
before and where we want to be in the
future
we have to learn how to benefit from
what we do on orbit and bring those
natural benefits back home so we help
ourselves out on the ground while we
also learn to live somewhere else and it
really at the very deepest level is
about survival of our species so I get
pretty excited when I spend a few
moments thinking about what we're off to
go do because this really is the first
step to learning to live live off the
planet
that first step is just the start of our
journey to create a lasting Legacy in
space
while commercial companies may be
stepping in to imagine what these new
space habitats look like it's what's
happening inside of them that may unlock
the future of space industrialization
on the next episode of giant leap we'll
visit the private companies who are
looking to build their business around
Manufacturing in space
using the unique properties of
microgravity they plan to create new
materials with extraordinary qualities
that can't be replicated on Earth
including new manufacturing techniques
that could change how we build large
structures in space and even unlock the
ability to 3D print full human organs
but before low earth orbit can become a
new industrial center we're going to
need to take another giant leap
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
foreign hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look at that that is the biggest crowd
MTV has ever ever had
why
two words Backstreet Boys
in the 90s it was a great time to be in
the music business
things were booming and as a result
expensive parties big launches yeah that
was part of the culture
this is the era of in sync and the
Backstreet Boys
this is the era where a single hit could
sell you 10 million albums Plus
they were just printing money
[Music]
you have the great sales of CDs over
that period dwarfing whatever had
happened in the industry before
the profits coming in no massive
it was a hell of a lot of fun
from my viewpoint we were going to get
better and better all the time
[Music]
we really didn't foresee the change in
the technology
we'll be telling you tonight about a
method of compressing audio data called
MP3
[Music]
and um that was the end of everything we
know
[Music]
the birth of the MP3 was a seminal
moment for all of media and
entertainment it would completely change
the music industry completely disrupted
open up people's minds to what the
future would be
[Music]
if music is free for downloading the
music industry is not viable movies
books television nothing creative has
any value anymore
the music industry simply did not
embrace the magnitude of the change and
it failed you can't fight progress you
can't fight technology
the mb3 totally changed people's
relationship to the internet to culture
and to how Society works
it's a fact it was so much bigger than
just the music industry
[Music]
would you say that you love audio do you
just love it oh sure oh sure
I have to admit I got older so I'm not
as critical in listening as I've been
some decades ago
but I definitely
love music and love audio
and I have to say with all this great
reproduction technology the best is
still to sit in a concert hall to hear
real musicians
[Music]
when people call me the father of MP3 I
always have to add no no I was as you
sometimes say standing on the shoulders
of giants
but my original contribution is really
some of the basic ideas to MP3
story of the MP3 really begins in West
Germany back then in the early 80s and
even late 70s
people started trying to compress music
including my own thesis advisor Dita
seitzer
theater was a Visionary who came up with
the MP3
he was seeing the original digitization
of music with a compact disc and
thinking instead of manufacturing
Millions upon millions of plastic discs
why don't we store all the data in one
centralized computer and then stream it
to people in their homes
moment so he applied for a patent to use
the phone system to transmit music
1982 that's when they first had this
idea
but at a huge problem
the compact disc took about a million
bits of information to store one second
of audio
and the pipe they were trying to send it
through the telephone could only do
about 128 000 bits
for this to work they somehow had to
magically shrink the size of the compact
disc by 90 percent or more the patent
examiner looked at it and that no it's
not possible
essentially almost everyone thought this
was impossible there's no way to do this
but around 87 or 88 Dieter science was
brilliant graduate student Brandon Burke
made a breakthrough
by taking advantage of the sort of
obscure academic discipline
psych acoustics
the human ear has a lot of inherited
flaws
for example two tones that are close
together in Pitch will begin to cancel
each other out
and therefore if he realized much of the
information in the compact disc was
irrelevant the ear couldn't actually
hear it
to devise a series of mathematical
models to eliminate all of those
inefficient bits of data that you will
never hear
and in so doing he was in fact able to
shrink the music by an extraordinary
amount
foreign
what was done in the end exceeded the
expectations of everybody
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
the functionality of what they put up
was relatively Limited you had to go and
get a serial number where you paid and
license it to unlock full functionality
but the way the software underground
worked in the 90s is that practically
these serial numbers were available
anywhere
we tried writing looks as a stolen
software we will send the public
prosecutor after you
which of course
doesn't really work in these days
it starts to percolate out of the
academic audio and Computing sphere into
the broader public
and by 96 the Pirates find out about it
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
foreign hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
at bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions scrams or industry
buildings electricity all of those
things everything you need to know about
our changing environment the politics of
global warming we can and we will deal
with climate change in the fight against
climate change when we're green as you
covered
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the years about 1997 1998
I'm in seventh grade
uh school friend of mine said hey
there's a way you can listen to music
for free on your computer check this out
after I discovered my first MP3 it blew
the the floodgates wide open that's all
I did every single day every single
night
[Music]
I was the founder of the MP3 piracy
group known as audio pucks
we specialized in everything from punk
rock to ska to hardcore and heavy metal
the downloaders from Indonesia Japan or
Russia you name it people are
downloading
[Music]
back then in the late 90s if you want to
find MP3s you would go into IRC channels
it was a series of chat rooms that were
hidden and invite only
I eventually found these great little
channels that have membership solid by
enforcing a upload ratio where you had
to upload three songs or two songs or
whatever number in order to download one
song
so I would pull money together with my
friends in order to get a CD
Ripa CD
and then compress that into an MP3
and then we would spend all night
uploading the album putting it out on
the internet
we're eventually able to keep repeating
the process and have almost an assembly
line structure
and in our Prime we had probably close
to a thousand albums in our catalog
man now it was almost like a full-time
job which is dedicated to these song
files
did you ever think like wow this this is
kind of like I'm stealing from these
artists did that ever occur to you
you know in the late 90s we were idiots
we were kids yeah I I started this when
I was 12. I didn't know what I was doing
it wasn't called piracy back then
it was just file sharing
in the late 90s my staff started
monitoring the online space and we
really did see a significant amount of
interest in MP3 all of a sudden because
of its ability to compress a music file
the latest Advance called MP3 comes via
the Internet it's the future of music
and audio I'm sure that there are
millions of you out there who not only
understand what digital downloading
technology is about but who use it daily
to Great personal advantage
I think there really wasn't any sort of
panic in the industry in the early days
my team did look at it and see it as not
really as much of a threat as an
opportunity
we used to call it the celestial jukebox
Celestial jukebox it was a theoretical
construct at the time
every song ever made was going to be in
what we call the cloud right now and
would be instantaneously available to
anyone on the planet simply by pressing
a button on your Gizmo
but the industry really did not Embrace
that opportunity
I think when we first heard the term MP3
we didn't really know if that was
important or how it might be important
and even if it was important how did it
affect us
[Music]
but there was an awareness that the
digital Revolution was coming
and anybody who was in a senior position
had to say how do we make this work for
us
we began trying to find a way to
legitimately sell music on the internet
what systems do we develop how do we
deal with how we sell it how do you
price it Sony Music said today it'll be
the first major recording company to
sell new releases through the internet
these virtual singles be released at the
same time as CDs go into the stores
we were working at it but the senior
Executives that still had the mentality
of you needed a hard good and that was
the basis of their business
the music industry was making gobs of
money selling CDs that's the bottom line
so companies like mine mp3.com that went
to them and said hey we want to work
with you let's figure out something that
gives the consumer some value and gives
you some value they didn't want to hear
any of that
they tell me no the computer is for word
processing and spreadsheets
and they couldn't see it
we had meeting after meeting after
meeting with companies with proposals
for new technological ideas
um generally who knew absolutely nothing
about how the record business worked
which made it difficult for them to
express how it was good for us
so basically all of this stuff was for
naught
and then peer-to-peer came along and uh
changed everything
[Music]
I just stopped going to school I left my
dorm room I didn't tell any of my
friends I just stopped going
I knew that if I had told them what I
was planning on doing they would have
convinced me not to do it or they would
if they would have questioned my
decision to leave
in 1999 observing that file sharing was
fun but was not easy
Sean Fanning and Sean Parker come around
and create Napster
[Music]
they were two teenagers hanging around
an IRC chat Channel and swapping MP3
files
now at the time there were all these MP3
files being created but there was no
sort of central index where you could go
download them easily
and so Fanning said why don't I create a
new technology that will connect all
these files together
something called a peer-to-peer server
my computers appear and your computers
appear the files that are on your
computer I have access to them and vice
versa
so it was like the ultimate file trading
tool
and it facilitated really low friction
sharing of music
Parker's role was essentially the face
of the organization
Fanning wrote the code Fanning kind of
did all the technical and computer side
stuff
I was spending two or three days in a
row sitting at a machine writing code I
passed out on the desk or on the floor
it was just a blur
this is a guy who just sat in the
basement and cranked for six months
was the first computer program he ever
wrote he went out and bought a Visual
Basic book knew what he wanted to get to
and just kept at it
he was not to be deterred
and of course it took off
my head of anti-piracy Frank Creighton
came in my office and said I've just
found the most fascinating thing
it was Napster
I put in you know Madonna's Holiday
I was like whoa
it's pretty amazing that's like the
celestial jukebox we've been talking
about this for years
we immediately contacted them and said
you know really cool system but you're
infringing on copyright
well if you send us a list of all of
your songs we'll make sure that none of
them are on there
I said all right just start with the
Billboard top 200 songs take those off
they said okay fine we'll try that well
they didn't
and it just grew and grew and grew it's
called Napster and is by far the fastest
way to download music from the internet
it allows anyone to copy thousands of
musical selections for free and if you
said so quickly that it's clogging
computer networks on hundreds of
campuses
so this became hugely popular overnight
basically
it was really one of the first viral
apps
the hysteria over Napster culminated in
I would say an riaa board meeting in
February of 2000.
it was in Los Angeles at the Four
Seasons Hotel and I will never forget
this day
all of the heads of the labels literally
the titans of the music business were in
that room
I had somebody wheel in a PC and put
some speakers up and I started doing a
Name That Tune
give me your last five biggest hits
every single song that somebody named
was available on Napster
[Music]
well give me some old ones like what you
know name older artists
that was on there
[Music]
okay now tell me what you're releasing
next week
and sure enough you know 20 of the top
new yet to be released songs were on
there as well
[Applause]
we used to have this line in the record
business that there was sort of nothing
a good hit couldn't fix
there was no screw-up a good hit
couldn't fix
there was no amount of money lost on a
deal that a good hit couldn't fix
I think that was the moment when people
said hmm
maybe a good hit can't fix this one
[Music]
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
history experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring see what's
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
our generation's biggest problem climate
change is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions transport industry
buildings electricity all of those
things everything you need to know about
our changing environment the politics of
global warming we can and we will deal
with climate change in the fight against
climate change Bloomberg green has you
covered
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
MTV News I was wondering if you had any
MP3s on your computer yeah so uh how
many MP3s you have on your computer it's
about 600. uh six or seven thousand
come again six or seven thousand
probably like three hundred for real
where'd you get them from uh truthfully
most of them from Napster
[Music]
the first time I heard about digital
music was through Napster
and I didn't really understand what it
was but I knew I could get any song I
wanted how many of you download music
from the internet
okay when I realized that there is an
opportunity to just download everything
we want and not really pay for it I I
started to use it
19 year old Sean Fanning developed the
Napster computer program today at BYU he
was treated like a rock star
strange it's awkward I can't I'm not
used to this he's an awesome guy and
he's so young too
[Music]
so you don't think this is stealing
not at all because you're just getting a
few songs that you find interesting and
seeing what's up
there was this era of discovery that
felt like the virtual version of a
record store I remember saying to myself
shortly after downloading my first MP3
I'm never gonna buy music again
[Music]
foreign
music No Stealing music don't steal the
music don't steal music
if people Leach out the system for free
the creators of copyright will not get
compensated and the movies and music
will not get made it's as simple as that
[Music]
when it became possible for people to
get music for free there was a lot of
outcry and a lot of concern about well
why do people think it's free what you
know why is that right if you make
something and somebody takes it without
compensating you you're hurt by that
everyone would like to have everything
for free
that's not how we work and it's not fair
it's not right
when you got a technology that gives
away what you do free
how do you compete with free I mean
when Napster hit it wasn't just an issue
for the music industry young teenagers
teenagers mind you are coming up with
ways we can get DVD movies on our
computers for free
anything that was reducible to a one or
a zero was potentially available freely
to Consumers
all of this was you know from a music
industry executive perspective
terrifying
[Music]
all right
artist Napster was probably a good thing
it made it so much easier to get
exposure
probably 96 97 started making my first
songs on the computer and putting them
on the Internet
and then Napster came out
it was pretty it was massive you know
I look at my songs on Napster and like
see see him on there like a lot you know
if a lot of search results came up it
was like a lot of people had it so you
could kind of tell like that like wow so
this stuff's really spreading you know
[Music]
I think Napster did a lot for
Independent Artists at that time
it was the beginning of an independent
path to find your following such that
you can sustain yourself have a career
without having a major label contract
benefit was and is an awesome MC but way
ahead of his time
the major labels weren't paying
attention to what was happening in the
MP3 world to their loss because the MP3
world was like a minor leagues
and if somebody floats they arrives to
the top then they could you know zoom
off to that other level the old Paradigm
from the last century only was good for
that last century the new century I look
at Nasa as being new radio and people
are finding ways that now you're gonna
have a million artists in a million
labels now all in the record game
but then the flip side if you're making
a living off of music as a musician and
suddenly your revenue streams like cut
out some money you're like yeah I
totally understand
from the neck down neck down neck down
I remember Lars from Metallica was like
you know he was really mad about it
Napster hijacked our music without
asking they never thought our permission
our catalog of Music simply became
available for free downloads on the
Napster system the argument I hear a lot
that music should be free must then meet
the musicians should work for free
nobody else works for free why should
musicians
drummer Lars Ulrich and his bandmates
say Napster is illegal and filed suit
against its creator for copyright
infringement
most artists weren't really too thrilled
with being on the other side of the kind
of the hip-hop new young thing
but Lars was frankly unafraid
to get out there
if they want to steal Metallica's music
instead of hiding behind their computers
in their bedrooms and dorm rooms and
just go down a towel records and grab
them off the shelves instead
when I saw Lars Ulrich going on that
campaign I just remember thinking that
was the lamest thing I'd ever seen
like Metallica you're all millionaires
so what are you complaining about
what's your beef with Metallica then why
not let the people listen to music
as far as I'm concerned Metallica
is off
five best help
foreign
[Music]
there was definitely a lot of hate and a
lot of backlash
my friend definitely said yeah F
Metallica I'm done I'm only listening to
Nirvana now I've removed all the
Metallica files from my from my hard
drive I don't want anything to do with
metallic anymore this mattered to a lot
of people Napster was like this symbol
of freedom and so when you have guys
like Lars Ulrich trying to shut Napster
down you're gonna have a hell of a
backlash
foreign
's argument was the one that I supported
and others in the industry did as well
but this was an incredibly disruptive
force in the music industry no matter
what side of the argument you came down
on
and the industry had to shut all of this
down
[Music]
using a PC to download music is one of
the hottest of today's Computer Trends
and that has the recording companies up
in arms and heading to court
at the center of their dispute is a
music sharing internet service known as
Napster
the litigation against Napster was
fairly monumental
they were fighting Us in court
aggressively
napster's point of view is like we don't
personally share any files okay we just
facilitate connections between users and
we're not responsible for policing the
contents of our Network
pure and simple it was theft of
intellectual property and I just can't
get past that that fundamental reality I
still get agitated even at this point
years later
[Music]
CNN covered the court decision live
so there was a lot of pressure
you know 25 million people were using
Napster every single day and really
invested in the outcome
success
and he and the judge ruled that it was
obvious to everyone at Napster that they
knew what was going on
Napster repealed that and lost again
in a 68-page opinion the appeals court
said Napster knew its users were
violating copyright infringement laws
the song swapping service this weekend
will begin blocking access to millions
of musical files on Napster
we stopped the sharing we basically took
the servers offline
over a period of time the the
obligations to the creditors just
overwhelmed the company and uh there
didn't seem to be any way to get Revenue
in and so the board determined at that
point the best thing to do would be to
go into bankruptcy
the days of free music with Napster
folks are over
it felt like this really dark horrible
day in San Francisco
I was depressed lots of people were
depressed
technology had lost
foreign
but then of course the moles started
popping all over the place
[Music]
there are already dozens of alternatives
to Napster with names such as my Napster
Napa Gator and cute MX
we had other file sharing Services crop
up that were in many ways more Insidious
there was no centralized server that the
files passed through and that was much
more difficult to address even if they
crack down on one program like Kazar or
something I think there's going to be
another program coming out that in the
next week or two that's going to be
doing the same thing
the huge huge problem at the time is
that it was very hard to tell people not
to use peer-to-peer methods and they'll
say well what should we use and the
answer was go to a record store and buy
a CD that's not what they wanted to hear
the record companies have to wake up and
I think they will to the fact that
they're no longer in the business of
hiring trucks and having big warehouses
and shipping CDs around people want
their music via the Internet
the answer to the piracy was to give
people what they otherwise wanted in a
legitimate way at a fair and reasonable
price we needed to have a legitimate
online music store
thank you
the labels tried in their own lame ways
to debut digital music stores of their
own which were total failures
I remember trying to use these things
and then these special players and and
it was just it was really pretty
anti-diluvian and and nobody really
signed up for these things
for the longest time there is such a
divide between Silicon Valley and the
music industry
you know it was just a big war
it was not in the software industry's
interest to help the music industry
they sold a lot of computers because
people wanted to get their music and
other content for free
the music companies they said you know
you guys are all promoting piracy and
the tech guys are like oh you guys are a
bunch of luddites you don't understand
you have to change your business model
and the one guy who was able to bridge
that divide with Steve Jobs
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
World On Demand
foreign economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
I've been back about uh eight to ten
weeks and uh we've been working really
hard
and what we're trying to do uh is is not
something really highfalutin we're
trying to get back to the basics it's
Dave jobs and been fired at Apple and
then been brought back
and at the time he he Apple was uh in
some ways a bit player in the computer
space
the Mac products represented about three
percent market share
this company's absolutely going to turn
around as a matter of fact I think the
question now is is is is not can we turn
around Apple uh I think that's the booby
prize I think it's can we make apple
really great again
in 2001 he introduced the iPod there it
is right there
so Steve saw a great opportunity in the
music space for Apple
[Applause]
music's been around for a long time
you know it's a real tangible market and
um I think if we can bring some value to
that market uh then we'll succeed
in late 2002 Steve Jobs called and said
that he was going to create an online
music store
and I saw that as the perfect
opportunity to at least say all right
we've got something out there
we came up to Cupertino
and went into a conference room
and Steve walks in I don't think we even
knew that that was going to happen
but he walks in and says I want to show
you the iTunes Store and he sits there
for two hours himself with the mouse
showing how the store would work
he was like a little kid in a candy
store absolutely you know fascinated
with this thing that I remember thinking
it's so simple and in fact it was but
that's what made it billion
it worked better than anything we'd ever
seen before
and it became obvious this this was a
good thing to to go with
[Applause]
the one thing of course about the iTunes
music store he wanted every song to be a
buck
Steve Jobs wanted to sell singles off of
every album that was on iTunes
he did not want a single album on the
store that you could not break down in
singles that had you know really serious
uh ramifications you know for the music
industry
that would be unbundling the album
[Music]
is a bundle
it's a bundle of songs if you want one
song You must buy the entire package
bundles inflate the total revenue
because people are kind of forced to pay
up a bit
so let's take a canonical example which
would be Vanilla Ice
[Music]
I would be surprised if most people can
name more than one Vanilla Ice song
but vanilla I sold something like 10
million albums on the basis of just one
hit song
so 150 160 million dollars in Revenue
once you liberated the single from the
album that excess income from the
compact disc would go away forever you
would only earn a small fraction of what
you previously earned
they knew this was going to hurt them
they say as a music fan but it seems
like music is almost disposable now
you would put out an album what every
six years tour for those six years off
of that one album but now having to put
out a single and then three singles and
then all of a sudden it's just a string
of singles with no cohesion like an
album and really the songs don't have as
much meaning to you as they did back
then
the pitch that Jobs made to the majors
was we will save you
it was like a siren song
[Music]
there was no choice really about anyone
who's odd about it there was no choice
today we've got 200 000 tracks
and all of this music with all of these
rights you can buy for 99 cents per song
[Applause]
it's called iTunes iTunes online music
store the iTunes music store they've
really just created you know what we've
all been waiting for which is a purely
digital music Marketplace iTunes did
spectacularly well
you had that great growth of downloads
iTunes recently sold this 50 millionth
song but the deal the industry made with
apple to me was a huge mistake the
unbundling of albums meant that the
revenue that came in was significantly
diminished
we were hopeful that the physical
product was hold on longer than it did
as it turned out it didn't
CD sales have dropped almost one quarter
in just three years that's an awful lot
of lost business buyers got very fed up
with spending eighteen dollars when
there's only one or two songs they like
this change with iTunes made people so
upset that people actually started
taking their products off the platform
Estelle had an album that had come out
and the label found out that about 90 of
the purchases were just of one song
American Boy
they pulled the entire album off of
platform for three weeks before caving
in and putting it back on
[Music]
really they were desperate
and they decided what they would do was
go after the end users of the
peer-to-peer sites
the average file Sharer John and Jane
download
this was extremely controversial within
the record industry Hillary Rosen the
head of the riaa actually resigned in
protest
I didn't want us to go against
individuals even though they were the
source of a huge amount of illegal
activity I felt like ultimately they
were still music fans
but essentially I was kind of overruled
my last day at the Raa was the day
before the litigation against
individuals started
[Music]
yesterday the music industry took
another step for the first time going
after people downloading and swapping
music online we want people to stop
engaging in the theft of music so that
people can go on making it
I don't remember if I got it via letter
or email
but I basically got what looked like a
scam from the riaa saying you owe us for
having downloaded music
I honestly ignored it because I didn't
care and
uh I got they sent another letter
saying I could be sued for up to thirty
thousand dollars per song of which there
were thousands
I didn't have that much money
I don't think anyone did I wasn't ever
really worried about getting fined for
downloading MP3s mainly because I was
using my Mom's computer and I was kind
of so I was like oh my mom's gonna get
fined not me like you can't take a 13
year old's income when he doesn't have
any income
filed something like 17
000 lawsuits
but rather than going after the big
infringers they ended up suing children
and grandmothers and people who were
dead and you know moms
Bonnie Bassett was shocked to be slapped
with a lawsuit for the hundreds of songs
her teens downloaded off the internet
for free my kids go to Catholic school
we bring we brought him up right no one
in our family has been arrested I mean
we don't we don't steal we don't steal
it's just ridiculous it was it was
absurd it was absurd I'm not downloading
anything ever again I mean
not even screensavers
almost everybody was forced to settle uh
often for a relatively small amount of
money like three or four thousand
dollars
but in the end this just made people
hate them
it didn't create a deterrent effect it
just made them loathed
you know I've been an avid record
collector for over 40 years right I've
got nearly 10 000 records you turned a
music fan
into an enemy
in fact more people probably went to
piracy as a result of this than anything
else
[Music]
I ended up having to pay like I think
close to a thousand dollars to the riaa
but in the end I ended up recouping my
losses by downloading overtime and
doubling down
between the piracy and the unbundling
the industry recognized that it was on a
decline
and over the course of you know 15 years
shrank significantly
[Music]
industry Revenue I think in 99 was
worldwide 34 billion
and it fell to something like 16 billion
the industry was just destroyed
annihilated
[Music]
a simple dynamic in business
when an industry is under threat you
consolidate
which is a fancier word for cutting
costs
you put two big music Enterprises
together you can eliminate a whole bunch
of jobs
[Music]
I'm currently standing in front of what
used to be the Virgin Megastore Union
Square
closed in June of 2009 it is now
a Duane Reade in a Citibank
[Music]
this building formerly used to be Tower
Records
it was the first Tower Records in New
York
that window right there where the light
is that floor I worked on it was the um
OD section
CD sales were dipping since I think like
2000 2001
that's where the decline really kicked
in I can't even remember the last time I
physically went and bought a CD
a 2006 happened was all over for me that
was the end of it
wasn't much I could do Tower records may
be toppling the music chain is preparing
to file for bankruptcy next week
when Tower was bought out a lot of us
the employees that worked there fell
into like a depression
we're like wow this this is it the job
the tower is going to be gone for good
how do I feel about it
crappy
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
World On Demand
foreign hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
at bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
look I brought a disc and we could copy
this okay no problem
all we gotta do is
[Music]
don't copy don't copy that floppy
beeping stealing take it what's not
yours is that really what you want your
life to go but they can't stop people
from coughing it's too easy it might be
easy but it's still against the law
don't copy don't copy that fluffy
foreign
[Music]
the mid-2000s post Napster
music piracy was still a huge problem
at the time it was all torrents
everybody had moved to Torrance that's
how most people were sort of young
people at least were getting their music
online piracy is costing the U.S film
industry 20 billion dollars a year
like don't they know they can download
that stuff for free
use BitTorrent
way to fight
a fight pack of them 98 shame on you
people
music industry was preoccupied with the
whole peer-to-peer file transfer illegal
theft
it had to figure out how it was going to
attack and approach the marketplace in
this new world to be able to remain
viable and competitive to us it's black
and white and you pay for it straight up
and down is stealing
foreign
[Music]
Sweden out of all the countries in the
world had adopted pyrep technology more
than anywhere else
it was a country full of hackers they'd
come up with all different kind of takes
on peer-to-peer networks and bittorrents
and they had the pirate party
the entire political party that really
traces its roots back to Napster
[Applause]
for them trading music it's like a
political cultural calling
[Applause]
the Swedish parts of the music industry
they were suffering even more than maybe
their American counterparts very few
people were buying CDs anymore or very
few people were buying licensed material
online everyone was using the file
sharing Networks
at that time there was a guy named
Daniel Eck who was Swedish who had
previously been the CEO of a torrent
company and he said I have a plan to
make people pay for music again we're
going to move beyond the locally stored
MP3 file into the kind of like globally
distributed stream that was his business
model which he calls Spotify
What If instead of you know having to go
through the trouble of you know buying
and downloading music what if they had
access to all the music in the world
[Music]
just through a streaming service
[Music]
Spotify launched in Sweden in October
2008
Spotify took off in Sweden and so Eck
was able to go around to different
countries and get and get the labels
there to do the same thing and
eventually he came to the U.S
potatoes he's not Steve Jobs
[Music]
is very soft-spoken you can tell that
he's kind of a nerdy engineer
is very polite and and easy going and
for the labels I think Daniel being not
as abrasive and scary and Powerful as
Steve Jobs was probably pretty
attractive
and the thought of him sitting in a room
with all these music execs and and
banging his fist on the table is hard
for me to imagine
but he's the one who talks all of these
labels into cooperating and giving the
service that he made a chance
Spotify they presented us with an option
now we could say we don't want to use it
we don't want to distribute that way but
we'll be like dinosaurs and we wouldn't
be here the mistakes the major record
labels made in the late 90s I will give
them credit for this they learn from
those mistakes and they understood that
they had to scramble to get ahead of the
next wave of Technology Europe's best
kept secret is out in the open Spotify
has landed in the USA and with 10
million registered users in Europe it
could be a big hit here the unlimited
service is ad-free but locked to your
computer while the premium service
brings Spotify to your mobile devices
you're like hey you want to hear this
new song all you have to do is go boom
it's right there wait a minute
everything's here like everything just
like the first time I used an MP3 I said
oh my God I'm never going to pay again
the first time I use Spotify I was like
I'm going to pay again aren't I and so
that's how well it worked
foreign
of the century until three or four years
ago the music industry had lost around
40 percent of its entire value physical
sales are pretty much over but streaming
is growing growing growing next thing
you know Google Amazon Microsoft Apple
they all want to have a streaming
Subscription Service good morning
good luck today we're announcing Apple
music today I'm happy to announce Google
play music all access Amazon is taking
the plunge diving into an already
crowded streaming Market with a new
subscription music service some big
names behind us streaming music service
being relaunched now with some help from
Jay-Z he bought title for 56 million
dollars in January we've reached a point
where there are too many streaming
options to mention companies ran away
from music because there wasn't any
growth now there is that's a sign that
the industry is becoming healthy you
know after years of being you know
really sick
it's just a question of what it means
for artists
for Microsoft Google Apple music doesn't
mean something special to them it's just
somebody that gets bundled along in this
monthly fee that you pay for various
things whereas obviously this is the
lifeblood for musicians streaming has a
lot of business challenges attached to
it the whole notion of micro pennies
you could have hundreds of thousands of
streams and you get paid 12 cents people
can't even tell me what a stream is
worth it just changes from month to
month to month to month to month no one
knows how to quantify
as far as online streaming the record
companies they take whatever their
percentage is everyone gets a cut
what's left of that we have to split
four ways and with our manager so it's
literally nothing you know the artists
are looking at these 10th of ascent
royalties and going that's crazy do you
know how many times I'm gonna have to
listen to that song or those groups of
songs to be equivalent to what I'd make
from an album sale
tonight word of a music Smackdown Taylor
Swift is pulling her music off of
spotify and all of this over pricing in
an editorial she wrote file sharing and
streaming have Shrunk the numbers of
paid album sales drastically valuable
things should be paid for that's all
what Taylor Swift just did and I think
that's awesome I mean the only person
really getting screwed here is the
artist and that's the way it always is
why don't they pay Taylor Swift more why
don't they pay you already the rugged
Man more Taylor don't need the money as
much as me but she's got a good point
everybody's doing the work then they
need to get paid
just that simple
I need my money
so you had some artists speaking out
Rihanna released a new single last week
she's one of the partners of title you
can't stream it on Spotify but you can
stream it exclusively on title in
reality they're all coming back
streaming is it's the way that the music
industry is going so we're all going to
have to figure out a way to make it work
when people are bitching they're not
making enough money they have to
understand if you're a successful artist
today you can make more money than
you've ever made in the history of the
music business their sponsorships and
you can do ads in addition concert
revenues exceed by a huge margin what
they used to so you have to look at all
the opportunities not only from these
streaming services yeah you get Pennies
on the dollar whatever who cares go out
there and play a show and make money and
get out there and do that don't complain
about an internet streaming service
that's so lame
Crimea River
[Music]
through this entire period of time while
the recorded music industry has been
down the live music industry has been
flourishing
and there's maybe an easy explanation in
a world where we get less and less
personal online
the precious thing is seeing it live and
experiencing it because you can't
digitize experience
the digital age makes it a lot easier to
scout talent I would say
we're able to get data and metrics from
all sorts of different sites whether
that's Spotify listener data on the
publicly available about the artist page
there's usually about 40 percent we see
of their monthly listeners in a certain
city would actually purchase tickets to
that show in that City
[Applause]
I think now your recording is an
advertisement for your performance and
your live engagement not the other way
around
touring
touring is non-stop Revenue all year
that's where all the money comes from
I'll talk till I'm dead
I've taught till I'm dead
[Music]
it shouldn't be that you have to be a
touring act touring is grueling we don't
want to tour all the time you know it's
we're getting older and it's a lot of
hard work being out there doing that but
those are things you have to do
I think I make the most the majority of
my money from shows it wasn't always
like that but it's like that now merch
is probably next
I didn't think I'd be a t-shirt Merchant
well then I was started making music
these are socks these go really quickly
especially at shows this is a raincoat
it has the Hot Sugar Castle I have
shirts I have afro hoodies I have this
afro shirt right here this is a t-shirt
another T-shirt with another picture of
me you cannot to my knowledge download a
shirt
this is a front and back hat
this is Valhalla Java it's a brand of
coffee that Zack Wilde created
I'm telling you you can clean your house
about five times mow the lawn three
times even though it's already finished
the first time you mow it and that's
before brunch
and it is one of the best selling
coffees on Amazon
you have to as an artist make products
that are sellable
because music is not is sellable as it
used to be
where records had always been by far the
majority of the income earned by people
who made albums increasingly artists
were making more money from touring from
Live Events and to giving and
Merchandising animals and they really
were earning from their records our
Revenue model didn't make any sense any
longer
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
access the financial World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions transport industry
a building's electricity all of those
things everything you need to know about
our changing environment the politics of
global warming we can and we will deal
with climate change in the fighting
against climate change when we're green
has you covered
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I was offered really deals in my life
[Music]
and it got to the point where I hated my
label
so I said hey I'm gonna run and do this
myself
and when I started doing Independent
Records that's when all my money started
coming in and that's where all my
success started coming and that's where
all of my fans started coming in
Chance the rapper has gone from making
mixtapes in his South Side Chicago home
Towing three Grammys and Performing for
the president at the White House all
without the backing of a single record
label more artists have been making more
music at home and releasing it
themselves in into streaming services so
it's a it's been a creative Renaissance
we're now going to be rolling out the
ability to monetize directly on
Soundcloud we're inviting hundreds of
thousands of creators this means more
money in their pocket at the end of the
day on a revenue share basis
thousands of people are making money off
their talents and hobbies with patreon
patreon is a lot like Kickstarter but
it's ongoing so it's per music video I
upload
band camp is this website where artists
can independently just take the music
that they produce themselves and put it
up onto the website an artist uploads
their music to bandcamp uh a fan pays
them directly for it we take a small cut
it's about half of what uh iTunes
charges bandcamp has become the hero I
think that they are more closely attuned
to listening to the needs of musicians
and actually Meeting those concrete
needs it's better than I think
virtually any other company that's out
there they've really provided an online
record store and a way for artists to
recoup money and I haven't seen any
other company try to meet those needs
if you've got merchandise if you've got
physical CDs if you've got t-shirts and
hats and all sorts of stuff like that
you can sell that directly on the
bandcamp platform as well can't do that
on Spotify or apple music
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
Milestone the world surpassing 1 million
deaths from the Coronavirus
I don't think we were prepared for the
realization that
the majority of our livelihood depended
on us being on the road all the time and
physically being at shows
[Music]
foreign
most artists today who are successful
are making majority of their income
through live performance
60 70 sometimes upwards of 80 percent of
an Arvest income is reliant on touring
on merchandise on on this which is empty
a little more than a month before
they're scheduled to be in California
variety reports BTS canceled shows in
Seoul Korea due to fear over the spread
of the virus more than 40 percent of
Canadians wouldn't feel comfortable
going to a music event until at least
six months after social restrictions are
lifted
the shutdown of live shows this year has
affected me in so many different ways I
have been turning to live streaming I'm
on Twitch every week I've built up a
nice little Community I've got a Discord
going I'm doing the whole thing
look we about to get it breaking in this
you just tuned into the latest channel
on switch
in a major collaboration that's clearly
a sign of times 12 million players
locked into fortnite last night to watch
a virtual Travis Scott perform in
concert
[Applause]
it's great for the artists it's great
for the fans and that's something I
think that you're going to see more of
after the pandemic is people not wanting
to just see a show at a venue in a
theater and you'll want to see more and
more experiences and unless unless just
pure concerts
everybody
on you Facebook you like And subscribe
to let's go make sure you subscribe make
sure you smash the Subscribe button on
YouTube thank you guys for donating even
if you didn't have the means to donate
thank you for tuning in
foreign
I've had a music career just by going
straight to Consumers into an audience
and fans rather than waiting for this
faceless music industry guy to help
pitch it
you didn't do nothing I did all the hard
work so why shouldn't I make 100 of that
money
what's up what's up guys hi guys welcome
back to the channel zoom in I want to
see you I got my screen right up here I
can watch you guys interaction is
everything for me something that's
really unique with live streaming is
that you actually get to know the names
of your fans and you get to know their
their personal lives big hearts up for
big cheese right now cause he needs all
love man he was he was down for a little
second dude shout out Savannah bibo
Sparky miss winter Falcon you guys are
legends
Legends your fans get to actually chat
with you live and give input as far as
what they want to hear
so the revolution will be televised
after that
but there really is nothing like being
on stage with tens of thousands of
people in front of you at a festival
with the lights and everybody's
screaming
I just miss it all
[Applause]
I don't think streaming is the end of
the game
I think the game will continue to unfold
you as a talented artist you can go make
your own recording
you can build your career using social
media
and the major labels role in creating
the next generation of successful
artists will become less and less
important
we found out that the record companies
are limited
it's like okay you're taking but what
you're giving back you've given me a
piece of my soul back to me or you just
taking my soul and keeping it and
cashing it in
if you've only got a niche audience it
doesn't make sense to sign to a major
label right now more than ever the law
of a thousand true fans is what we're
going to see working as a model going
forward
you could have 10 million plays on your
song on Spotify but that doesn't mean
that you're going to sell 100 tickets to
a show
one thousand true fans can sustain you
if you have the right Platforms in place
and that can be anything from bandcamp
to patreon to Twitch any of these places
that are meant to build community and
allow you to have a space that you
control where you can sell virtually
anything about your creative process
that you want
most people who aren't on a major label
want to be
a lot of the DIY guys once they start to
kind of you know blow up they go to the
label
the weekend is a perfect example
he did these kind of brilliant albums in
his bedroom
they got massive radio play after you
gave them away for free
but then he went to the major label when
the time came
labels definitely have a place but
they're not The Gatekeepers anymore you
don't have to sign to a major record
label to be successful in the music
business anymore you know and thank God
for that
foreign
doors please
the MP3 is now an obsolete technology
by 1998 there were more sophisticated
Replacements available
but the core of what it did lives on
whenever you're streaming music via your
phone it's using the same techniques
that Brandenburg pioneered back in the
80s
people are walking around with their
Internet connected phones and they're
just listening to music all the time and
it couldn't be easier
so finally we have this thing that
everybody's been talking about literally
for you know 20 years the celestial
jukebox
and people are listening to more music
than they ever have in history
go to the roots of the mobile Computing
Revolution
it's based on MP3 piracy
the idea of walking into an Apple store
and spending three or four hundred
dollars on a gadget you had to get
primed by the MP3 to want to do that
ultimately I think the MP3 created more
value than it destroyed yesterday Apple
reported the largest quarterly profit of
any public company in history
a lot of money was made along the way
just not by the people who used to make
it
the fundamental way that companies make
money has completely changed the first
time an MP3 was moved from one person to
the next
Generations from that point forward have
realized access to things is more
valuable than owning them
why own a car when I can call Uber
anytime
why own a second home when I can go to
Airbnb
if I can have access and hear any song
when I want why I own a CD
the march of technology is a good thing
not a bad thing
the fact that it uniquely affected us
was the way of life really
nowadays I love to listen to classical
music
I love some of the newer music
what about rap music
oh yeah why not
talking about MP3
I had the feeling this is not good for
the music industry
but in the end
I think it changed for a bit better
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions transport industry
a building's electricity all of those
things everything you need to know about
our changing environment the politics of
global warming we can and we will deal
with climate change in the fight against
climate change when we're green has you
covered
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
IPOs and high-flying startups you're
used to seeing dramatic changes over
short periods of time but nothing in my
experience has really compared to what
wework has undergone I think people felt
like they blinked and and everything was
Different At Last reporting they're
running out of cash very quickly here
sources have told Bloomberg that the
company could run out of cash by next
month I was surprised at the vitriol and
the speed with which
investors apparently rejected what
wework was trying to do from the first
day that we started we work it was about
bringing people together there's an
energy that you feel that energy is
something that's hard to explain it's
something that either you feel it or you
don't we like to call it the we
generation in less than one year wework
one from one of the most highly valued
startups of all time to losing more than
three-fourths of its value
ousting its Rockstar CEO and desperately
needing a cash bailout from its biggest
investor just to keep the lights on in
order to understand how we got here we
need to take a look into the mistakes
made along the way the ambitious vision
of wework is effectively Dead period
This is a case study of when a company
got too much money too fast with no
effective oversight on how to spend it
they are no longer the market leader
that company is going to get smaller and
it's never going to be 10 times bigger I
mean the story is over
[Music]
as late as summer 2019 the co-working
company wework was considered one of the
most valuable startups with a 47 billion
dollar price tag more than Airbnb stripe
and SpaceX but in just a few months time
that valuation has vanished and the Very
future of the company is in doubt to
understand how this happened it all
starts with the company's now former CEO
and founder Adam Newman
Adam Newman is the co-founder of wework
and was its CEO for a long time he came
over to New York for college after being
in the Israeli Navy and started a few
businesses including my favorite example
is a baby clothes line with knee pads
his landlord was actually showing him
another building in Brooklyn when he
came up with the idea of sort of sub
dividing that space which Miguel
McKelvey his co-founder who's a trained
architect sort of came up with the plans
and then boom they were away they
started a company called Green desk
which they sold and that was the first
iteration of wework which they started
in 2010. we work as a new environment
for the workspace so co-working was sort
of where it started today there's a
movement in changing the way people work
2010 was a great time to be starting a
co-working company in New York City
there were a bunch of landlords with
empty Office Buildings vacancies wework
actually presented a solution for them
the very first building down in Grand
Street in downtown Manhattan was where
wework launched its first co-working
spot and from there it was sort of Boom
from 2010 to 2011 it doubled in size and
from then on the growth was exponential
some of their original investors were
people who were involved in commercial
real estate they got some early
investment from Adventure capital from
called Benchmark and eventually sort of
kept growing kept taking on new leases
and and started to grow the business
starting in New York City
business grew quickly and by 2015 the
company already quadrupled its valuation
to 10 billion dollars counting 23 000
customers paying memberships in 32
locations renting desks for as little as
45 dollars per month wework's whole idea
was let's not just be a commercial
office Leasing Company let us accelerate
the new world of how people work and
make it better
Community being surrounded by a group of
like-minded individuals being part of
something bigger than yourself inspires
people to work harder spend more time at
work and just have fun doing it and
initially this attracted the attention
of young entrepreneurs looking to expand
their companies we thought it's about
time to give you a tour of where we work
a tour of where we work a tour of where
we work you got your Cokes you got your
you got your Red Bulls incredible group
of people Everyone that I've met through
the wework community has been absolutely
awesome and all the staff here are
incredible
it's almost like a cult-like sensation
that they created with the very early
employees sort of realizing that wework
was more than a company it was a bit of
a family it was a community and members
too sort of realized that they realized
they could lean on each other in terms
of networking in terms of growing their
own businesses this excitement Drew in
even more investors to the company the
Adams and his company you know it's not
2.0 it's 10.0 I mean he's taken it to
really the next the next level and when
you walk into their space and you see
the energy you see the excitement you
see the interaction it's a very very
powerful uh concept
and the most crucial investor would be
SoftBank
I would say the time that I think we
were really started to take off was when
SoftBank invested in them in 2017 that
gave them a valuation of 20 billion
dollars and that's really when you start
to get into the high ranks of other
venture-backed private companies
with softbank's investment we were
quickly expanded its footprint
throughout the world
and it's the beginning also of this
partnership between Adam Newman and
masayoshi Zone who's the head of
SoftBank they have this meeting that is
often told again and again in the lore
of wework where Adam made this pitch and
Masa said that's great but let's make it
even bigger waywork is actually one of
overrated companies that SoftBank Vision
fund has backed with its over a hundred
billion dollars softbank's idea is
there's lots of money out there in this
unique period of transformation let's
make everything happen faster with more
money and let's enable companies that
have smart ideas to get even more
ambitious bigger and faster
between 2017 and 2018 SoftBank would
invest around 8 billion dollars into
wework doubling its valuation to 20
billion in 2017. in 2019 SoftBank
floated a potential 16 billion dollar
investment which would give them a
controlling stake in the company
ultimately they would scale back to just
2 billion dollars but it was enough to
double weworks valuation again to 47
billion
so at 47 billion which is a little bit
of an illusory number it's not real but
that put we work in the very top tier of
high-valued young startups so the
reaction from a lot of the real estate
world was wow that's crazy in part
because there's a company that trades in
the UK called iwg used to be known as
Regis it trades at a fraction of that
and people were looking at that company
which is profitable and we work which is
not and wondering what the gig is why
people didn't understand or what
SoftBank maybe knew that they didn't and
that's because in many measurable areas
like Global square footage members
locations countries revenue and profit
iwg is either similar or much higher
than wework except of course for one
area valuation where rework was valued
nearly 13 times higher than iwg we of
course
looked at that every single day and said
what are we missing is there something
that we're not doing is there something
that we're missing is there an
ingredient
that sort of there that we are missing
out on that we can add into what we're
doing but um we never found it
after getting these investments from
SoftBank and license to spend quickly
that's just what wework did opening more
and more offices around the world making
investments in a variety of different
companies and even opening an elementary
school in New York City
it's almost stuff of Legend right now
how recklessly we will expand its money
on things from a company that makes wave
pools
to a company that makes superfoods led
by a guy that Adam met while he was
surfing
you know when you see a startup that's
in the commercial real estate sector
investing in an indoor wave pool company
and in a children's school you know
something has gone wrong but just how
wrong wouldn't be fully realized until
wework announced in August of 2019 that
it would file for a public offering it
was the first time since a bond offering
last year that investors were able to
peel back the curtain and see into the
company's financial performance read its
metrics see its growth I got up really
early and was was reading it and I
remember
um you know on my way into the office
and it was still dark outside and there
was a small line and just a couple lines
about how Adam Newman the CEO he had
personally purchased the trademark to
the word we
and it sold that back to his own company
for 5.9 million dollars
and I looked at that and I thought
that's kind of weird this was just one
of many examples of how the corporate
leadership including Adam Newman
seemed to find Opportunities to enrich
themselves at the expense of
shareholders and at the expense of the
company the filings also showed in just
the first six months of 2019 wework lost
690 million dollars bringing its total
losses to almost 3 billion dollars in
the past three years
things start changing rapidly investors
are telling we work in its Bankers you
know what this isn't for us people are
throwing out numbers as low as 12
potentially even as low as 10 billion
all these things that raised a few red
flags
um just started kind of added fuel to
the fire of this discussion of is this
company ready to go public it just
doesn't feel like it has the controls in
place that you would expect of a public
company that needs to protect the value
for shareholders on September 17th we
work officially pushed back it's much
awaited initial public offering we have
decided to postpone our IPO to focus on
our Core Business the fundamentals of
which remain strong the board and in
particular SoftBank its biggest investor
decide that there needs to be a big
change it needs to come from the top and
that Adam is now more of a liability
toward the company than he is an asset
on September the 24th he resigns saying
too much Focus has been placed on me he
realized he was a distraction to the
company in a vote with all board
directors of which he was one he
actually voted against himself remaining
as CEO two senior wework Executives
Sebastian gunningham and Artie minson
were appointed as co-ceos among their
housekeeping items Sal Newman's 60
million dollar private jet put multiple
wework Acquisitions up for sale
postponed the IPO indefinitely close
down we grow the company's private
elementary school and lay off thousands
of employees
we reported that the co-ceos ADI minson
and Sebastian gunningham have secured
themselves multi-million dollar
Severance packages at a time when the
company doesn't even have enough cash to
pay Severance to its thousands of rank
and file employees that it plans to lay
off have you ever heard of anything like
that before a company not being able to
afford to fire their employees I haven't
have you SoftBank would ultimately bail
wework out injecting a much needed 9.5
billion into the company which now is
valued at less than 8 billion dollars
now that SoftBank has bailed out wework
I think the overarching sense is one of
uncertainty for everyone who's involved
in this company you know when I've
talked to ex employees from wework they
often feel pretty drained by The
Experience they felt like they came in
drinking the Kool-Aid thinking wework
was going to change the world and make
everyone more connected and help people
do what they love and by the time they
left they felt like they hadn't really
been valued and that and that the
company was kind of all over the place
and and they felt worn out
there are some cautionary notes for
every other young company the running
the business in a completely
unprofitable manner the lack of board
oversight that there was no adults in
the room saying no and so I think what
happened at wework is a sign that you
can only run a company
without guard rails for so long I mean I
think it's basically a shocker for
everyone I don't think anyone's seen
anything quite this big and this strange
go down but for those of us in tech
there is great precedent for a
transformational change getting underway
and then a bunch of the early folks sort
of flopping I mean there was a time that
eBay was 10 times bigger than Amazon now
Amazon's 50 times bigger than eBay there
was a time that Myspace was the only
social network now the only one is
Facebook those kind of reversals happen
quite regularly and so it's not really a
surprise that the first Mouse to chase
the cheese is the one that got caught in
the Trap I think that's roughly what
happened at wework I think we work as
sort of both a little bit of an outlier
in this era of Technology startups but
also kind of the perfect encapsulation
of what this era of sort of easy money
and no rules has delivered in in startup
land
[Music]
assess the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions scrams or industry
buildings electricity all of those
things everything you need to know about
our changing environment the politics of
global warming we can and we will deal
with climate change in the fight against
climate change when we're green as you
cut
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
I've been covering this trade War for
almost three years now and oftentimes it
you know looks very chaotic the China
trade deal is dependent on one thing do
I want to make it if we don't make a
deal with China I'll just raise the
tariffs even higher thank you very much
and it's really hard to think back to
the beginning of it but how it really
started actually seemed like there was a
strategy to it over the course of the
U.S China trade War Trump's aggressive
policies and unpredictable Behavior has
managed to bring the Chinese to the
negotiating table we've come to a very
substantial
phase one deal China will continue to
eat your lunch unless somebody takes a
stand and it just so happens that it was
Donald Trump that took the stand we're
close with the promise of that phase one
deal looming on the horizon can that
same aggressive strategy produce
meaningful reform in China I wrote a
paper during the Obama Administration
saying people are not taking China
seriously enough and the president has
to be directly involved for American
policy to actually make sense I think in
some ways it's better to wait till after
the election with China but I'm not
going to say that I just think that now
the president's directly involved and
American policy doesn't make sense the
reality is that the Trump Administration
has done this in a much more aggressive
way than previous administrations have
it was an asset going into this trade
War it may have been a liability in the
end this this is a case study of when
negotiating tactics turn from method to
Madness we can't continue to allow
Dinah to rape our country and that's
what they're doing it the greatest theft
in the history of the world president
Trump ran a successful campaign of
denouncing China's unfair trading
practices they take our money they take
our jobs and we owe them 1.6 trillion
dollars I think it's important to
understand that the president inherited
a very difficult situation one where we
probably should have addressed some of
these problems with China a lot sooner
but I think the president had great
wisdom and courage to step up and
realize that we really can start to make
progress and after becoming president
his team began devising a strategy on
how they could rebalance the
relationship with China and this man
Derek scissors was part of those initial
conversations the goal starts with we're
going to focus on intellectual property
which we were trying to decide how do we
get the Chinese to reduce their
intellectual property coercion and theft
they weren't going to stop but how can
we reduce it how can we show we're
serious about this issue change their
behavior and that got pulled into the
president saying I want High tariffs I
want to reduce the trade deficit which
is a completely different goal putting
tariffs on all firms doesn't discourage
theft and coercion of intellectual
property because it doesn't punish the
guilty it punishes everyone tariffs are
really the big bazooka in in in the
trade world you don't like to use them
normally or if you do use them in in the
trade well you tend to use them as for
short-term uh leverage to try and get
someone to the negotiating table
in March 2018 Ambassador lighthizer the
trade representative was testifying on
Capitol Hill and he was kind of laying
out what he called an algorithm the
purpose of your algorithm is to pick out
things to the extent you can that are in
that category things that are in the
category have had the maximum effect on
on China and the minimum effect on U.S
consumers the initial number that Folks
at the U.S trade representative's office
came up with was 34 billion dollars and
the president looks at it and says well
that's not big enough and we've seen
this a lot in our reporting covering
this trade war that the president really
likes round numbers a second list of 16
billion dollars of Chinese Goods is
published raising the total initial
tariffs to 50 billion dollars and while
looking back this may seem haphazard it
is part of President Trump's strategy
and this is just the beginning I want to
tell you that this is just the beginning
Donald Trump has always had two things
he's tried to accomplished it through
these trade Wars one is selling it
domestically to his base he wants to be
seen to be punching China in the nose
and the second thing is his old art of
the deal approach and that is he he
likes to destabilize people across the
negotiating table this Administration
has kind of prided itself on being
unpredictable kind of the notion that
unpredictability is a real strength in a
negotiation because if they don't know
what you're going to do somehow they're
going to give you more but not everyone
agrees with that sentiment at least in
regards to the larger intent of getting
a deal done with China to me they
haven't been unpredictable at all I
think the president has been saying for
two and a half years that he wants to
have a deal with China if he can get a
deal that is good and that is in U.S
interests and he's gotten a deal with
Korea and he's got to deal with Mexico
and he's got to deal with Canada and
he's gotten a deal with Japan and we're
having these negotiations with China
early on the maximum pressure strategy
only resulted in the Chinese responding
with tariffs of their own going after
after areas that could hurt Trump's
political base imposing tariffs on the
Auto industry pork and especially
soybeans
once the Chinese stop buying soybeans
the impact in the markets was pretty
Stark immediately the price collapsed
and Farmers started getting ahead so
when you engage in this you know
tit-for-tat tariff War the question is
really who can live with the pain
for longer
and obviously that is a question of
political will
and that's always going to be the case
and there's sort of No Way Around that
I've you know fortunately for US
president Trump has shown that he has
that political will for the rest of 2018
the two countries would raise tariffs
back and forth the U.S would go from its
initial 50 billion in tariffs to 250
billion and China's total tariffs would
now hit 110 billion of U.S Goods
eventually these tariffs would have
their desired effect in December of 2018
president Trump and Chinese president Xi
Jinping would meet face to face in
Buenos Aires
startup meeting we'll be talking about a
number of topics at that dinner in
Buenos Aires the two leaders agree that
they won't raise tariffs on each other
anymore or at least for 90 days while
they try to negotiate a new deal
over the spring the two sides keep
negotiating but the Trump Administration
seems to be moving the goal posts or at
least that's how the Chinese see it one
they refuse to lift tariffs as part of
any deal and secondly Trump seems to be
constantly increasing the amount of
purchases he wants to see from China at
one point he goes from 1.2 trillion
dollars over six years to a two trillion
dollar number and that just seems both
impetuous to the Chinese but also
economically impossible by April the two
sides create a 150 page document and
there's optimism that a deal is in sight
and you know the White House was very
confident that this you know tough
negotiating strategy from from the
president has really you know turned out
to get results and fix the issues that
they went into the straight War for my
understanding is that both sides were
actually discussing where the leaders
would meet to sign the agreement however
in the final stages of negotiating the
Chinese began to walk back some of their
larger concessions most importantly
China didn't want to commit to making
legal changes for the U.S and I think
what happened here is that China thought
that Trump wanted a deal at any cost and
that he was so out there promising this
deal that he wouldn't mind if they took
some things off the table that's the
point where I think the president kind
of got fed up and the events in the
negotiations led to a entirely
disproportionate response on his part in
a tweet on May 5th Trump suddenly raised
tariffs on the existing 250 billion
dollars worth of goods and also
threatened that he would tax the
remaining 325 billion dollars worth of
Chinese Imports
that tweet I read on a plane I was like
okay I'm going to buy Wi-Fi now and I
worked the entire plane ride over there
Days Later Trump again escalated the
dispute by placing Chinese Telecom giant
Huawei on a blacklist that was the
biggest slap in the face for the Chinese
yet and relations further deteriorated
where
many many decades but in another
face-to-face meeting this time in Osaka
Japan Trump and XI were able to
negotiate another truce on further
aggression so covering this we often
have Deja vu's and you know think well
we've seen this movie before they have a
truce
it goes on for you know a couple months
until Trump realizes China again didn't
live up to its promises and that's when
Trump Unleashed another series of tweets
so in early August Trump decides to
escalate things again and announces that
he is going to put tariffs on the
remaining imports from China importantly
it's also for the first time really
going to hit consumers it's going to hit
things like smartphones toys kids
clothes
and this is the first time that the
trade Wars are really going to come home
for a lot of Americans
after a year and a half of all this
madness
Trump's advisors
re-elected you have to stop this now we
need to find an off-ramp and so they
came to him for the first time in
September and said why don't we pocket
some of these wins why don't we get
something good for farmers and do
something like a partial deal the August
tariff threats were split up and the
ones that would hit consumer favorites
were given a December 15th deadline with
the hopes that a deal could be struck by
the end of the year a tremendous deal
for the farmers a purchase of from 40 to
50 billion dollars worth of agricultural
products it's actually hard as someone
who's been following this for several
years to really care about the phase one
deal agriculture is not going to solve
the trade imbalance it's not going to
bring back U.S manufacturing jobs for
this year if you sign phase one you
don't side phase one your doesn't matter
you're not going to get any meaningful
economic changes from the Chinese in
2019 or 2020.
one of the big questions around this
trade war is was it worth it the real
question is are we going to get future
phases in a negotiation and are you
going to get some meaningful changes in
China and a lot of people in Washington
certainly a lot of long-time China
Watchers feel like that's not the case
if I think we're finally having serious
negotiations with China after many years
of frustration and I think I think
everyone has finally started to realize
that we have actual leverage in this
situation and that we have the
opportunity to improve the the type of
trade Arrangements that we have with
China
20 months and many false Dawns later
what have we learned about the use of
this maximum pressure campaign and can
this strategy of unpredictability really
work over the long term just so you
understand I've been very mild about it
very very mild there's a long way I can
go I think number one this just shows
the trade negotiations are tough and one
of the kind of you know shortcomings of
this negotiation has been we've kind of
been all over the map I mean at some
points this negotiation has been all
about agriculture other points it's been
all about these structural issues like
IPR the main problem the president has
is he wants us to wrap up too quickly
president wants this done now he wants
to run on it he wants to say I solved
this problem so because of that he has
lost patience with the pace of
negotiations and he's fine with the
outcome of very high U.S tariffs that's
one thing everyone has to understand the
president doesn't think oh I'll pressure
the Chinese and they'll automatically
give in he thinks I'll pressure them and
they'll give in or I'll get to keep the
tariffs and the trade deficit will fall
both are good for me
dollars and we're giving some of that
money to Farmers and others
now that President Trump is on the cusp
of signing a phase one deal will his
willingness to use tariffs really lead
to the fundamental economic changes he
is seeking from China if you want to be
a good negotiator some element of
unpredictability is useful but I think
here we've gotten to the point where
we're so unpredictable that other
countries are kind of throwing up their
hands and trying to decide is it even
real is it even worth doing a deal with
the United States because we don't even
know if the United States is going to
stick to the deal
I mean I think you have to remember that
you know two or three years ago we were
being told that the U.S had very little
leverage in in trade negotiations and
there really wasn't a lot we could do to
get other countries to accommodate Our
concern the reality of it is is that
countries understand that this is the
biggest economy in the world it's a
great Market it's an open market and I
think people are always going to be
interested in making uh trade with the
United States it's fair to say that
tariffs brought the Chinese to the table
but what have we gotten out of it and
this gets back to not so much the tool
tariffs but the strategy if we don't
know our own goals it's very hard to
have a win at the end
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our generation's biggest problem climate
change is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions transport industry
buildings electricity all of those
things everything you need to know about
our changing environment the politics of
global warming we can and we will deal
with climate change in the fight against
climate change when we're green has you
covered
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
movement first took off and we were
getting women coming forward and telling
their stories of harassment assault or
discrimination in their workplace
we're like this is the only matter of
time before we get some really good
stories coming out of the financial
industry because we know that it exists
Wall Street just like lots of areas has
some serious and pretty deep problems
but uh you know a big cultural moment uh
has not happened now to the metoo
movement growing this morning in the
wake of the Harvey Weinstein Scandal
high-powered men across entertainment
media technology and politics have been
brought down by women who felt empowered
to tell their stories
but on Wall Street a system of Silence
has protected the status quo the primary
difference for women on Wall Street
versus other Industries is money and
money is power and Wall Street has the
most money and the most power of any
industry in a story by story it's like
we get this peak into this machine you
know different arms of the machine those
arms explain why there was no revolution
in finance this year instead there were
rare moments of Revelation that pierced
the silence keeping people quiet doesn't
make it better for the business you
don't hire the best people if you
exclude people who are brave
this is the story of the forces that
have kept the metoo Reckoning from
hitting Wall Street at least so far
women didn't want to come forward with
their stories they didn't want to go on
the record women I talked to actually
didn't even want to name the people that
had assaulted them or hurt their careers
in a particular way and we kind of had
to take a step back and say why is that
happening and evaluate what is the
culture in Wall Street or the system in
Wall Street that's keeping women from
doing that you know there is a machine
of Silence that we've learned about that
has to do with arbitration and human
resources and public relations and a
culture of fear and a culture of money
and all those things together combined
to create kind of a wall between
allegations and transparency first of
all you have this very male-dominated
industry about 26 of senior Executives
on Wall Street are women and that and
when you get to the CEO level it's it's
abysmally low women only make up eight
percent of CEOs at Major financial
institutions
and in the history of Wall Street no
woman has ever LED any of the six
largest U.S banks
I remember Wall Street women saying to
me you know what do you think Wall
Street values they value relationships
and they value secrecy and they value
loyalty and if I dare to go against
those things I will be exiled and if
someone does decide to complain it isn't
done in public but rather hidden behind
a widespread system of arbitration
arbitration needs to be relabeled it
needs to be called forced silence
arbitration is a private system that
takes fights behind closed doors away
from a judge and jury it was originally
used to solve industry disputes but Wall
Street has helped it spread to all kinds
of fights including harassment civil
rights issues
should be dealt with in court civil
rights issues should be transparent
that's Lee Stoll a Wall Street veteran
who's suing Canter Fitzgerald for
harassment discrimination and
retaliation but that's just a part of
her fight she's also battling to stay
away from arbitration
I want to go to court because I want it
to be transparent it's not a female
thing it's not a male thing it's a human
thing what's so wild for us as reporters
following the least old story is that
she had not one but apparently two
arbitration agreements Cantor says so
basically she said yeah I can't I I am
not supposed to be thrown out of court
I'm supposed to stay in this venue and
the court agreed with her Cantor denies
her allegations and is appealing the
decision to let her stay in court but
these days judges all the way up to the
Supreme Court have been siding with
arbitration
from wall Street's perspective that
system is quicker cheaper quieter and
just as Fair as going to court women
like Lee see it differently for those of
us who are not corporations we want to
be able to show the evidence and we want
to be able to change Behavior women are
not learning about each other they're
being isolated from each other so they
can't really come together and bring
something bigger against a bank or an
institution and say you have a major
problem here because it's all in this
hush-hush system that nobody knows about
while Lee was fighting against
arbitration women thousands of miles
away were struggling to have their
stories heard inside Lloyds of London
Lloyd's is a 331 year old exchange for
the Worldwide Insurance Market that
steeped in Tradition
[Music]
a book for the current day and a
corresponding book from 100 years ago
much of the work there is still done
Face to Face by mostly middle-aged white
men on paper and sealed with rubber
stamps but reporting from Bloomberg
uncovered that Lloyd's also has a deep
seated tradition of sexual harassment we
spoke to women who had been attacked by
their bosses in in pubs in taxis you
know we'd spoken to other women who were
deluged with texts graphic texts graphic
emails from their employers basically
soliciting for sex what's so Sinister
about these stories isn't just the
picture they paint of Rich Men Behaving
Badly but the way HR protected them at
least in my experience for the Wall
Street firms most of the time say that
they simply can't go to HR it's just not
an option
because if they do HR is then going to
report them to either the exact mail
that they just complained about or
somebody else in a position to make
things difficult but if the ones who did
go to HR they reported being discouraged
from pursuing their complaints further
they were warned about the possibility
of being marked out as uh difficult
women so kept quiet Lloyd's first female
CEO Inga Beale tried to change that but
she was met with hostility including a
death threat and was eventually replaced
by John Neal in 2018. Bloomberg's
reporting hit a few months later two
Executives at the company have now
resigned following allegations of sexual
harassment you know sometimes when we're
reporting on stories like this you know
companies just deny what we find and say
look everything is fine in the case of
Lloyd's Gavin's reporting was so
powerful that the CEO of this insurance
Market came out afterwards and said yeah
this is pretty much unacceptable and we
will change this is not the Lloyds that
I want to be part of and not the Lloyds
that many of my colleagues feel they
want to be part of either Lloyd's
unveiled a whistleblower hotline banned
alcohol and announced a lifetime ban for
sexual harassers whether there is any
long-term impact from these measures
it's too early I think to tell
and while the Lloyd story showed how
women's stories can help bring an
Antiquated institution into the 21st
century a conference in California
showed what happens when the industry's
bystanders break their silence hey
everyone it's Alex shalakian just got
back from the Tiburon CEO Summit dinner
in October of 2019 Alex chalakian who
runs a firm called Lake Avenue Financial
was attending a conference and did
something unheard of on Wall Street he
publicly spoke out against someone at an
invite-only conference
things that were said by Ken Fisher were
just absolutely horrifying he made
comments about genitalia talked about
picking up on a girl uh and don't show
them what's in your pants and shortly
after Bloomberg reporter Sabrina Wilmer
was able to speak to Ken Fisher on the
phone his initial reaction is that he
didn't think it was a big deal because
he's been saying this a very long time
and nobody has questioned it Ken Fisher
was speaking in a way that he was used
to speaking which was gross quite
frankly I don't know if I could but if I
was 30 years old and I had to do over
again I'd have more sex
well like while I could while I could
once you get older you know once you get
older you know you're like a Christmas
tree you know you're you're firm once a
year and the balls are just for
decoration
but instead of awkward laughter behind
closed doors this year Fisher's
institutional clients from Texas to New
Hampshire yanked about four billion
dollars from his investment firm Fisher
CEO Damien ornani even went directly in
front of a Los Angeles pension board to
apologize
[Music]
but for pension board members like Brian
Pendleton that apology wasn't enough I'm
incredibly proud of what the LA Police
and Fire pension commission did by
decisively terminating the contract with
Ken Fisher that I hopefully sends a loud
message to the financial Community while
about 4 billion dollars was lost the
firm still manages 115 billion dollars
and the company has said that since the
incident their assets have actually
grown
and we talk to each other inside The
Newsroom and we ask is this is much
change as we're going to see it's
plausible that this is as far from the
status quo as things are going to Veer
and things will get back to business as
usual I'm not in favor of outing other
women
but I will say that women have reached
out to me and told me that
we need to keep this going I'm not I'm
certainly the a drop in the bucket to
the issue and the only way to change
that is for a couple people to stand up
and I'm hopeful that other people will
stand next to me
we're never going to stop trying to tell
women's stories what we can hope for is
that the industry is moving in a
direction in which more women feel
comfortable telling their stories
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
's biggest problem climate change is
happening and the world's most
innovative solutions trams or industry
buildings electricity all of those
things everything you need to know about
our changing environment the politics of
global warming we can and we will deal
with climate change in the fight against
climate change when we're green as you
covered
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
imagining a pool of Middle Eastern Oil
money the size of a U.S budget for
public transportation and education
combined and all of that money is
entrusted to a Japanese businessman who
constantly talks about starting some
kind of a revolution that's basically a
vision Fund in a nutshell
for us in the media who cover vision
fund daily it's kind of easy to forget
how insane and unusual this whole thing
is it was kind of a shocker when
masioshi-san announced the vision fund
and his plans to raise 100 billion
dollars to invest in the tech space it's
the largest technology investment fund
ever 100 billion dollars well that was
something Equity to buy things man
that's a lot it made bets on a spectrum
of startups from AI to ride sharing apps
two of division fund's biggest
Investments Uber and wework causing
investors to wonder if masa's Vision
fund is starting to show some cracks
SoftBank the Japanese corporation that
runs the controversial Vision fund
reported a record operating profit last
year with the vision fund as its best
performer but bad Investments and the
global pandemic have changed everything
in May the vision fund reported a 17
billion dollar loss contributing to the
biggest loss in softbank's history
division fund at this point has lost
more money for South Bank than made
[Music]
[Applause]
is a very impressive entrepreneur from
Japan U.S educated actually got an
engineering degree at the University of
California Berkeley started a few
companies while in school by the time he
moved back to Japan in his early 20s he
had all these business projects going
built up his Empire from there
he is willing to take risks a lot of
risks including in the first.com boom
and bust around 2000 he placed a big bet
on Alibaba and almost everything he had
got wiped out except Alibaba at the
bottom of the crash
I actually revived my spirits of the
fighting you know so I thought it was
good
soft pink is now one of the biggest
companies in the world it's a
conglomerate they have lots of interests
in Mobile phones and they started this
investment fund a few years ago with a
rival of vision funds South Main group
was dramatically reshaped it was
reshaped as a holding company with
investing at its Core Business now as to
what's son's Vision I mean I think he
has a really Keen sense of these
cresting ways of technological change
and he wants SoftBank to be the company
that not only survives these sort of
cataclysms but also emerges as a key
player and key investor and the
companies who will go on to to run the
world so when you told people you were
going to raise 100 billion dollar fund
did they tell you you were a little
crazy
well some people said
[Music]
the thing about softbank's Vision fund
is it was bigger Bolder grander than
anyone had ever seen before suffix
itself is a big investor but it's
biggest investor by far is the public
investment fund of Saudi Arabia you had
a meeting with a man who was the deputy
Crown Prince of Saudi Arabia who's now
the Crown Prince of Saudi Arabia and as
I understand the story you went in and
in one hour you convinced him to invest
45 billion dollars
no no it's not true okay
45 minutes 45 billion dollars okay sorry
one billion dollars per minute it
certainly wasn't as controversial until
late 2018 when the Washington Post
journalist khashoggi was murdered by
Saudi agents and that suddenly put a
spotlight on softbank's dependency on
Saudi money truth be told it didn't seem
to have stopped a lot of companies from
taking their money I think the amazing
part of the vision fund story was how
quickly it all came together from the
first talk of the idea to raising the
money to spending the money it's been
just a couple of years
so as of last count there were 88
portfolio companies a division fund more
than 10 billion dollars was invested in
DD a Chinese right hailing app Uber took
about 7.7 billion some 4 billion dollars
went into wework another three into grab
a Southeast Asian ride hailing company
did anybody even thinking of competing
with you just looks at the size of your
checkbook and gets scared and doesn't
even try and he does seem to have a
particular weakness for a very
charismatic and very flashy Founders and
you know Adam Newman of wework is a
prime example I mean son himself loves
to talk about Jack ma the founder of
Alibaba his best investment today he had
no business plan but his eyes was very
strong strong eyes he wants his Founders
to be the next Jack ma to be crazier
than the craziest guy in the room
the vision fund I mean let's not forget
they've had some successes they were a
big investor in Flipkart an Indian
retailer that they sold they've had some
companies that have ipo'd unfortunately
there are some high profile Investments
that have just lost tons of money we
work being the prime example
they aren't making any money they're far
from making money no one really quite
understands the business model according
to people with knowledge of the the
discussion SoftBank is concerned about
the valuation that wework could get in
the public market when we work IPO so
spectacularly imploded SoftBank
essentially had to step in and pretty
much buy the company they came up with a
9.5 billion dollar rescue package and
now own about 80 percent of the startup
which essentially makes it their problem
to make them profitable they had a
fairly you know credible plan for how
this could happen
time will solve the wework problem we'll
make money once the wework building
portfolio is allowed to ripen how
stop the new building developments and
the profitability will drastically
improve and we can expect the cost to go
down by half or even more
wework declined to comment for this
video about softbank's investment in the
company
there are some bits that are digest in
retrospect seem silly you know for
example Zoom the company that wanted to
make robot pizza and then pivot it to
revolutionizing the food industry and
eventually basically crashed and burned
probably the best example of a sort of
self-inflicted injury is is oil this is
a company that came out of India created
a platform for hotels where people could
book a room and expect a reliable
service which was a considerable feat
for India and their targets seem to have
been just the raw number of rooms
available on their platform that is of
lost count they had over 1 million rooms
but they were nowhere near profitability
it's a prime example of the kind of
growth at all costs that does come with
vision fund money that could take a a
good company and a good business idea
and essentially ruin it SoftBank has
declined to comment on its investment
strategy
despite some large and high profile
losses the vision fund actually seemed
to be doing okay last year SoftBank said
that based on its analysis of the
companies in the vision funds portfolio
the fund was making money
but then 2020 happened
and Mark's close
gig economy including Uber Lyft doordash
Postmates and more are facing a host of
challenges relating to the virus
outbreak
a lot of
company been hit so hard by this
pandemic so Uber is one of those it's
had to lay off a lot of people another
company in a similar position is oil
covid-19 is certainly going to be a
death blow for a lot of companies on on
Vision funds portfolio son himself has
said that about 15 of them will go uh
bust but son still has confidence in the
fund's bigger companies
large size investees are surviving and
actually doing study they have a better
chance going through this Valley of
coronavirus the exception is we were we
made a mistake in investing in wework
and I'd admitted that several times I
was foolish and made the wrong decision
you know I guess some of the vision
funds investment practices have made it
uniquely vulnerable to the to the covet
pandemic in part their heavy exposure to
ride hailing they invested in all the
top companies and it's by far the
biggest segment the fact that their
companies are Geared for high growth and
not necessarily profitability
SoftBank group says it's Vision fund
lost 17.7 billion dollars in its last
fiscal year that's after writing down
the cost of bad Investments the vision
fund went from softbank's biggest profit
maker a year ago to its biggest drag on
earnings Envision two I don't know seems
like an uphill battle for sure
I think the real takeaway from the
vision fund is the money really can't
buy success that all of that cash the
huge checks that masayashi-sung was
cutting were actually hurting the
founders and the companies he was
investing in more than they were helping
at first it looks like having all that
money allowed them to burn cash longer
to beat other companies to survive
longer but the problem is that they were
hiring a lot they didn't have fiscal
discipline and so in the end all he was
doing was creating bigger bigger bubbles
that were bursting and collapsing at a
much grander scale in these past few
months someone often stood on stage and
said that he's learned the lesson but
he's actually quite short on details the
lesson he seemed to have learned is that
investing in wework was a mistake it not
at all clear if he learned the lesson of
the kind of hyper growth the vision fund
has promoted
that's what's
seasonal stopped him he's so determined
he's so stubborn he's got such
incredible self-confidence that really
is his greatest gift he's an incredible
showman but at some point there is going
to be a reality
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
's biggest problem climate change is
happening and the world's most
innovative solutions transport industry
uh buildings electricity all of those
things everything you need to know about
our changing environment the politics of
global warming we can and we will deal
with climate change in the fight against
climate change Bloomberg green has you
covered
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
coming up on quick Take the Lead soaring
into space Jeff Bezos and blue origin
successfully complete their mission but
what's next for the commercial of manned
space flight we'll have a live report
from Van Horn Texas
then fear over the Delta variant is real
and it's hitting Silicon Valley giant
Tech employer Apple says it's delaying
its workers from returning to the office
so while other employers follow suit
and from the office to the open road car
prices are soaring as a result of the
pandemic economy and it's not just brand
new models we're going to tell you
what's driving up used car costs as well
it's Tuesday July 20th I'm Madison Mills
my co-host Scarlet Pooh is off today
we're gonna have those stories and more
coming up for you right here on quick
Take the Lead
[Laughter]
we start the show tonight with breaking
news x-trump Ally Tom Barrick is under
arrest and charged with illegally
lobbying the United Arab Emirates what
we know so far is that he's charged with
obstruction of justice and making false
statements Barrick is the founder of
colony capital and a former top
fundraiser for Donald Trump he was
arrested in California today so we're
going to get this put into perspective
for us by Bloomberg News editor at large
Eric schatzker who previously spoke at
length of Tom Barrick not related to
this arrest today but in other
interviews Eric thank you so much for
joining us live by phone let's Jump
Right In Here what do we know hi Eric
what do we know from today's breaking
news so far what can you tell us about
these charges
well we know that that Tom Barrack is
accused of effectively lobbying
illegally on behalf of the United Arab
Emirates and that's very interesting
because Tom Barrack has long-standing
ties
to to leaders throughout the Middle East
and has spoken very favorably about
Muhammad bin Zaya the Crown Prince of
Abu Dhabi of the de facto leader of the
United Arab Emirates and and as you were
just saying uh not only have I
interviewed Tom Barrack on a number of
occasions I actually sat down with him
last week a week ago today
to talk about his new investing business
um of which he was very excited
and
we spoke specifically about his plans to
raise money from uh emiratis as
co-investors for deals he wanted to do
in the hospitality